uh
good morning everybody um
it's now 10 o'clock and
[Music]
open
everybody hear me
and
see me okay
you just set your arms up stand up good
thank you
my name is david cliff and i'm a
chartered town planner and i've been
appointed by the secretary of state to
hold this inquiry and to determine uh
the appeal
the inquiries into an appeal made by
gladman developments limited under
section 78 of the town country planning
act 1990 against the decision of
district council to refuse outline
planning permission
i see there's a hand up
there's something you want all right
you're here
just in my life all right
all right okay sorry
you didn't have okay you can hear okay
yes thank you very much good okay thank
you i shall i shall continue against the
decision of the phallic district council
to refuse outline planning permission
for the erection of up to 450
residential dwellings including market
and affordable housing structural
planting and landscaping formal informal
public open space and children's play
area sustainable urban drainage with
vehicle access points including
associated ancillary works and
operations from hearthstone road shutter
down road and manson road at land on the
north west and southeast sides of
shotenton road in margate
details of access are proposed as part
of the application with matters of
design landscaping layout and scale
being reserved matters for future
consideration
uh
i'll come to this little detail of the
event management shortly
but kind of probably to help with things
like bandwidth and to make sure we get
good reception we can hear everybody and
see everybody that needs to speak if
when you're not speaking or not part of
a discussion if you can turn off your
microphone and also your
cameras it's great at the start actually
to see you all so i can see all the
faces but we'll probably get to a
situation where we have other celebrity
squares or i can't hear or see anybody
because there'll be so many people so if
we can all turn off our microphones and
cameras and obviously put them on
uh when you wish to
speak and i'll come back to more of the
detail about uh how things will pan out
in terms of event management
in a moment
these m these opening remarks are my
introductory uh preliminary remarks uh
they may go on for a little while but
there's quite a lot of important things
i need to set out at the start of the
inquiry and you'll have an opportunity
to ask questions as i go and if you wish
to ask a question
if you can use the raise
hand
function which i've just hopefully
used this actually is a new system for
me so i've used microsoft teams
zoom various other things but not this
one but it seems pretty similar in
functionality to what i hope we or most
of us are are used to
now uh we'll move on to
appearances so i can make sure that
everybody is here and
uh everyone can introduce themselves to
me
if i can start
with
appellant
and
i believe mr williams is the appellant
uh council if you'd like to introduce
yourself
then
please thank you sir my name is guy
williams
i'm a barrister
i'm instructed by chris ball
um of gladman development limited
and so
i will be calling five
witnesses
um and i think it will be in in this
order given the program that you've set
out
mr matthew travis
who deals with flooding and drainage
matters
mr claire caught miss claire caldwell
who deals with ecology and biodiversity
matters
rosie meera
who deals with heritage matters
and then mr edmund
dealing with viability
and mr chris ball dealing with planning
planning policy planning balance
okay thank you welcome everybody and
thank you for that introduction mr
williams and if i can turn now
to
the council and
i understand it's uh
mr ux and qc who's representing the
council
yes good morning sir my as you say it's
william upton qc instructed by estelle
culligan who's the director of law and
democracy at phanet district council
in a sense we have we have two witnesses
i say in a sense because there's one uh
witness with the proof and that's mr vic
hester who's dealing with viability and
planning issues relating to the reasons
for refusal
but as it's just been mentioned a number
of witnesses dealing with other issues
and when it comes to things such as
heritage habitats and flooding at the
round table it's going to be in
livingston who's the planning
application manager
who will be able to contribute on behalf
of the
council um he's also the person will
deal with uh things like planning
conditions and the sil compliance so
there isn't a proof of evidence from him
but he's basically able to speak to the
various statements that have been
submitted so just to reassure people
they're not missing a document it's just
that he's going to be stepping up to
deal with those issues whereas mr hester
is dealing with the reasons for refusal
so i hope that's clear
thank you yes i understand and i'm sure
it'll be helpful
uh for me and everybody to have mr
livingstone as part of those discussions
as well so thank you for that just so i
can make sure i get the name right the
person that you were instructed by can
you just repeat that yes estelle
culligan it's estelle
e-s-t-e-l-e and culligan c-u-l-l-i-g-a-n
and let's say she's director of law and
democracy at the council right thank you
okay thank you
and
we have a
rule six party with us today samson ward
residents association
and
uh rowan dickman um i am the vice chair
of the summit award residents
association
uh we brought the rule six
um we had intended to uh provide one
witness however we felt that as that was
replicating very much um tdc's approach
and you did have the report uh given our
finite budget we've opted not to bring
uh that witness so it'd be basically
uh reading from this statement and
indeed supporting tdc's approach to this
right i understand so just to clarify
because i got this email yesterday i
think from your yourself is that
yes it's not it's myself primarily yes
okay and your witness who was going to
uh give evidence on
viability military mr martinez was going
to give evidence on viability but we
felt that as it was really just
reinforcing tdc's stance uh to save that
time and indeed to be honest with you
with our finite budget we
opted not to call on the stores
okay i understand just so i completely
understand the situation
am i right saying it sounds like this is
the case that you're not
you haven't certainly said that we've
drawn your your argument on all sides
and housing it's that you the army said
would be obviously would be outlining
that in our statement
right okay
thank you and
obviously you'll also have an
opportunity to take part as you wish as
will other interested parties in the
other discussions roundtable discussions
etc that we have today
obviously because your witnesses sort of
withdrawn the
proof of evidence so to speak you won't
get the opportunity
to cross-examine
the uh appellate's witness as you
otherwise would do although i think you
would still get the opportunity to ask
questions of them as would any other
interested party today i really
appreciate that sir yes okay
okay thank you is everybody else clear
on that on that position
yeah
mr williams
thank you sir that's how i had
understood the position and you'll be
aware obviously that mr cordrey's proof
of evidence
um already deals with a number of the
points made by mr orst
and say we're happy that you have
the ability to
um
understand our case fully in response to
that i will
as that mr dickman will be aware i will
make submissions about weight that may
be given to evidence in circumstances
where it hasn't been
available to be tested
but i only make that point for clarity
at the outset i don't take any objection
to the to the evidence remaining before
the inquiry
i understand
[Music]
thank you
okay
so moving
along i've got a list of
other speakers that i've been told who
wish to speak maybe some of the ones as
well
and this is in
no particular order this is the order
that i have been
being given but firstly the west gate
and guardians action group and i think
it's a jacqueline brown who wishes to
speak on their behalf
yes i want to read out a summary of the
statement from westgate and garland's
action group for you
okay thank you and just so i make sure
i uh
introduce you appropriately uh
miss ms mrs how would you like to be mrs
okay
thank you
and i'm assuming from what i've read
that all the other interested parties
are
opposing
the
uh
development and on which basis i'll
assume that is the case unless you tell
me or somebody tells me otherwise
yes that's correct
okay
um
i should also add that
if
you anybody wishes to speak
there will be an opportunity
for the appellant and myself to ask any
questions
unless you particularly sort of don't
want that to be and if so say so but
obviously
a little bit by mr williams if you if
you allow yourself to ask questions
obviously
that allows a sort of degree of scrutiny
that can sort of affect the sort of the
weight that i can give to
representations but it's purely your
your choice
um i was just going to read that read
the statement now that's okay that's
fine yes that's fine would you be happy
for a question to be asked afterwards if
if parties or myself wish was that to be
the case
i wouldn't expect it sort of going to be
like a big cross-examination in fact i
would not encourage that
me only sort of any sort of questions of
clarification or anything that anybody
wishes to to ask i think it's generally
the the approach um yes if i can i'll
try and answer yeah
okay now certainly as i say i know we
have two uh advocates here and i know
that there will be cross-examined later
on but it's certainly not my intention
that interested parties who've not put
forward approves would be would be
cross-examined as as such but but but
questions can
can usually be asked if that is
appropriate
okay
thank you and i don't want that to put
anybody sort of off from making
representations either because i'm here
to hear what everybody has to say be at
the council the appellant or all
interested parties
as well
um
okay bear with me um
[Music]
i'll also anybody wishes to speak i'll
add your name to my decision letter as
well
and i'd also say that i have read all
the written submissions that have been
put in
so far so even if somebody doesn't speak
i will still take into account
the representations they've made in
writing yeah
okay moving
on and for the other interested parties
if you could also give you're not
representing a group your your address
please obviously if you are representing
a group please say so and also if you
could add in in what authority you have
to do so
we've covered whether or not you support
or objects the proposed development i'm
assuming the interested parties today
wish to object but if not please tell me
and also any qualifications that you
wish to be recorded
uh when i write your name in my at the
end of my uh decision
okay and we'll also at the end i'll have
a little discussion on when parties will
be heard because i know from a few
emails that i read this morning and
yesterday not everybody is able to
attend at all
uh times
so
moving on with the list that i have got
i've got a david uh
morish i think it is
from the cprt
that's me
good morning i i am the chairman of
planet uh district branch of cfpre
i also have a background of 40 years
professional service in local
governments i'm a chartered civil
engineer
and i am a trustee of cpr
okay thank you welcome to the inquiry
um
i've next on my list got a richard
brennan
mr brennan are you with us
it doesn't appear that mr brennan
is
okay if mr brennan joins
later on
then
i'm sure that i can still accommodate
what he wishes to say but it doesn't
appear mr brennan i'm here oh brother is
here sorry
yes i'm just a uh just a resident of
shuttle down road
okay i've been a resident for 21 years
okay thank you
good welcome to the inquiry uh
next on my list is
counselor pauline
farance and if i've mispronounced your
name please let me know and this is
quite applies to everybody because i'm
sure i will mispronounce someone's name
along the way over the next few days so
please correct me if i do counselor
fahrens are you with us oh yes you're
there thank you yes thank you
good morning
and are you representing the cat in the
terms of views you wish to give today
those are the council or your personal
views
um i'm representing residents um
obviously as a counselor
um and my own views
but i am largely driven by my obviously
comments from my residents and concerns
of my residence
okay
thank you please remind me which ward
you it's samson ward yeah thank you
okay next on my list i've got a question
mark is sonia stewart i don't think
sonja stewart from emails i've seen is
with us
[Applause]
now i understand that uh
mr it's part of the westgate and
garland's action group so uh and that
miss brown as we've heard will be
providing such views
okay
moving on sir roger gayle mp
good morning sir i'm the member of
parliament for north fanet
address house of commons london
if you need it um
and i'm representing uh those who
elected me
and i have not submitted any proof of
evidence um i shall be
working
from notes but i assume that the
hearing's recorded
um i'm more than willing to provide
notes if necessary and i'm equally happy
to be
questioned by either mr williams or your
software
um i'm trying to accommodate this around
parliamentary business as you'll
understand but um i will do my best to
be present for as much of the hearing as
i can
okay thank you just on in terms of
if anybody sort of is speaking two notes
and wishes to send a copy of those notes
to
the planning inspectorate case officer
uh holly dutton then you you may do so
but there's no need to do so that's that
is only optional
uh
okay thank you moving down my list as i
say we'll come back to when we can
accommodate people in terms of people
with obvious obvious time pressures
uh
counselor pew is there a council of pew
here
yes hello good morning um i'm councillor
pugh i'm a
councillor for fanuc villages
which uh half this application sits in
my
ward um i'm also deputy leader of the
council but i'm speaking just as a award
counsellor
for uh fanuc villages um and
representing my own opinion and the
views
of my
residence
okay i understand and welcome to the
inquiry
next on my list
uh
mr timothy nib mr never you
morning sir good morning
i'm a local resident in the psalmist and
ward
and i'd be interested in making comments
on this application that's why i've
asked to speak here
but i i think it'd be in the round table
discussions
okay
uh that is fine and that would avoid
sort of repetition from things being
said in people's sort of introductory so
not introductory but sort of general
submissions as i said before if anybody
wants to take part in the particular
roundtable discussions then you know
subject to my reasonable control of the
meeting and ensuring that making sure
that no one is repeating what everyone
else says then that is that is fine
which roundtable discretion would you uh
intend to to join
uh probably the
biodiversity one
okay
thank you
and
next on my list is a counselor kerry
boyd
good morning um
i'm here on behalf of my residence and
as a
local neighbour of the site
and and i'll be representing their views
on the council of the garland ward
okay thank you
and welcome
that is the list that i have got of
those who wish to speak or those who've
said they wish to speak at the moment is
there anybody who wishes to speak who
hasn't so far
introduced themselves or been introduced
okay i don't see any more hands up if
anybody during the course of proceedings
does uh feel they wish to to add
anything then obviously
let me
know
okay uh
thank you and i'll also at this point
say welcome to those people who are
watching the
live stream of this on the council's
youtube
channel
uh
it may feel rather strange that you're
not sort of part of the virtual room so
to speak but i hopefully gives you an
opportunity to follow
this inquiry over the next few days so
welcome to those people
too
a quick reminder that the planning
inspectorate is subject to the general
data protection regulations so i suggest
that you avoid referring to sensitive
personal information
during
the inquiry i think if you do have
something to say which is sort of
sensitive
uh and might be subject to the data
protection regulations then i think it's
best to email the planning case officer
uh holly dutton that's playing a spectra
first and then we can try and sort of
work out a a way of
ensuring that you have your your your
views without giving that sense to the
sense of information
uh
in public
okay um
now in terms of when
people will have the opportunities
to speak other than in the roundtable
discussions etc
we will be doing
after my introduction
openings
from the three main parties
and then i intend to give people the
opportunity
to speak
with any say sort of general sort of
comments that they have
not wishing to sort of repeat anything
that's then going to be sort of talked
about in any round table discussion so
i'm imagining that will be either side
of lunch time
so i'm hopeful
that everyone who is here
for part of his introductions will be
able to
attend either side of lunch time to to
have the
say so to speak if that is a problem and
obviously let me know before we we close
or before you disappear because i do
want to make sure that everyone is
accommodated
uh
is that okay for everybody
okay
thank you
yes
yes that's okay fine thank you
okay put your hand up if it's not okay
okay
good
um
moving on to a virtual event management
thank you for the council for organizing
the virtual inquiry this was intended
originally to be in person but obviously
with
omnicron etc that was no longer possible
uh things seem to be working okay so far
but things can go wrong
and i want to make sure that everyone
remains engaged throughout it can be a
little bit more difficult to engage
possibly during a virtual inquiry than
an in-person inquiry so i'll endeavor to
avoid long sitting hours and i'll ensure
we'll have morning and afternoon breaks
to reduce screen fatigue etc um
if anyone can't hear me
uh or wishes to uh raise an issue at the
appropriate time then raise your your
hand obviously this is a formal
proceeding so when we're into the
uh formal cross-examination
evidence-in-chief after the proceedings
then we have to sort of stay with
the formal approach so you won't have an
opportunity during a cross-examination
witness example to suddenly sort of say
anything then as i said before you are
able to ask questions of parties at the
uh the appropriate
points
uh
also the sort of difficulties of doing
virtual inquiries i've got various
screens here i'm doing the inquiry from
from bristol by the way and uh i've got
uh
yeah very screen so if i'm looking away
at a different screen when you're
talking it doesn't mean to say i'm
ignoring you i'm just looking at a
relevant bit of evidence that's
associated with what you're going to or
what you are saying i'll also be
taking notes obviously as i go along
and because my eyesight is disappearing
fast i tend to sort of look down a bit
so apologies if i do that it's just
we've all got a little
whims with these things and i think
they're more pronounced in the virtual
events than they are in public events
not least having my face on a show for
six hours a day so even i might
occasionally take 20 seconds to turn my
camera off to have a sneezing fit or
whatever it might be and everyone you
know feel free to do so at any point as
well obviously we'll stay with the main
party all the parties we're speaking
with their cameras on if you're not
speaking or part of a discussion no need
to have your camera or audio
on
uh also please turn off mobile
headphones and try and keep
interruptions to an absolute minimum or
keep them on silent and when we adjourn
for morning or lunch breaks
uh please allow me to leave the meeting
first just so i don't get left in the
meeting with one set of parties and not
the not the other for fairness i will
always leave the the meeting completely
so that i can't hear anything but bear
in mind that when we do break for lunch
or the morning break
uh
sometimes you get situations where
people don't turn off their audio so you
can hear the separate conversations so
just make sure you do turn off your
audio when you uh when we when we have
the uh the breaks if you're not actually
leaving the virtual
room
okay
i think
those the main points with the event
manage the virtual event management if
anybody runs into a
serious problem are you losing a
connection
then
obviously just try and reconnect first
of all sometimes that does help even
sometimes if you're getting a poor
signal reconnecting can help but if we
lose somebody who's important to that
part of the proceedings then obviously
we can adjourn whilst we're trying to
get them back
in the meeting everybody so far seems to
touch would have pretty good connections
so
uh famous last words but uh that's the
side of it seems to be pretty good
so far
uh
now representations from interesting
parties have already said that i've read
all those could the appellant just
confirm that you have seen those
as well
so i've seen
all i've seen a large number of
third-party representations
um as the speakers have indicated not
each of those currently down to speak
has produced a representation but i i
have been provided by the dependent with
all those that we have received
okay thank you
uh
i've also received several proofs of
evidence i'll just quickly go through
these
uh from the appellant
uh i've got a from mr ball
planning evidence
from mr
caldery financial viability and
affordable housing evidence uh proof of
evidence from claire caldwell on
ecological matters and also a proof from
mr travis on flood risk and
drainage those are the proofs that i've
got i'm aware of several of the position
papers statements of common ground et
cetera but those are the proofs that i
have got from the council mr vic hester
on both
viability and affordable housing and
planning
matters
uh
obviously we did have the proof from the
rule six from mr austin
i suppose as we discussed before that
proof is still in existence i'm not sure
it's actually been withdrawn and it has
been dealt with in writing by the
by the by the appellant but obviously
mr horse won't be speaking to that proof
or being cross-examined on that effort
we've already adequately covered
that
uh
i've read all the proofs so i'd expect
them to be largely taken as read but i
think when we go on to the various
discussions it can be useful because
there's a
reasonable amount of people here for the
relevant uh witnesses to sort of
summarize the points from those those
proofs and obviously the opportunities
to do that in the cross-examination
parts in the in the evidence in chief
um
okay if we could just move on to
statements of common ground
the only statement of common ground i'm
missing at the moment is the statement
of common ground
on
uh viability and affordable housing
i understand that from emails i've seen
that there is progress made towards that
although we are quite late in the day
obviously at the start of the inquiry so
what is the latest
position
on the statement of common ground on
affordable housing and viability
uh
mr williams do you want to kick off
thank you sir we received
a
version with some additional comments on
from the council
yesterday evening
and that's been worked through by mr
cordrey this morning so hopefully you
should receive a final version of the
final statement of common ground during
the course of this morning
okay
thank you mr upton is that
the great position
that's certainly my understanding yes so
uh crosstalk is for
its production this morning
okay
okay uh
if we could obviously work on that basis
and obviously the well i'm not going to
be reading anything until the end of
this inquiry but i think absolutely it
is needed today both from my point of
view to get
you know to grip with actually which are
the issues in between the between the
parties on this issue and also for other
interested parties to have a chance to
consider that if they want to do
as well as i think as we all know it is
unfortunately a document that is going
to be submitted
quite late in the proceedings for
various reasons what just so everyone is
aware what is the sort of perhaps mr
williams you can answer this what is the
sort of the what have been the
particular problems of getting this
document
agreed or at such a late point
i think it's just been a series of back
and forths
between between the parties um i haven't
been directly involved in those
exchanges but i understand the process
has just
taken longer than
perhaps the parties would have liked
okay
thank you
i think it's safe to say from the
program that we're not going to get on
to that particular issue
till tomorrow in fact i would say we
definitely can't do that till tomorrow
because i won't have a chance to even
see the statements of common ground
until this evening
uh
that's right and
there was a point on programming i just
wanted to raise um which my friend and i
discussed briefly yesterday afternoon i
don't know whether this would be a
convenient time to do it or whether
you're going to come back to program
i was going to come back to program uh
yes i was going to come back to program
is this the issue of what order we do
things because one of the witnesses
speaking to both planning and uh
viability matters effectively yes uh
yeah that's on my list i was going to do
that a little bit later on in the
instructions
we'll come on to that because yeah
that's a question i want to
ask as well
okay um
right
thank you everybody
in terms of other documents all the
documents and evidence should already
have been provided i'm not inviting any
particular sort of submissions at this
particular
stage but
is there anything that's not already
being submitted apart from what we've
talked about the same common ground and
one or two other things as well that i
will come on to that any party wishes to
submit i've got a small list of things
that i've been told yesterday my emails
are sort of
uh in the effort so to speak uh
if i just start with that list that i've
got of things that i'm aware of and then
anybody else can add anything else that
they wish to submit
uh
first of all i'm aware of a
update from the council
on
their proof of evidence
i got an email about this yesterday
does that ring any bells or yes it's
just so everyone knows it's there are
some figures that uh are in the appendix
to mr hester's proof from
uh regarding your viability uh there was
correction to be made to a couple of
numbers
uh because of the issue of uh
land tax and stamp duty that was picked
up by mr cordray and
it made sense to put a number on it
hopefully that and then not be a dispute
that
it needed correcting so that's all it's
intending to do
and mrs hester obviously will speak to
it
so that's what the document is it's just
to pick up that point and say well
then the numbers look like this
okay thank you that's a sort of a matter
of clarification and the point of
agreement and that's obviously helpful
from my point of view mr williams are
you content with that to be submitted as
a late
document so to speak
yes sir thank you okay has anybody else
got anything they'd like to add on
that
okay it seems sensible that i accept
that as part of the
the inquiry
documents um
as i've not see i was aware of it but
i'm not actually seeing it because i've
got various emails through so i think
these will have to be documents that i
accept as part of the
inquiry so let me just make a note of
that
uh to see whether on the um call
document website it's got the title
thank district council correction note
right that's the title of the document
okay so it's been added to the core
document list okay good uh
thank you okay
that is that one
uh
now again in no particular order but
let's move on just to the 106 agreement
again through emails yesterday i saw
that there was a draft section 106
agreement
submitted
what's just the latest for myself and
also for everybody else here what's the
latest position on on that
thank you so i can see mr balls just
raised a hand i don't know whether
that's
yes sir
developments
it may be helpful if i come in at this
point just to provide the latest
position
um after sending the email last night to
the planning inspectors we received
further comments from kent county
council
they were provided late last night they
don't change any fundamental points or
principles of the agreements um but
we're going to be working through those
this morning
um the only other elements of the
legal obligations is the unilateral
undertaking which i referenced in my
email
with regard to schedule 3
and the affordable housing review
mechanism
those documents are both
being worked on at the moment
okay so the draft that was submitted
yesterday
uh
is a working draft effectively
and is sounds like it's going to be
subject to some
further alteration
yes
okay that's correct sir um but just to
give you some comfort um
things that have been identified are
confirmation around things like plans
uh with ken county council just wanting
sufficient assurance that enough land
has been safeguarded for things like the
link road
okay
and by the time we have our discussion
on
the planning obligation
and to a degree this may also involve
the evidence that's given tomorrow we're
at that point on affordable housing and
viability
will it be in a position to be
effectively
complete or subject to signatures etc by
that stage
um we are working hard and fast with uh
the county and with the district council
solicitors our aim is to try and get an
agreed form of the draft as soon as
possible so in the hope yes
um but it's subject to agreement from
tdc and kcc
okay
and obviously as
kent county council
are a signatory of that all obviously
very and very much involved in that that
i presume they're not going to be
appearing at
the inquiry this week certainly i'm not
going to them down as a list of
potential speakers
uh i would require a letter
from them sort of clearly setting out
what their position is on the final
on that on that final version
of the of the agreement
okay
is that everything for now on the
section 106.
so yes i think that i think as mr paul's
email said yesterday one of the issues
has been
that there is both a unilateral and a
bilateral obligation
and there has been considerable
discussion about the appropriate
affordable housing review mechanism so
just in terms of third parties being
aware
it is intended that the 106
provision
will um
provide for
a percentage of affordable housing
informed by your decision
but that there will also be
a review mechanism to address the
situation whereby viability improves
prior to the commencement of the first
phase of the development
and that
review mechanism
we understand now has to be in the
unilateral rather than in the bilateral
um so the discussion on the terms
has been very advanced but the location
of where that review mechanism is going
to appear in the documents has to be
changed
okay i understand and i'm sure we're
going to consider that in more detail
later in the inquiry thank you
okay
thank you
the next one i've got
is from the
cpr
e uh so mr
mr morish
and this is a
sort of i think an update really or sort
of a position
uh
statement from the cpi based on all the
information that there is in so far i've
not read this i'm just aware of it
because i'm not formally accepted into
the inquiry yet so mr
mr morris are you
are you with us yes you are yes
could you just sort of update me and the
inquiry on what is the purpose for this
document why it's coming at a late stage
because obviously the deadlines of
documents has
has has passed and i can then sort of
ask the parties for their views and
decide whether or not to accept it as a
as a document as part of this inquiry
two reasons is to record a
general support for these
[Music]
inquiry
but also to
add to it commentaries on the procedure
that led to
the
council's position in the first case
and then finally
we have
picked up
evidence from this amazon resident
association
on flood pollution risks
which we had made reference to in
earlier objections we wanted to
subscribe to and support the residence
association on that matter
okay
thank you um
mr williams and mr
have you seen this
this document i understand it has been
forwarded to either side i think i'm
correct in saying the there was such a
flurry of emails yesterday i can't
guarantee that
i saw it by email yesterday it came
through so but it's not on the the
website so just to confirm it's it would
be a just an attachment to an email at
the moment right
mr williams has the appellants seen it
so yes we received it by email
last night
and um
i've read it
and without wishing to
encourage any further late documents
our position is that this raises points
that have previously been raised and we
don't object to it going in as an update
position
how i would propose that we deal with
points such as this
is is through the round table discussion
so
when interested parties and um
make their statements what i would like
to do if this is acceptable is just to
keep a note of the points that i think
are then
best addressed by
um our respective witness when it comes
to the round table session so that you
can hear the appellant's response to it
if that has to be updated um from what's
already in the written proofs
okay uh yes that's how i was envisaging
that the roundtable discussions would
work and in respect of any such
documents such as that it would be a
good opportunity
for any sort of responses to be provided
at that stage so i yeah i'm happy with
with that general approach obviously
there are some matters today which might
be sort of discussed later on which or
or
submissions that are made that's not
related to the roundtable discussions
and any additional points that haven't
been sort of responded to by the
appellant uh
so far and can't be responded to in the
roundtable discussions because they
involve a different matter
that could potentially be
picked up by your your planning witness
absolutely wrong
just to make sure that any you know any
point that has been raised which has not
yet been responded to there is a fair
opportunity to do so
okay i'm i think mr morris i'm i say i'm
not
i don't like accepting late evidence to
late stage because it just causes quite
a lot of uh sort of confusion for people
and difficult to keep on top of things
we think on the basis of what has been
said i'm happy to make the exception for
that document that you have
have uh submitted yesterday so if that
could be added to the
uh
council's website please so everybody
has a chance to look at that
as well
okay thank you very much
right okay those were the
three that i had written
down is that any other submission or
written submission or anything that
anybody wants to
provide or wishes to provide that it
hasn't been put before the inquiry
so far
so just
it's it's
not a written
submission but there was an update
letter from natural england
to the spa letter
that came in
i received it yesterday afternoon
and
i know that this is on your agenda for
the biodiversity
discussion but it
effectively
confirms that they raise no objection
and they conclude that the avoidance and
mitigation measures
are
appropriate to prevent there being an
adverse effect on the integrity of the
european side
i don't know whether that's found its
way
through to you
yes it did uh it came from yesterday i
was gonna arrange it at the roundtable
discussion but yes effectively it's
another it's the document i mean that
was in response to the uh
as i'm the competent authority uh i
effectively wrote out before christmas
asking for the uh and natural english
latest
views on that so i think that was a
response to that so uh yes
that obviously is something that will be
accepted into the inquiry as well and we
can discuss further during the relevant
round table discussion so thank you
um
the one other one
that sorry mr upton your hands up as
well i've just followed that but
actually just people know there's there
are two letters dated the 10th of
january
the from natural england the deal with
this point one is addressed to the
inspectorate essentially confirming that
it was just me said the other was
a letter addressed to mr ian livingston
in a sense it's sort of an update of the
representation the natural england
wanted to make on the application but i
think it comes to the same purpose it's
just
it's worth noting there are actually two
different documents that they sent
um and so that you need to be aware
there are two letters of the 10th of
january right um just slightly
differently matters there
and yes they're not yet on the website
and they they just came through
and are dated when they came through by
email yesterday
um the other thing i was just mentioning
so was the we've also added suppose
there were two appendices
uh regarding the strategic um viability
assessment work that was done it's from
the local plan so they're probably
documents it's just they've been added
to the website so you're aware that when
you do look at the website why they're
there
they just further expand on the work
that was done at the local planned stage
um in case it becomes relevant um
webster has just given evidence because
there was obviously a viability
assessment done at that stage and that's
what that information's about so
i think they've been given reference cd
6.5 and 6.6 to say aware what they are
right um one that hasn't quite made its
way through
which i'm sorry about is the annual
monitoring report because
i'm aware that though we and the
appellant have agreed about the state of
the housing land supply
um the fundamental information is set
out in that monitoring report which sets
out the calculation number of
the capacity of
sites and indeed an individual there's a
very detailed table of what individual
sites can deliver and then obviously
then the calculation about the housing
land supply numbers
um but i think it's just it's a useful
important supporting information and as
i say because the two sides essentially
had agreed and thank goodness for it
that we don't need to go through uh the
detail of that
unfortunate hasn't made its way into the
information before you uh even though it
is a public document that is the formal
monitoring report
um so we were going to make sure that
was part of the court documents
um but nice to say i don't think it's
coming to you separately yet
no i'm not aware of seeing that
obviously with these inquiries there's
quite a lot of documents so sometimes i
do miss them but yeah i'm happy for that
to be uh
to be to be put in uh for my yeah that'd
be useful to have i'm presuming no one's
got an objection to
to them yeah that's that's fine
what date is that by the way just for my
note oh just yes so you know because
obviously each district does slightly
differently it's it's a 2020 document
the annual monitoring report for the
local plan of 2020.
uh there is obviously a 2021
document version two that would come out
probably the end of january but it's not
available in any sensible form at the
moment
uh so we're not anticipating it changes
anything before you
um but obviously in terms of the data
then the monitoring port they come out
at a regular interval
so if it does come out before you
determine matters obviously we would
make you aware of it
but certainly the way the numbers are
going it doesn't change the fundamental
points before you
okay thank you and just very briefly
those two documents that you referred to
before which were also been added to the
council's course uh course strategy list
core documents list
were they or were they previously
appendices to the council's proof of
evidence they they should have been and
i think
what appears to have happened is they
didn't get onto the cool document list
is basically they are the
documents that were submitted to the
local plan examination saying here are
the strategic sites and the assessment
of their viability
um and so that it's the
um
i'm just picking him up
sorry yes i have to refresh the site so
it is
simply making sure that it's on the core
document list i don't think it's new in
any other sense
yeah that was my understanding as well
and in which case i'm i'm certainly
happy for those documents to be to be
included as they're clearly referred to
in the
in the in the relevant proof
okay thank you
i thought of another one actually that i
need to ask about which is going to ask
about it later on but i will ask about
now as we're at this point
in terms of the
suggested
conditions i'll just say for any part
here that any discussion of suggested
conditions is absolutely about prejudice
to my eventual decision
but is there an agreed
uh document between the two parties
on the suggested conditions because all
i've got so far i've obviously got the
conditions which the
muscle officers recommended
on the in the original planning
offices planning committee report and
i've got a response from the rule six
party with some
uh
additions or amendments to conditions
but i don't think yet i've got an agreed
uh
list between the main parties
of
the suggested conditions where i too
allow the appeal what's the update on
that see mr ball's hands gone up so it's
probably best from school to update you
i think it's been again one of those
documents going back okay
that's correct sir uh and that is the
update there is an agreed um
or almost agreed list of conditions they
largely reflect what was in the
committee reports um the changes at the
moment are looking at plan references um
but i think we are pretty close to
having an agreed list between the two
parties
okay thank you now that could be shared
with mr dickman as well from the rule
six party as well obviously when you've
made your own comments on those
conditions as well which obviously we'll
discuss later on in the inquiry uh
towards the end of the inquiry when we
get to conditions
but just some so the main parties are
all kept in the loop so you all have a
chance to um make your relevant points
uh later on on that
okay
that's
fine on
conditions
obviously get that to me as soon as
possible and we're not going to get to
conditions until
uh
i say sort of optimistically on thursday
uh but if i can have that agreed
document by
let's say the end of tomorrow so i can
consider that after the uh after we
close tomorrow evening to make sure that
i can uh
hold a discussion on on that mr dickman
oh yeah just to say that if that info
information could be sent through to uh
mr hans who's our consultant he's the
person who's been the link between you
thank you
good okay
okay is that everything in terms of
other submissions
okay i won't see any hands up just on
the hands function if i miss a hand and
somebody else spots it just let me know
please at any point uh because sometimes
it can be difficult to spot all that all
the hands
okay uh now in terms of the plans before
me these are set out in the statement of
common ground the general statement of
common ground
i've got two questions i don't want to
sort of repeat the ones what's being
said i'll go through every plan
but
my
in terms of the uh the site location and
access arrangement
plans and
plan sk09
which is the
uh
bear with me
sk09 the copy i've got is
revision
b
and this was the copy that was sent
through by the appellant
when the appeal was
submitted but in the statement of common
ground
it says revision e
is there a more updated plan that i have
not
got
for sk
it's the access plan
so if i could come in here again sir
um
cd
[Music]
2.19
and the update
reflects a
[Music]
change to the drawing in that
notification
it includes notifications on the width
of the road
right
which
c core document number was it again
2.19
2.19 and this is the appellant's core
documents that's correct so yes okay
uh
go with me while i uh
get that up in the screen in front of me
okay i've got that on the screen in
front of me so just describe to me what
the
revision
does
again please
i'm going to bring in the site project
mr robert black
morning morningstar good morning yeah hi
hi um the the update was um in response
to kcc highways comments regarding the
road widths and um
rid to the width of the lanes in and
around the right hand turning lane on
hearts down road you'll note
between the two plans
there's no dimensions on the one at plan
b which was the original submission plan
but this one that's revision e has got a
6.75 meter carriageway width within the
site and three lanes of
3.5 meters within the heartstown road
carriageway um it was notified and that
was something that the
at the request of of kcc highways to
include that on that on that working
drawing
so is that just the notation the actual
plan is effectively the same so the
plan's effectively the same yeah you
just you just need to
put the figure in
yeah so sorry the the right hand turning
layout to be white and slightly from
three meters to 3.5 meters but any extra
is taken up within the site right okay
i see
and that is the only change to that plan
from what was considered by the council
when it determined the application i
know sorry
this was part of the determination it
wasn't
during the determination process so it
was in front of the council at the at
the time of determination
right that's revision e was before the
council yes
all the documents that are stored at our
cd
they're all ones that were submitted
prior to determination with the council
so they've all been in front of the
council sir okay
mr upton could you at some point confirm
that that's the case you don't
necessarily need to do it now but at
some point just to make sure that
the council is happy that these plans
were the ones that were before the
council would be determined i'm assuming
some of it is from the same
plan i got sent when the appeal was
launched albeit that was probably some
time ago wasn't it still after the
determination of the application
obviously
it still refers to revision b that's
what got me confused
uh there's another one as well
and that is
the parameter plan
listed
is
in the statement of common ground is
revision c
oh no this is the way around the the
parameter plan
in the statement of common ground
or the one that i've got is revision c
but the copy in the core document says
revision b
so this is csa4430122
the parameter plan
just want to make sure i know which is
the correct
one
um
right my plan is the one i've got is
revision b sorry so the one i've got
this is the parameter plan is revision b
and in the statement of common ground it
says i think revision c
i think that's
hopefully clarifies
apologies sir technological
failure and i managed to close the
screen and drop myself up in five
and that's okay it's the sort of thing
i'll be doing at some point as well no
doubt uh
i think sir just to make sure
can we come back to you just to make
sure
yeah if you could please because i don't
want to sort of waste time sort of
discussing
uh going backwards and forwards now so
we can sort of move on to the other
parts of the inquiry but all you can
and just to make sure that the plans
i've got
are the plans that were the ones that
were considered by the council when it
made the decision or if there's been any
actual
change since then obviously i and
everybody else needs to know about that
as well
uh i've got a hand up mr hester
thank you sir um
if you press the button on the tab
that says revision b the plan that opens
up is actually revision c
ah so exactly how it's referenced on the
card document
on what council's website should i say
thank you right
so it is a revision c should be the
correct plan
that's correct yeah
right
okay again if this could just be up you
know maybe clarified in a note at some
point during the date that would be
great and to make sure that everyone is
in agreement with that
okay
thank you
good okay apologies everybody because
some of this stuff may sound a little
bit sort of uh
dirty so to speak so moving on
um
the inquiry will obviously be conducted
in accordance with the year 2000 inquiry
procedure rules uh there'll be something
of a sort of a hybrid approach including
both cross-examination and round table
discussions
uh just going through the program
briefly and this one will come on to the
point that was going to be raised i
think previously about the
witnesses and evidence of chief etc when
i've concluded my opening remarks i'll
invite the appellant the council and the
rule sixth party to each make a brief
opening statement and this will help
everybody to understand the main
arguments i will then hear from
interested parties who may be able to
ask questions by myself and or
the
appellant
and that will be i suspect sort of
either side of
lunch
um
although flooding and drainage matters
are not part of the council's reason for
refusal a number of concerns have been
received obviously from local residents
so
i've got an item in the agenda to cover
this where the appellant's witness will
be called to summarize the flooding and
drainage evidence and then answer
questions from both myself
and from interested
parties
following that we'll have a roundtable
discussion on biodiversity matters
including the effect on the thames coast
and sandwich bay special protection area
along with the other
specific biodiversity matters that have
been raised i wanted this to be a
roundtable discussion again it's not
well the effect on the sba is a reason
for refusal uh for the council but also
i've got a statutory duty to consider
such matters i'm also wanted a chance
for everyone to consider the late
information or the the the further
information and other matters that have
been
uh raised since the council's
determination of the application
and then there'll be what i imagine will
be a short round table discussion on
heritage matters again this is given the
such obligation for me to have regard to
the effects upon the significance of any
designated heritage assets
notwithstanding that that wasn't a a a
reason for refusal from
the council
moving on and this is the point i think
needs a little bit of discussion
it was proposed the council will present
its evidence on affordable housing and
viability which will be cross-examined
uh
by the appellant
um
and the opportunity for re-examination
of of the witness
and i will hear the appellant's witness
on the same
basis
uh
the issue i think here is that
the
council's witness
is covering both planning and
uh
affordable housing viability
matters so i think it's mr williams you
wanted to raise a point
link to this do you want to raise that
point now
thank you sir i was going to suggest
that mr hester gives his evidence in one
block
with viability and planning and is
therefore cross-examined
once by me
and in your
program
0.789
are all viability witnesses but actually
um there is only one witness for the
council
mr orst isn't giving evidence
and so i think it is more logical
um to hear from mr hester
all the way through and then to hear
from mr cordrey and then to hear from mr
ball
so that was my suggestion and i raised
that with milanese grin yesterday
okay as i say it was a point i wanted to
discuss with you as well because it
wasn't sort of picked up so much at the
case management conference that we were
in that situation but i understand what
you say about the uh yeah in terms of
one witness giving being cross-examined
twice
there are certainly i think advantages
for that to be done in one
in one go so to speak mr upton
would you have any objections to such an
approach
uh pretty sort of two things so firstly
uh that makes sense in terms of
particularly the way the evidence is
written
it's there isn't a sort of natural
division within his brief evidence it is
it is basically dealing with the both
issues
so that's certainly fine from our point
of view in terms of
he presenting his evidence um
speaking in one go and then there's sort
of one block
we were quite right at the time of case
management we weren't sure if there was
going to be a separate um proof and the
rest of that so
it makes sense to to change the
suggested order to that he just deals
with his evidence um and then we move on
to mr caldery and mr bull afterwards
um the second thing i need to mention is
just
i suppose a sign of the times is
unfortunately
um mr hester was diagnosed with kovid
last week um is
okay to continue i did check with him
but does unsurprisingly get more tired
than he otherwise would do
um so if we could sort of yes sort of
go through that we're not asking him to
do too much in one go and try to build
in the breaks that i think you were
going to suggest in any event i'd be
very grateful for that obviously just
checking with him
um
i suppose it's one silver lining this at
least is online that we can continue in
a situation otherwise we probably would
have had to
pause so i just wanted to raise it
because um
i think obviously there's always a
pressure on people to continue in the
situation public inquiry i don't want mr
hester to feel in that situation but he
does feel at the moment he can continue
um so i just wanted to flag it as much
as anything
um and hopefully he will lead us uh if
he does need to take a break more than
um has been anticipated so those are the
two points in terms of conversations
evidence that yes we feel we can do it
in one go but can we just be careful
about the timetabling
okay um
okay
firstly mr sorry to hear that and i hope
you're feeling okay you continue to to
do so and absolutely whatever sort of
breaks whatever is needed i want to make
sure obviously from my point of view
that witness the witnesses are in their
sort of investment position to give the
the clearest evidence that was to mine
to my benefit so i'm very happy to sort
of watch this space uh based upon what
you've been
said and i've also i think it's when i
read
mr hitler's proofs let's test his proofs
that i thought actually this issue about
maybe we need to sort of switch the
programmer around a little bit it
doesn't make an awful lot of difference
i don't think really in terms of the
overall program it just sort of rather
makes seven eight nine
and 11 a little bit more but it seems
sensible to
all of the approach i think from my
point of view that's been suggested
yeah subject to
uh mr hester's
health and obviously sort of ability to
be able to present the uh the evidence
so i am unless anybody else wants to
comment on this
i'm happy to go forward with that
approach which seems to be the most
sensible and i think indeed the most
efficient way of
proceeding with things as
well and it does and as we said earlier
it does seem to me that we're not hard
up against
the timetable in this case and
um
certainly i think that
that's that's exciting
yes yes absolutely i think yeah it will
allow for more uh efficient use of the
the time which i'm certainly all in
favor of
okay
thank you and i should add that those
objecting to
the proposals will have the opportunity
to ask questions
of the uh
of the appellant's witness i know in
some areas
local residents
have differing views
to the council on some of the planning
matters general planning matters shall
we say and i think because of that when
it comes to
again some of you mr hesita's evidence
on planning i'll keep an open mind as to
whether or not to allow the opportunity
for
uh interested parties to ask questions
of mr hester as well as the appellant's
witness on planning matters it just
seems as though that might be
appropriate to do so given the fact that
whilst that obviously the residents are
opposing the application as the council
is uh their views and everything are not
absolutely sort of identical so it seems
sensible to keep an open mind on that
okay
following that we'll have a roundtable
discussion on conditions and the
planning obligation as has already been
said which is standard procedure uh
that doesn't indicate i've made up my
mind on the case and does not weaken the
council's uh opposition to the proposal
or the appellant's case that planning
permission should be
granted uh we've just we've discussed
the list of suggested conditions we've
discussed the 106. so that is good
then finally at the end i will hear
closing submissions
from firstly the council
secondly the rule six
party and finally the appellant and as
always it would be helpful for me if
these could be provided in writing and
i'll try and structure the proceedings
as best as possible to enable you to
give you the time to
to do so
the inquiry is scheduled for a maximum
of four
days
i need to establish a program to make
sure it runs efficiently i think what
we've discussed so far will will lead
towards that
uh
it may be possible to complete before
then in fact my
it seems to me that it is possible we
could complete after three days
if
at a good pace but there again i don't
necessarily rush things in order to do
though but we can keep an eye on time
and at the end of uh perhaps at some
point tomorrow we can discuss where
we're going
with that
um
i've issued a draft program as you've
seen and also an agenda for the round
table discussions thank you for the
estimates from the two advocates in
terms of your your timings that has been
helpful
um
they'll also be
at the end of the inquiry i will ask
whether or not any party wishes to make
an application for costs
again one emails i think yesterday is
from the appellant foreshadowing a
possible application for costs
uh
which i presume is still the case mr
williams don't want to necessarily waste
time at this point discussing that but
no sir i don't want to make a big thing
of it
your case management conference note
indicated that it would be helpful to
have an advanced notification
as well as an application in writing
at the same time before closings and so
that's we will of course keep it under
review but that is the current position
okay
thank you
uh each day i intend to break for lunch
at one o'clock with short morning breaks
and and afternoon breaks i don't want to
finish any day beyond five o'clock if
it's five past five soviet but i really
want five o'clock to be the latest that
we we sit for for all sorts of reasons
uh not least we're all staring at our
screens all day and probably have other
things to do
after five o'clock as well so this is
not an inquiry where i want to go on at
all beyond five o'clock some days it
might be possible to finish a little bit
earlier and if so that would be that
would be good uh in terms of timings i
propose we also
start tomorrow and on subsequent days at
9 30 in the morning if everybody's happy
with
that
okay i'm assuming so
uh so that would be good
and then moving on to the site visit
last thursday i traveled to the site uh
to have a look around from public
vantage point so i've had sort of a good
sort of half a day walking around the
footpaths the the two or three footpaths
in the area as well as uh
surrounding roads looking at various
heritage assets as much as i can see
from public vantage points so i've
already seen the site and some pretty
good detail i could see a lot from
public vantage points but i do still
wish to make a sort of like formal site
visit as part of the
uh
inquiry or following the close of the
inquiry after i've heard all the
representations it probably will be
still be useful to do do that after i've
heard the evidence as it stands at the
moment because i'm in bristol and even
we finish sort of on thursday it's
unlikely that i'm going to get to the
site on friday as i would do normally if
we're in my day doing it
so i really don't think it's going to be
possible for various reasons for me to
do the site visit on friday so i
proposed that i would do the
accompanied site visit
next
week at some point and the day from my
program i'd much rather to do it on is
tuesday but obviously for an accompanied
site visit i would need to be
accompanied by uh
you know the main the main parties or
very least the council and
the appellant
i don't particularly with omnicron still
around i don't propose it to be one of
those site visits where i'm followed by
20 or 30 local residents it doesn't
really necessarily help or add anything
but if the residents or mr dickman want
a particular person to come to the site
visit as well then obviously you would
be most welcome i mean i'm not proposing
that we continue the the discussion of
the inquiry at the site visit uh
and uh it will be purely for people to
point out relevant things to me and to
help that and i think mr dickman's
already kicked this off with a helpful
note suggesting various vantage points
that i go to it would be good if the
three main parties could agree a list of
the things that they think i should see
and vantage points that i should see
things from and also helpful if you do a
a route and i think mr dickman you've
already sort of set the ball in motion
with that which i'm very very grateful
for uh but if that can be obviously
circulated with the council and the
appellant and then you can agree a sort
of you know a site visit program for me
and also a suitable day for it to be
done so tuesday would be my preference
but you know i'm aware that other
parties will be might not be available
etc so that's something we need to give
a little bit of consideration to
uh
and at the end of the inquiry we'll come
back to that to discuss the actual day
but if between you the parties you could
discuss those matters and then come back
to me at the appropriate time in the
inquiry that would be useful
um
any comments on that at this point
mr mr siraji gail you've got your hand
up i think
um in the light of what you've just said
sir can i give my apologies now for
tuesday i shall not be able to be
present for the site visit because i
shall be in london at the house
um but a quick technical question
are we using the same link every day
this week or is there a fresh link
for each day please
yes good question as i understand it
it's the same link unless somebody's
going to tell me differently mr
livingstone is that the case
yes it is the case it is exactly the
same link every single day
good that's uh yeah that's helpful thank
you
okay where
are we uh sorry we're coming to the end
of my opening points which you'll all be
pleased to hear i think um
okay we've done costs i should also say
that i have the power to initiate an
award of costs whether or not any
applications have been made by the
parties and if i were to do so that will
follow a written process with the
relevant party after the appeal is
issued
the main issues
the acceptability of the provision for
affordable housing provided as part of
the scheme taking account of viability
and secondly the effect of the proposed
development on the provision of the
effects of the proposed development
um upon the integrity of the thames
coast and based special protection area
and as i've said previously there are
other issues raised by residents which
the air which the council hasn't raised
its objections and obviously several of
those are covered in the timetable that
i've got there are also some matters
such as landscape
agricultural land and one or two other
things which have been made clearly in
writing
and the appellant has provided position
papers on those so i don't intend i'm
i'm satisfied those matters can be dealt
with through writing obviously if any
resident wants to watch the party wants
to raise such matters
later on today they can do so and the
appellate will have a chance to respond
through the planning through its
planning witness
uh
and just because those two matters i
read out are the only main issues that
doesn't that wouldn't necessarily
prevent another matter becoming a main
issue in my decision so i'm here to
listen to what everybody has to has to
say and the evidence that uh that is
going to be provided to me
uh
one of the council's reasons refusal
related to
the lack of
appropriate planning obligations i'm not
put that down as a reason for refusal
because the council has indicated it
will not be objecting to that based upon
the satisfaction 106 agreement or 106
undertaking
that's obviously been discussed and that
appears to be in motion but obviously
we'll return to that when we consider
planning obligations later
in the inquiry um
good okay those are the end of my
opening remarks has anybody got any
comments on all those
procedural matters that have been
raised so far or anything else in terms
of procedure or program or technology
whatever it might what might be
so may i just raise one question
in terms of submitting
documents for example
my opening speech and friends open
speech is it best just to email those to
holly dutton yeah
yes please
absolutely and obviously to
i don't know who the contact of the
council is but the relevant email at the
council so those could be put on the uh
core documents list as well
but uh from my point of view yes please
send anything to holly don't turn them
in the situation is it's quite helpful
with the virtual work and she is sitting
also actually at home i suspect but
anything that can be sent to her can
usually be sent to me sort of fairly
fairly quickly touch wood so that is
helpful right any more points before we
get on to the uh
next stage of the proceedings
no okay
looking at the time actually it's 20
past 11 i've been going on for an hour
and twenty minutes apologies for the the
only remarks went on for for a while but
obviously quite a few important things
to raise what i suggest now
is that we have a
short break because i could do with a
drink of water etc so if we have a break
for 15 minutes
and if we come back at 11
and then we'll continue
with the main party's opening statements
and those will be in the order of
firstly the appellant secondly the
council
and thirdly the rule six
party
and then following that we will do
what as many interested parties as we
possibly can before breaking for lunch
at one or one o'clock so what i would
say is that anybody who isn't going to
be around after lunch and for whatever
reason and wants to make their
submissions before lunch then just let
me know after we've done the opening
submissions so i can make sure that
everybody is heard
okay is that okay for everybody uh okay
i will adjourn this inquiry for well
fourteen minutes now we'll return at 11
35.
thank you everybody
hmm
why are you running out um door
you
hello is that wrong
yeah
it's done
you
right it's 11
35. and time to resume
the inquiry
and we're moving on to the opening
statements just before we get to these
after these as i said before the break
we'll do
submissions from other interested
parties and
i expect the opening statements to take
let's see around about 35 45 minutes so
this will take us to about
20 past 25 plus 12. so we'll have half
an hour or so for
interested parties what i suggest is
going through the interesting part is in
the order
that they were introduced
uh earlier on
so starting from westgate and garland's
action group continued
uh i don't know if councillor
boyd
is here but i believe that
um
their availability was from 12 30 till
two o'clock and then from four o'clock
till at five o'clock so i'll need to
make sure that
that is slotted at the appropriate
time but if everyone's happy with that
then i will say
no more
okay
okay thank you so
item two
is the opening statements
uh and
i will start with
the
appellate so mr williams please
thank you sir i have
sent
a
written copy through to holly gutten i
didn't know whether that has reached you
and murdered friend as well
thank you sir
yes thank you
so you identified the main issues
in dispute at the case management
conference as being firstly the
acceptability of the provision
for affordable housing provided as part
of the scheme taking into account
viability matters
and secondly the effect of the proposed
development on the integrity of the
fanuc coast and sandwich bay
spa
and you noted that the inquiry would
necessarily also look at the benefits
arising from the development
it's inevitably the case that the
evidence to the inquiry
focuses on the issues in dispute between
the parties which in this case are very
narrow
however the planning balance is to be
struck by reference to the scheme as a
whole
its assessment against the development
plan red as a whole and the presumption
in favor of sustainable development
in circumstances where the council
cannot demonstrate a five-year housing
land supply or meet the requirements of
the housing delivery test
and i've put in the footnote the
statement common ground reference
which provides the
position in respect to those two masses
as such
it's of importance that the appeal
proposal
delivers up to 450 units
of which 15 percent or 68 are affordable
on an allocated site in the 2020 thanet
local plan
subject to the proposed conditions and
planning obligations the council doesn't
identify any breach of an adopted policy
within the plan
and this is straightforwardly a case
that falls within paragraph 11c if the
framework
where development accords with the
development plan
and permission should be granted without
delay
turning to the first issue and that of
affordable housing
there are i suggest three important
points to note at the outset
firstly the appellant worked openly and
cooperatively with the council to agree
the highest percentage of affordable
housing provision that the site could
support given its site's specific
constraints and its strategic role in
delivering and paying for the on-site
highways infrastructure of the link raid
the council's planning policy department
consultation response
recognized that the inner relief road
was the priority provision for this
allocated site
therefore the proposals put forward and
recommended for approval twice by the
planning department of the council
reflect the most appropriate development
of the allocated appeal site in line
with policies of the adopted local plan
secondly the only outstanding objection
raised by the council to the appeal
scheme relates to the amount of
affordable housing
the council instructed independent
consultants that's both specialist
viability surveyors and also quantity
surveyors
to verify the approach taken to
viability taken by jll and mr caldery
this was an iterative process which led
to total agreement between the appellant
and council officers and their
independent advisors
officers endorsed the appellant's
appraisal and offer on three separate
occasions
and eventually members were advised that
following yet further review
there were no reasonable limits of
deviation from the assumed inputs which
would increase the viability of the
scheme
and yet in the absence of any further
evidence to support refusal
members refused permission on very
limited grounds relating to the
percentage of affordable housing
the appellant understands this is being
confirmed that the council isn't
intending to call any evidence from
viability surveyors or quantity
surveyors
the advice of dicks and certain council
officers that the affordable housing
offer is appropriate therefore stands
equally the council provides no
alternative viability appraisal of the
appeal scheme
thirdly the appellant has at all times
indicated its willingness to include a
review mechanism within the obligation
so that if viability materially improves
due to market circumstances then an
additional contribution will be made
it follows that the council has the
security that if the market improves
then additional affordable housing
within the district will be provided
given the need for affordable housing
the provision of 68 units is a very
significant benefit
if additional units can be provided then
that is an additional benefit
as to the up-to-date position the
opponent relies on the evidence of mr
cordrey the inputs and assumptions are
consistent with those approved by the
council officers and their advisors
there's no suggestion from dixon cell
or ermc that's the cost consultants that
those matters of approach have somehow
become unsuitable
an update on the agreed basis shows that
the scheme remains unable to support
more than 15 percent affordable housing
it's a fundamental
principle of planning law that the
decision maker can only determine the
application before him
the council puts forward no case that it
is necessary to consider alternative
developments and no alternative scheme
is put forward
when the appeal proposals are assessed
against the development plan
it is clear that they are entirely
policy compliant
it's well established that the
development plan is to be read as a
whole and that the relevant development
control tests are those set by the
adopted policies themselves and i refer
to the churchley court case
the council does not identify any breach
of an adopted policy of the development
plan
the strategic objectives of the plan
including strategic priority three
are met
and not contravened by the provision of
homes including affordable homes on an
allocated site
what matters
is that they are delivered
which this scheme enables
also the review mechanism
is prepared to say that additional
affordable housing may be provided in
the event that the viability position
improves
before commencement of the individual
phases
on
the spa second issue
the planning application was accompanied
by an environmental statement with
detailed ecological information and the
shadow habitat regulation assessment
updated environmental information has
also been provided as explained in the
proof of evidence of miss causewall
the position in respect of the spa is
common ground with the council
see the ecology statement of common
ground
in particular it confirmed that in
response to the shadow habitat
regulations assessment the council as
then competent authority under the
habitat regulations
undertook an appropriate assessment and
concluded that subject to the secured
mitigation
the project will have no adverse
recreational effects on the integrity of
coast and sandwich bay spa
either alone or in combination with
other plans or projects
natural england have also been consulted
and raised no objection and the footnote
refers to their most recent letter of
yesterday in that regard
kent county council also raised no
objection
it is an agreed position
that subject to the secured mitigation
no adverse effect will occur on the
integrity of the protected sites in
proximity to the appeal site either
alone or in combination with projects or
plans
and it's further agreed that the
proposed development and level of
contributions made
will be in accordance with local plan
policy sp 29 and so entirely policy
compliant
as to other material considerations
there are a number of other
considerations referred to in the third
party representations and in the
statement of case of srswra
these are now largely addressed in the
range of statements of common ground
relating to heritage ecology flood risk
and in the main planning statement of
common ground
proofs of evidence have been prepared by
ms cordwell
and i set out her qualifications and
matthew travis equally relating to
ecology flood risk and drainage and
these witnesses will address any
outstanding concerns through the round
table sessions
however the outcome
is that the technical issues have been
properly assessed and addressed and that
the conclusion of the assessments is
that the appeal scheme will mitigate its
impacts and will generate a net gain in
terms of biodiversity
and flood risk
there is also a statement of common
ground on heritage considerations and a
position statement prepared by ms mira
in summary following a comprehensive
review of potential effects on
designated and non-designated heritage
assets
it's agreed that the impacts are either
non-existent or negligible other than in
relation to the grade two listed shot
and dane farm house where there's a very
low level of harm towards the lower end
of the less than substantial harm
spectrum
it's agreed with the council that the
public benefits arising from the scheme
outweigh the harm to designated heritage
assets so that the development meets the
requirements of paragraph 202
off the framework
turning to the planning balance then the
appellant submits that the appeal
proposals are called entirely with the
development plan
and so should be permitted without delay
applying the presumption under section
38 6 of the 2004 act and paragraph 11c
if the framework and there is no
identified breach of development plan
policy
however due to the council's inability
to demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply and also the performance against
the housing delivery test
the appeal must be determined applying
the tilted balance
that is that the council must show
that the harm caused by permitting the
development demonstrably and
significantly outweighs the benefits
the benefits of the appeal proposals are
substantial
these are set out in mr paul's proof of
evidence of paragraph 7.1
and the benefits reflect the pressing
need for housing and affordable housing
in the district
however the benefits are also reflected
in the adopted local plan
the appeal site is allocated because of
its importance in delivering housing and
highways infrastructure
the benefits are very significant to the
local housing need the affordable
housing need the need for infrastructure
and community facilities
there is we suggest no harm to be
weighed against this
the council's case is based on the will
of the wisp
the alleged harm is
unidentifiable
there is a pressing need for market and
affordable housing
and the appeal proposals deliver both on
an allocated site alongside very
significant highway infrastructure works
there is no harm only benefit
the quantity of affordable housing has
been the subject of very detailed
consideration
and verified by the council and its
advisors
there is a review mechanism in the
planning obligation
in reality the only harm would be caused
by refusal of permission
thereby undermining the council's
strategy for meeting market and
affordable housing needs in the district
as a result it's respectfully submitted
that planning permission should be
granted
thank you sir
thank you mr williams
now turning to
the council mr upton before you start
have i got a
uh written copy of your
submissions uh word copy it's not
essentially not
if there should be unfortunately i
suppose i i'm relying on the speed of
the internet um so it's only recently
just would have been sent off uh and
obviously for you it's coming via holly
dustin so
i've received it um
the email has gone
um so i'm glad to know it's got to one
one part of the
link
um i got
some emails
from holly but not
it would be most recent but i agree she
may not be waiting to press the forward
button
let's just uh
i'm just opening this email
no
no although she sent through mr williams
twice
[Music]
okay it's not essential she'll have it
and she'll send it through to me uh so
i'm i'm happy to uh obviously
i'll have it on record anyway so but i'm
happy to listen without the age of a
separate document so that's right
as you say it will be available as a as
a written document
uh
shortly as indeed it was the appellant's
um opening comments
so so on behalf of the local planning
authority i did want to say uh some
fairly brief points and obviously i'm
aware that we as you say take a more
limited approach than
uh others who have objected to this
scheme but as i say this appeal concerns
the development of one of the new
strategic housing sites identified in
the thanet local plan
and although this is an allocated site
for up to 550 dwellings the proposal to
be determined by this inquiry proposes
less than that
and the appeal is regarding has been
mentioned the erection of up to 450
residential dwellings including market
and full housing
structural planting and landscaping
formal informal public open space and as
is set out in the description
as those who follow the debate will know
this has been a controversial
application locally it was considered by
the planning committee several times and
that has been deep concerned that one of
the major strategic sites was not
delivering what it should be
there are three reasons for refusal
dealing just in brief terms with the
adequate provision of affordable housing
as part of the dwelling mix which would
not meet the identified need for
affordable housing in the district
the absence of a legal agreement
to secure the delivery deliveries
necessary infrastructure required to
support the development and finally the
absence of mitigation against the likely
impact on the protected habitats on the
fanuc case and i'll come back to those
points uh again
but
as you've mentioned there are other
matters that have been raised in the
objections
and
these still remain of course for you to
determine and those concern the matters
such as flood risk implications and
drainage the effect upon other
biodiversity and wildlife issues
separately from european protected
habitats
the effect upon the character and
appearance of the area transport and
traffic impacts and the loss of
agricultural land now the council just
to be clear was it self-satisfied that
these could not form a reason for
refusing this application
and these matters have been made the
subject of the statements to common
ground either in general one or in other
topic specific ones
and copies of all those documents are
available on the council's website
and these draw as documents on the
material that was submitted as part of
the planning application and the
environmental impact statement and
further supporting information
it's also worth noting at the outset
about the status of the development plan
policies
the policies in the recently adopted
plan are not
put on quote out of date in the ordinary
sense of the language and still carry
very considerable weight in those terms
but the council is in the regrettable
position under the terms of national
policy
the development plan policy that are
most relevant to determining this appeal
are quote unquote out of date
despite having recently adopted because
of the effect of the national planning
policy framework
and that's because the council cannot
meet the national housing delivery test
and it cannot currently show a five-year
supply of deliberate housing land and
that therefore engages what's called the
tilted balance in paragraph 11d of the
national planning policy framework where
the balance is tilted in favor of
granting bank permission
of course as regards the extent of any
shortfall that still remains relevant
but we would say that you have the most
recent data in the amr
annual monitoring report of 2020
on the five-year supply position
and that shows if we were using a five
percent buffer as of the normal position
there will be four point nine six years
supply so only just below the five years
and as indeed we have to do if you're
using the 20 buffer then the figure is
4.34 years
or if the opponent's figures were to be
used at 4.23 years supply
again with this consideration of 20
buffer but we do say ultimately the
extent of the housing shortfall is not
significant
and the housing action plan is in place
as required to deal with that
so can i then deal with those three
reasons for refusal and firstly the
suppose the second and third ones can be
briefly
dealt with we do anticipate at least by
the closing inquiry that the second and
third reasons can be satisfied for the
terms of planning obligations
and these reasons for refusal were
expressed in a conditional way now the
second one basically being the applicant
has failed to enter into a legal
agreement to secure the delivery of the
necessary planning obligations
uh and thirdly the third reason in the
absence of securing acceptable for
mitigation the proposed development
would result in increased pressures on
the spa so uh as i say we'll need to
look to the terms of planning
obligations they have progressed from
the heads of terms to a more complex mix
of a planning obligation and natural
undertaking
there is the sporting evidence and
policy considerations for the conclusion
that they can be met set out in what we
call the sill compliance statement
and that is also supported by written
representations by made by kent county
council on the infrastructure provisions
that are relevant to them
especially on highway matters
so hopefully that body of information
and indeed the legal agreement will mean
that the second reason for refusal is
satisfied
as regards the third reason
the residential development on this site
could give rise to additional
recreational pressure pressure of the
protected site known as the sanic coast
and sandwich bay
special protection area and ramsar site
there is an acceptable form of
mitigation identified in the local plan
regarding a what's called a strategic
access management monitoring plan
which is being produced in consultation
with natural england
and any mitigation needs to be supported
supported by a full analysis of the
likely impacts and that's been recently
confirmed in a court case from which
stannic was itself concerned
uh in july of this year
um
and the reference there is the
application of ge against district
council and kentucky projects limited i
hope so you do have a copy of that i
think it was sent through earlier but if
needs be a further one could be provided
but the point is that
it was therefore necessary to review
what was in the shadow
habitat regulation assessment uh there
is now a more recent version which we
say has addressed the issues uh properly
and we've had the recent response from
natural england in their letters and
those are the letters of the 10th of
january which confirm that that is the
case so again uh anticipation third
reason has been satisfied
and you'll be able to reach that
conclusion
so you can turn to the first reason for
refusal truly contentious and concerns
the percentage of the affordable housing
to be provided
the applicant at first suggested 10 and
has now offered 15
the appeal site is a strategic housing
allocation in the adopted standard local
plan that should make an important
contribution
to meeting local needs housing
in the district
and 75 percent of the district's housing
provision new provision is going to come
from its strategic sites
even though they require significant new
infrastructure to come forward
nathaniel itself is a district with a
significant shortfall in affordable
housing indeed the full application of
30 policy requirement would itself still
lead to a shortfall on the identified
need in the district as the local plan
inspectors report accepted
and obviously explained why it is
therefore at 30 percent
but it does remain important to make
full use of sites such as this one and
schattendeck
and we're going to hear evidence from mr
vic hester
who is a vla associate's independent
planning consultancy
on the viability evidence that is
available and the significance of that
work in making a decision on the
planning merits
as national policy and the plain
guidance state the way to be given to a
viability assessment is a matter for the
decision maker and with regard to all
the circumstances in the case
now in this case we are asked to
consider the viability on an outlying
planning permission
much of the typology of the housing
remains to be determined at the reserve
matters stage
changes at that stage could affect the
viability position
and as our consultants noted the size of
the scheme means the viability outcome
is very sensitive to relatively small
changes in the assumptions used in the
assessment
and a successful approach should provide
an appropriate number
mix of sizes and types of home
now broadly
we are not from the council's point of
view challenging the viability output
set out in this submitted financial
viability assessment i say broadly
because there is a an issue about how
one updates those figures to reflect the
current position because obviously
you're looking at it in june
in january
uh 2022 whereas the figures were last
looked at um in june
however um
even for not assessing uh
and questioning the outputs we have been
presented we say with a financial
viability assessment that assesses only
one version of the development that will
be permitted by the parameters of this
permission
and it does not even make full use of
them
it also assesses a version that is not
policy compliant
so whilst there is a financial viability
assessment as part of the application
it has several shortcomings in terms of
what it can be said to prove
there is an element of being
shortchanged
it's not just that the heavy lifting in
terms of the infrastructure required by
the allocation policy is now being done
by 450 houses not 550.
any assessment is actually only as good
as assumptions on which it is based in
the work of our viability consultants
that are appended to ms tester's proof
put some numbers to this point about the
potential movements and viability if if
you start adjusting
those assumptions in the scheme
and we do say that limits the weight
that can be attached to the viability
evidence
i would note that the third party the
resident association have submitted of
course their own vibration evidence we
now know it's in writing
uh which does uh question the numbers in
the um verbally assessment
and if that's right it would mean that
even less weight can be attached to it
now ultimately here the dispute is not
whether or not this site is capable of
being developed for housing
but about an important part of how this
greenfield site is to be developed
it has been identified as a strategic
site on the basis that it can be used to
deliver significant affordable and
market housing
whilst this scheme is not the only way
of developing this site the particulars
version that we have from the appellate
would deliver planning benefits in terms
of providing new housing it would help
deliver a key piece of highway
infrastructure as envisaged by the
allocation
but what is proposed
falls short on affordable housing
and as the reason for refusal itself
states the proposed development by
virtue of the proposed level of
affordable housing would not meet the
identified need for full housing in the
district
thereby not providing the required homes
to create a balanced mixed community
this harm is considered too
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of the development and
therefore would not constitute
sustainable development um as i say
that's all i need to cover sir in
opening
and i hope by now you may have a written
copy of that
thank you mr upton um
i have just got one through but it's
actually it's from the uh rule six and
not yours i
i don't know i suspect what's happened
is that uh
holly has sent through mr williams twice
but don't worry i'll chase it up you've
sent it mr williams has got it so i'm
sure it's out there so uh yeah i'll make
sure i i'll get that and if some reason
she hasn't got it i'll make sure that uh
we go back to you to make sure we get
that copy
uh i have though just got a
written version
of
the
yes the rule six parties statement of
case so thank you mr sigmund for sending
that through have you also sent that
through to the two of the main parties
as well can i check i believe we have
done uh mr hand uh sent the information
through they should have it
right okay
mr
if that if that's not the case i will be
talking to mr hand directly after this
meeting and i'll be happy to get him to
do so but certainly sent it to yourself
right okay
mr up to mr williams have you received a
copy of the
not yet sir but
there's no reason to delay on that
ground okay
i have now sorry like uh bombardment by
emails i have just received mr upton so
i have got that now
so i've got all three copies of the
opening statements uh
so that is
that is good news um
i think yeah obviously it will come
through to mr williams and mr upton due
course the one from the rule six but mr
dickman if you want to uh proceed with
your opening statement now please
thank you sir um
this statement provides an update on
three key matters
that were highlighted in the rule six
parties statement of case
submitted november 2021 and the position
statement issued december 2021
as you wear these statements focused on
three key matters
affordable housing viability
loss of biodiversity without mitigation
and flood risk which i will summarize
than it is the most deprived district in
kent and nashville is ranked 30th most
deprived local authority out of 317.
as measured by the
the office for national statistics index
of multiple deprivation 2019
rank averages score
the high demand of affordable
accommodation locally reflects the
social economic profile
swara supports the council's refusal on
the grounds that the proposed level of
affordable housing would not meet
identified need and firmly believe that
a higher proportion
is both required and feasible
the appeal schemers had made has made
has has had to make certain assumptions
to the financial viability assessment
about the housing numbers
mix
tenures types and sizes to justify why
the requirement for 30 affordable
housing on the site
is not viable and cannot be delivered
as a result swara commissioned an
independent specialist pathfinder
development consultants to review the
original fba dated june 2020
in his appeal the consultant mr all
sought to identify assumptions which
would give concern
to explain why and to consider
implications that flow from it
this includes most importantly the
impact on the total quantum of
affordable housing that may result from
the application of more
of more appropriate assumptions
the total financial implications of
these altered assumptions are
significant with the improved financial
position potentially leading to a scheme
of circa 27
affordable housing being viable
total of 122
affordable homes
80 percent affordable rent 20 shared
ownership
the exercise carried out by mr walls
clearly illustrates the fluidity of fbas
and the importance of realistic
assumptions
the ability for maneuver and revision is
evidenced by jll in their letter dated
7th of june 2021
providing updated scenarios which
resulted in an increase in the
affordable housing provision from 10
to 15
tdc's proof of evidence underlies this
matter concluding in paris 6.6 that the
fva does not adequately demonstrate that
for such an important site there are
other assumptions that will be used
or inputted into the fba that are likely
to lead to a higher proportion of
affordable homes on the site
than the 15 percent offered
swara agrees that logically the starting
position should be it should be to
propose a policy compliance scheme and
then to assess the availability instead
the appellant has submitted a
non-compliance scheme and has thought to
justify from the outset that this scheme
is not viable enough to deliver the
policy requirement for 30
affordable housing
swara fully supports the robust
conclusions of tdc's proof of evidence
on on this issue
and thereby considered no further need
to add to mr proof of evidence
in this respect
he emphasizes the key point that his fda
assumptions are regularly agreed by the
parties in viability assessment
negotiations
therefore
with this uppermost in mind and to avoid
using up inquiry time
examining the constraint contrasting
views of the viability of each of the
highlighted assumptions suarez will not
be calling upon mr ulst to provide
further evidence
the rule six party believes the exercise
to have been worthwhile in demonstrating
a fundamental point about the impact
that challenging and improvising certain
assumptions can make on viability
calculations
loss of biodiversity biodiversity
without mitigation
firstly breeding birds a key ongoing
concern has been the absence of an
adequate survey of breeding birds on the
appeals side
repeated requests to see the survey were
rebuffed these in reticence to believe
that it remained an outstanding
requirement
the lack of such a survey was referred
to and discussed at all three planning
committee meetings dealing with the
application
as a result sarah commissioned its own
survey on the site to fill the gap
had requests for the breeding bird say
survey report been met
this would not have been required
the appellant's ecological proof of
evidence produced by csa december 2021
indicates in para 4.2
that a breeding bird survey report has
been produced and that the survey was
conducted between april and june 2020
however this has only been reported in
the last month
with no indication why was not made
available earlier
it therefore seems unclear whether
natural england tdc or the county
council had actually seen the breeding
bird information
until the report recently materialized
the delayed report indicates the
importance of the site for breeding
birds with 26 species identified
including the presence of several red
listed species such as corn bunting
skylark and grey partridge
paris 614 the csa proves states that
mitigation measures have been proposed
to address slightly significant effects
on farmland birds
species within the breeding bird survey
report
csa stroke 4430
stroke 22 stroke b
cd8 0.03
this includes the creation of a bird
mitigation area of 108 hectares by
identifying the proposed archaeological
exclusion shown for this purpose
as well as questioning the suitability
of such a small area one twentieth of
the current site
it is considered a completely unsuitable
location for breeding farmland birds due
to its proximity to manston road the
waste recycling center and the footpath
tm-14
fencing off this area will not
compensate for loss of open field
habitat
skylarks avoid vertical structures as do
many farmland birds and partridge are
unlikely to fly into a relatively
restricted fenced area
proposed planting of new hedgerows will
take a while to mature by which time
is a distinct possibility that the birds
will have gone
therefore suarez questioned whether the
proposed single hectare bird mitigation
area is either suitable
or sufficient whether off-site provision
would be more meaningful
swara welcomes all the additional
mitigation measures listed in paris 6.15
provisions of small bricks house martin
cuts etcetera
and supports the requirement being
secured by an appropriate planning
condition
but questions whether this is sufficient
because of the cumulative effect
on the wildlife from
inter int into an area
more people
cats and most important proximity to
existing proposed roads
bats
swara commissioned an independent review
to determine the adequacy of the
submitted ecological assessment for bats
the resulting report highlighted issues
relating to the environmental assessment
and statement provided provided by
wardle armstrong
including a lack of initial field
surveys
shortfalls in reporting
failure to adequately consider the wider
effects on the landscape
and implementation of effective
mitigation strategies
these issues are addressed at length in
the csa reproof paris 617 and to 6.57
the author of the soiree commission
report has been unable to consider fully
the comments and prepare a response in
the limited time available
however a key point is that the
appendance of the expert relies on the
assumptions that the site is considered
to be
low quality
paris 6.19
and an isolated habitat both of which
are questionable
flood risk
soira's main concern on this matter is
that the proposals have not taken
significant account of the presence of a
anti-historic watercourse
tivoli brought that flows in an
underground culvert from tivoli wood and
on into my gate sands the planning
application states
that the site is not within 20 minute
meters of watercolors however tivoli
brook is located downhill from the
appeals sites lower field and close
enough to be of significance
particularly given the history of
service water flooding in the area
the appellant's proof of evidence on the
matter refers to a letter from county
council
as the lead
local flood authority
with respect to tivoli brook dated 19th
in november 2021
this states into alia that from our
previous investigations we are not aware
of any connectivity between the
development proposed and the culvert
coveted watercourse
swara has now seen this recent letter
from kcc
although this provides a stronger
response to ongoing concerns than for
many previous requests for information
there is conflicted evidence from the
bathing water profiles monitored and
published by defra
environmental agency
it is stated therein that the market
main bay
the
bay the natural drainage hydraulic
hydrologically catchment surrounding the
bathing water is approximately
1650 hectares
this includes the catchment of tivoli
brook an underground stream that drains
most of the local urban area
the tivoli brook emerges through an
outfall onto the beach the wider
surrounding areas predominantly rural
arable
the accompanying map on the website
clearly indicates the holy appeals site
lies within the surface water catchment
that discharges onto margate main sands
in addition
tivoli brook and its disputed ownership
are discussed in the margate surface
water management plan
which noted dispute the dispute as both
parties southern water and vanit
district council were partners on the
project
kcc are not discussed formally since the
kcc i'm not aware that any formal
discussion
have taken place it would appear
therefore that ownership and
responsibility for the watercourse has
not been resolved
a suggested planning condition to
address this issue has been submitted by
eswara
in conclusion
the site was a late addition to the
local plan as an allocated strategic
housing site
fundamentally its suitable suitability
is questionable
given the significance constraints posed
by
topography hydrology geology and
archaeology on the development
the complex nature of the sites impacts
directly on layout and financial
visibility viability
this results in an unexpectedly low
level affordable housing which fails to
accord with the local plan policy
there appears to be inflated assumptions
in the fba that impact on viability and
thereby the level of affordable housing
alternative regulatory agreed
assumptions could provide significant
cost savings that would allow
considerable room for maneuver
the apparent the the potential adverse
effect impact on the proposal of
biodiversity is substantial
notably in relation to breeding birds
and bat species
and the proposed mitigation measures
appear inadequate to compensate for this
the increased risk from surface water
flooding posed by the this development
another large-scale housing site on
adjacent land remains a major concern
the role of tivoli brought in a drainage
area together with the question of its
ownership is not adequately addressed
for these reasons and in consideration
the panning balance swire affirms its
conclusion that the appeal should be
dismissed
thank you
i think thank you sir um i'd just like
to say that sarah bowers um of westgate
and garden jackson group has also joined
the meeting to help me with i need help
with answering questions if that's okay
good okay not quite ready yet for you to
go on but in a few moments but yeah
thank you for clarifying that
uh
thank you for the free
opening statements there from the three
main parties that's all very
helpful
um
counselor tomlin saying could you do you
mind if you turn your camera off
unless you're
sorry i was going to mention it before
but i i forgot but if we can try and
stick to the people who are involved in
the conversation
at any one time can have their cameras
on uh
and then everyone else can have their
cameras off until their wish to speak
thank you
so
we can now move on
to
the
uh other submissions from interested
parties
and
as i said before
we'll go on the list that we uh
they were introduced
so
mrs brown how approximately how long do
you consider yours will will take i
should ask you
i think you're on
i think you're on mute
sorry i'm sorry sir um
not terribly long it's not it's a
summary so it won't take a huge amount
of time
thank you okay over to you thank you
thank you sir thank you
thank you for this opportunity to
provide a summary an update of the
written representation submitted last
november by the westgate and guardians
action group in relation to the appeal
site
that submission highlighted several
aspects of the proposed development that
were of prime concern for local
residents in relation to landscape
character loss of productive farmland
inadequate bird and back surveys surface
water flooding sewage pollution traffic
generation and the inadequate nature of
gp services local gbt services i'd like
to summarize some of these main concerns
for the inquiry
landscape and lots of farmland the
appeals site is located in the local
character area undulating chalk farmland
this is described in the sonic local
plan as an area of high quality
agricultural land
of
value for farmland and roosting coastal
birds the openness and undeveloped
character of the farmland contributes to
the essentially rural character and
relatively dark skies
then its heritage is based on hundreds
of years of continuous farming which is
the fabric of the landscape
vital for food production and home to
increasingly rare farmland birds such as
skylarks corn buntings and wings
the proposed development should not be
viewed in isolation as it is closely
connected to other proposed developments
at birchington and westgate and garland
1 650 and 2 000 houses respectively
via the planned inner circuit ring road
another one thousand seven hundred
houses are planned southeast of the
appeal site two hundred and fifty
approved at songston grange and a
further one thousand four hundred and
scheduled for strategic site sp 18 at
westwood
all these developments are in the same
landscape character area and combined
will lead to a loss of 30 to 40 percent
of productive farmland thereby
detrimentally affecting working farms
all of this is on land owned by a very
small number of farmers whose businesses
will be adversely impacted
if farms become unviable this landscape
and its functionality will change
forever affecting landscape character
local distinctiveness habitats
biodiversity and water environment
the proposed development will also
remove the last patch of dark skies in
the area
currently vital for protective species
including bats and owls
this is all contrary to strategic
priority four and policy scp-26 of the
sanic local plan
which aim to safeguard local
distinctiveness and promote the
protection and enhancement of than its
environment
including the landscape and the
biodiversity
in addition we consider the sanity local
plan policy sp 30 which specifically
states that developers are required to
mitigate against the loss of farmland
bird habitat is also contravened because
the proposed on-site mitigation area is
neither functionally suitable nor
sufficient
flooding surface water drainage
the lower field of the appeal site
regularly holds water during heavy rain
and consequently as a sustainable urban
drainage system is proposed as part of
the development
however our main concern is that the
proposals have not taken significant
account of the presence of an historic
watercourse called tivoli brook
in june 2021 residents were strongly
reminded of the threat from surface
water flooding because heavy rain caused
storm water to flood along shotenden
road as if it were a river
this water followed its historic route
along shottenden valley tivoli brook and
out onto margate main sands
development on the lower field could
result in contaminants from those houses
gardens driveways and additional roads
ending up in ship at tivoli brook
the whole of the appeal site lies within
the surface water catchment area that
discharges on margate main sands the
department of environment food and royal
affairs bathing water profile for
margate mainstream bay
states it has a natural drainage
catchment of approximately 1 650
hectares this includes the catchment of
the tivoli brook
an underground stream that drains most
of the local urban area
tivoli brook emerges through an outfall
onto the beach the wider surrounding
area is predominantly rural arable
the potential for flooding and
contamination of margate main stands by
tivoli brook was raised and discussed by
the sunny district council planning
committee at three meetings but senate
district council and the appellant
continue to dismiss this possibility
sewerage infrastructure
southern water regularly pour treated
and untreated sewage into the sea all
around the fanuc coast during periods of
persistent heavy or even moderate
rainfall
issues with pumping stations not
functioning properly in such conditions
are well documented both senate mps
recognise the seriousness of this issue
for public health tourism and the
environment and have both called for a
moratorium on house building in this
area because the sewerage system clearly
cannot cope
adding more houses onto an already
failing system this will only worsen
worsen the situation
traffic generation and climate change
like many other local authorities planet
district council have publicly
recognised the climate and biodiversity
emergency and issued a declaration to
that effect
use of fossil fuels particularly by
transport is a major contributor to
greenhouse gas emissions
and climate change
instead of building more roads we should
be investing in schemes that encourage
active travel and the provision of
better and more reliable public
transport in line with the local plan
policy sp-45 transport infrastructure
the proposed development is completely
car dependent there is no bus route
along any of the three main roads that
serve the site shottenden road
manchester road nor hearthstone mode the
nearest bus stop on helena avenue not
beatrice road as stated by the applicant
is cited to be 850 metres away but it is
more likely
0.8 miles and a 15-minute walk from the
center of the site
the applicant also states that the
railway station is 1.5 kilometers away
but again it is further closer to 1.5
miles or a 25 to 30 minute walk
the development proposals include a new
distributor link road through the site
and associated junction roundabouts as
part of kent county council's planet
transport strategy this is aimed at
relieving traffic congestion at the
coffin house roundabout however
inventing car use so centrally in this
development will only add more vehicles
to the local road infrastructure some
260 movements during peak hour
this is contrary to policies sp-43 and
sp-44 of the zanit local plan which aim
to promote safe and sustainable
transport for accessible locations
pressure on gpe services
residents in samson ward are assigned to
the lyme surgery in central margate
which has approximately 6 000 patients
per gp compared to the national average
of 2 000. the gp provision at the lyme
surgery clearly cannot support another 1
680 residents
based on 2.4 people per dwelling for the
450 houses proposed
in addition to the 250 houses at samston
grange which have already been granted
outline planning permission
in conclusion we support thanic district
council's refusal of the proposed
development and firmly believe that the
appeal should be dismissed
however the reasons for refusal are not
considered to be sufficiently
comprehensive
because they do not reflect the wider
ranges of issues associated with the
application
several aspects of which are contrary to
local plan policies thank you
thank you
thank you mrs brown that's very helpful
can i just ask that several of the
matters you've raised will be subject to
our sort of later discussions will you
be joining those discussions as well um
i'm not sure i'll be able to or not
actually i will if i can
okay because as we discussed before some
of the points will be
sort of responded to by the appellant in
those as as as well so
obviously if you are able to attend
those discussions that might be yes
yeah um sorry just raised her hand
several hours
hi i've just joined to support jackie
i'm a resident and also a member of the
west gate and garland action group i
just wanted to say that if you would
like somebody to be present in those
discussions i'm sure we can arrange if
necessary i can join and perhaps jackie
can join too
okay i mean it's purely up to you but
obviously you know i'm here to sort of
hear sort of from interested parties and
everybody as well as their their palant
and
the council and they're all sick so you
know if you're able to then i'm sure
that could be helpful it's just that
several of the matters you raise will be
subject to more detailed discussion in
those so
thank you
mr williams if you've got any questions
you would like to to ask
dave thank you very much sir as
we discussed earlier i think the most
efficient way of dealing with these
points of which i've got a careful note
obviously
um is through the appendage witnesses in
due course thank you very much
okay thank you
okay mrs brown thank you mr that's
helpful thank you i was going to write a
note in another notepad a second so bear
with me a second
right
moving on then to the
other
interested parties speakers and next on
my list
is mr morris from the
thank you very much mr cliff
um
i think my
comments that i'm going to briefly uh
refer to now are all substantially
within the
four-page uh
position statement that's submitted
yesterday and again i have to apologize
for the late submission
uh
we're very glad to see that the
uh in general terms the
council are now ending get over them
uh the local plan
uh presumptions of
uh 30 affordable out for housing
we are concerned however
that
what seems to have been uh given a clean
sweep
and there's been lots of discussions
from various parties about the viability
of affordable housing
what is completely unquestioned at the
current time
is the fact that
the uh
there's a concern
obviously from council officers
that the affordable housing contribution
were to be exacted from the developers
would somehow
have an effect upon the
the county council's policies
to provide
funding
for the strategic highway network and
i quoted in the second page of the
secondary submission
what was said in the june
21 committee report
it would mean that development would not
in the opposite view sufficiently
mitigate the impact of the developments
on the highway network
uh
ignore the impact on community services
including education by reducing off site
contributions outlines
in the heads of terms
it it may mean that insufficient funding
is available for strategic projects for
the district
and what i set out in our third page is
that
what has not been demonstrated
currently
to
uh brought to the public attention
council's attention that that
those strategic contributions
are part part of a package of schemes
that were
would be required to deliver the county
council's
head projects other inner circuits of
highway schemes
uh which
for which there is no county council
money available which all of them would
have to come from developers
and would rely upon
at least five other developments other
than
uh
this particular development contributing
to a network of improvements
only deliverable over the next 30 years
[Music]
those
the presumptions
of the need for the highway network is
itself based upon other presumptions and
i think mr williams referred to uh one
of the will of the wisp assumptions
and one of the will of the rich
assumptions that i'll suggest that there
is is the fact that
when the new local plan is considered
there would have to be
in view of what has been happening in
the last three years transnationally a
uh
significant uh
reduction in the number of uh
housing units that are required for the
area in turn it would reduce the
likelihood of having a
completely new network of which the
contributions for this development is
put apart
so there's quite a a crumbling structure
on which
uh
the delivery of a strategic network
would
would uh depend
and if that has to be sorted out in the
future
and
at the last local planning inquiry i it
took some three or four days to try and
weave together a a a net
a network of agreements by which all
these various developers that each
develop
for each
contributes
to to the network
so it's highly dependent upon
a the
need for
all of the housing developments
uh
put forward the last uh
traffic local plan were to take forward
and they would be accompanied by the
somewhat like estimate 80 year old
idea of a little circuit
rather than has been referred to by mrs
brown in the previous evidence
of the safe and sound transport plant
that gives more credence to public
transport
um
that
i then would just like to move on to the
without
any questioning currently
the highways requirements have been
taken as being you know
actually there based on his development
but they are
they are dependent upon other
other developments going through the
plan
also i would
make a commentary on both councils
both councils have
a shared interest in
highway matters and transport matters
even though they don't actually fulfill
uh
their responsibility
for public transport very well
but both councils
do have
uh
uh responsibility
uh for the various aspects of flooding
and land drainage
uh flooding and land drainage is a very
complicated issue but essentially the
two
apart from the water authority the two
main local government players are
district council and
ken county council
and they seem to have paid scans regard
to the disposal of surface water
drainage for this particular site
and i have to say cpre are indebted to
the world has been carried out
uh by
the samson residents and their
consultants in
in
defining and illuminating all of the
problems that are there suffice it to
say from our case and this is uh
referred to in our previous evidence
the one main beach on thunders north
coast
is the jewel in the crown which is
margate
main sun
that's a regular season but i'll be not
at this time of year in that my good
condition of hell i wouldn't go in and
see but with the times of the year i've
pleasured in swimming on the other
beaches they've got blue flags the
actual uh
foul water pollution in margaret sands
which has never actually been tracked
down or any attempt to make death
tracking down
undoubtedly is affected by the fact that
it is serving some
600 hectares of land and surface water
drainage
i hope that with the conditions that
that
some of the residents have put forward
there may be uh
concentration on this issue but it is to
uh it is very surprising to me his next
level government officer how the
officers can put so much concentration
on highway issues so little
concentration on drainage and pollution
issues especially considering that
planets uh and
[Music]
the uh
southern water authority are getting so
much
fun publicity for tourism uh from the
current bouts of pollution
i think that here end of the reading for
warning so that's my contribution thank
you very much
[Music]
thank you mr morris for those
uh submissions and again on matters such
as drainage you will have the
opportunity to ask questions of the
uh drainage expert or drainage witness
okay
just one question from a brief question
you mentioned the emerg that
the new local the emerging local plan
do you know i just remember from reading
the statements of common ground that the
main parties are in agreement that at
the moment you can't give much weight or
very little weight to that because of
the stage it's at do you are you in
agreement with that or do you do you
differ on that well insofar that the
existing plan only deals with the first
five years
and the previous draft local plan you
know it was a full uh local fund referee
30 years
that really the only substantial
uh
planning commitment sorry uh
within
the uh approved plan and
the the main developments is psalmist
and development
the representatives of
darlington westgate some people say for
themselves their concerns for all of the
other development sites that have been
put forward in the original plan
which may be the cause for well it
should be the cause for the
debate and congestion that the the next
inquiry but unless and until
there is a proper planning case for
those developments then the whole
highway games
it
does not hold together and the
substantial costs which kcc are
demanding there's a contribution that's
attached
doesn't work unless you've got the
uh
contributions from
more than the science of development but
at least another four or five
developments and
[Music]
five developers involved in the district
okay thank you and
any matters concerning the emerging plan
i'm sure could be picked up by the
planning witnesses later on in the
inquiry as as well uh taking account of
what you've said okay uh
thank you mr morris mr williams if
you've got any questions you'd like to
ask of mr morish
no thank you sir we'll take the same
approach thank you
okay thank you
thank you so much that's very helpful
now uh
next on my list it's 18 minutes to so
depending on how long then and next
speaker is we may pause for lunch after
this but is a counsellor is counselor
buoyed in attendance now because i do
know that you sent a note earlier
saying that you might be available
between 12 30 and 1 o'clock
yes you are would you like to make your
on that basis would you like to make
your
submission now
i said yes certainly and that'll
probably make things a lot easier i
won't take too much of your time either
i do need to
back off
um
so i'm just going to run through a
couple of the points i see i'm here
representing my awards primarily of the
garland's residence um and something
that i can't say that i think from the
beginning of um this application process
there was a severe lack of engagement
with garland residents
and it was very much seen as something
that fell into the villages ward or
samsung and gardens was kind of
not seen even with the the public
consultation was held
i don't know if you won't know the area
i appreciate that but with us
considering uh the way
the back of being kind of hidden away
um which you know making difficult so it
will have a severe knock-on effect on
garland residents
particularly around sort of the traffic
which has been mentioned
and i want to thank mrs brown and bowers
for their contribution earlier as well
and i don't want to go over too much
stuff and repeat stuff but certainly the
traffic around
hearthstone road
and it's not been mentioned yet but on
particularly match days obviously we've
got a very big football club down there
and having a road put in there it's
simply going to be helpful
if anyone's down there you can see that
the road's already um quite severely
over overwhelmed something out of double
parking um which will make it
harder
and shot on zone itself um for locals
it's already used as a kind of relief
road to avoid
the densely populated canterbury road
area and to avoid going through the
towns
and so to increase more traffic through
that is also going to be
more
detrimental to just the lifestyles and
the livelihoods of people that live here
and and in addition to that
overall i'd say this kind of runs a
mockery of our local plan in terms of
we would ask and expect developers to
have better affordable housing and which
has already been mentioned several times
um and i thought this inquiry is a
standpoint that this will pave the way
for future developers and they will use
this as an example and it kind of
undermines us as an authority
and as to what we can do and it also
makes local residents feel less
empowered that they have a say
um as to what goes on in their in their
local area and so what i would say is
just that this will be almost a
blueprint as to what goes on next i know
that there will be other developers from
neighbouring
um sites that will be watching this and
see what the outcome is um so that was
kind of my point and
i will try and listen in as much as
possible this week uh in and around my
work commitment so thank you very much
for your time
okay thank you councillor boyd that's
that's helpful just one quick question
because i'm not sure i've seen it raised
in the evidence as yet but market
football club you mentioned some
potential impacts on traffic what sort
of crowds today
yes what's that
live
we had a local derby which was between
margaret and folkston at new year and we
had
something like nearly a thousand people
and they're 800 so it's it's really busy
on match days they'll be saturday
afternoons um however it's also busy
during the night i myself play um
firefly football in the evening so
anything from six o'clock to nine
o'clock um you can guarantee we've got
eight father-side football there
so you can imagine um how many people
there per hour and that often drive
across than it and so anyone that thinks
that is only busy on a saturday is um
delusional unfortunately um it is really
busy during the evenings um as well so
and they you know they are looking to
expand and build a hotel and build
um you know a big stand as well and
increase what they're doing so
you know that that's why it's a bit of a
concern for that particular race
right
okay what league are they in you know
what league though
um yeah they're in um i'm trying to
remember what it is um but it's the one
below sort of national it's kind of like
south south but they aren't trying um
but yeah you'll see me there
yeah okay thank you uh and thank you for
your submissions that's helpful thank
you for your attendance
today thank you
i should have asked actually before you
disappeared mr williams wants to ask you
any questions sorry mr williams
no thank you sir that's fine thank you
okay thank you and thank you councillor
boyd
uh
right
going back to the
list
missed and probably the last one before
we adjourn for lunch at one
mr
brennan
are you
with us
if you wish to make a submission
mr brennan
no it doesn't appear that he is
so
moving
on
um
councillor farence
yeah hello um
[Music]
my submission will be
um probably at least 15 minutes and but
i don't mind if um
[Music]
you know you want me to split that
before and after lunch whatever suits
you sir no i'd rather do it in one in
one go um
15 minutes that will take us just to
beyond
one o'clock with possibly sort of a few
questions i'm i'm happy if you're happy
to to go and then we can just do an hour
i want to break for an hour for lunch to
give everyone a good a good break from
the proceedings but uh i'm happy for you
to
to go now
okay thank you
okay
um well first of all i just wanted to
introduce myself i've been counsel of
the samson ward since may 2019
and
i just wanted to point out that i'm
obviously
very impressed by by the caliber and
obviously experience of everybody here
and i just wanted to point out that even
in the council i'm not on planning and
it isn't an area that i'm particularly
familiar with i've had a lifetime career
in public service in health and
education so
first of all my
my submission really is representing my
residents
um
and
i grew up in margaret and i returned 25
years ago to raise my children so i do
have a lot in common with my residents
and their considerable concerns about
our home so i'm hoping that i can bring
that to this um this meeting
um
i realized that lots of people here
today don't have much knowledge about it
and its uniqueness and i can totally
appreciate that um
we have two
odd uh two particular areas i think that
make us fairly unique
uh one is sadly that we are as has been
mentioned a very deprived area and later
on i'll give you some stats on that
um but we also have of course our
wonderful coastline our rolling fields
and our open skies and the local plan
encapsulates that by saying that the
undulating chalk farmland is a
particular landscape feature in planet
the openness and undeveloped character
of the high quality farmland contributes
to the essentially rural character and
relatively dark skies and this is quite
key to the
concerns of residents
um
but we've also got to be aware of the
fact that than it is actually
the most built up area in kent already
um except for fringes around london
and i did send in a map that does
illustrate that it's quite um
it's quite uh
clear that planet is is a is a
relatively very built up area already
and i think this is helpful in putting
local people's fears into context and
why we are so desperately concerned
about the possibility of an even more
built up planet of the future
and
the specter of having none of our
precious open spaces left
um
from the point of view of deprivation
and affordable housing and viability
um the fact that this is an area with
high levels of deprivation and low wages
means of course that the demand for
affordable housing is very high
i understand that the low offer of
affordable housing from dagman
is due to the fact that the development
would be difficult and expensive
because it's on a hillside and it has an
area of potential flooding in the middle
and that gladman is aiming for a profit
of around 20 on the development and i'd
like to suggest that gladman could at
any time have considered making a
slightly smaller profit and giving
margate the housing it most desperately
needs
um it's also worth noting that other
developments in thanet offer 30
affordable housing one even has a
hundred percent
affordable housing that's a new
development that's just been recently
started and those developers work
extensively with tdc biodiversity and
horticultural officer and are ensuring a
retention of the expansion of woodland a
large pond and many other wildlife
initiatives that are actually obviously
too many to list here
um
further it goes
i think it goes without saying
that in an area of high deprivation and
core health
issues which affect the well-being being
of residents become even more important
so
we need to ensure that the landscape of
our beloved island isn't changed
significantly or just detrimentally
in fact the open space strategy of 2017
highlights one of the key issues facing
the health of sanet
in that 68 of residents are classed as
having weight issues this is in the
local plan page 147.
the local plan of 2020 also gives some
excellent guidance
and i have been asked by residents
uh to emphasize just a few of these
to you
today and these are quotes from the
local plan then it forms a discrete and
distinct area characterized by its unity
of land use arising from high quality
fertile soils
open with few trees the area is
dominated by wide views over an
extensive land cover of cereals root
crops and other horticultural crops
future development should seek to
protect and enhance the assets which
provide a strong sense of place
the undulating chalk farmland is a
particular landscape feature in planet
the openness and undeveloped undeveloped
character of the high quality farmland
contributes to the essentially rural
character and relatively dark skies
indeed the local plan also says
development proposals
development proposals should demonstrate
how their location scale design and
materials will conserve and enhance than
its local distinctiveness
in particular a sense of openness and
big skies particularly in the central
part of the district
gaps between planets towns and villages
and subtle skylines and ridges which are
prominent from lower lying
landscape
this distinction between town and
countryside should be retained but
um unfortunately it seems that these
proposed developments seeks to do the
opposite of those aims of the local plan
um i also note that gladman have stated
that the landscape of the site and i
quote is not of any notable heritage
interest
and is of negligible significance in eia
terms that's i suppose environmental
terms and is not a heritage
asset
we strongly contest this view
um it has of course a long and vital
heritage but i'll leave it there because
i know that other people are giving
explanatory evidence to challenge or
have given explanatory evidence to
challenge that statement
um the thing that i the the area that i
would
particularly like to focus on because no
one else apart from westgate group
westgate and garnish group have
mentioned this but his gp
services um
i am obviously aware that officially
this is not tdc's responsibility and
it's the requirement is for kent and
midway ccg to state a required sum of
money
for new buildings or extensions to
existing surgeries
however when i talk to residents and
residents talk to me about the proposed
development they always voice their
fears about more lives being put at risk
when we all know that our services are
so stretched already
therefore we feel it's clear that we
cannot consider any new homes until this
overriding problem of gp services is
addressed and i'll explain why this is
particularly important with um
statistics to go with it
as we've mentioned margaret is an area
of extreme deprivation it's actually the
67th most deprived area
out of over 32 000
in england and wales okay the 67th most
deprived out of over 32 000 areas
and the second
out of
902 most deprived area in kent
currently
gp provision infante is woefully
inadequate but in particular
the line surgery in central market has
approximately 6 000 patients per gp
whereas the national average is about
two thousand and it's this lyme surgery
that would accommodate all these new
residents which is a total of sixteen
approximately sixteen thousand six
sixteen and 1680 new residents which
includes
um the 250 houses already designated for
samsung ward
um in october 2020 the kenton midway ccg
wrote to tdc planet planning department
to justify a developer's contribution
of
[Music]
388 000 pounds towards new buildings and
extensions to gp surgeries
to accommodate additional residents
um the report from the ccg made no
mention of the increased number of
doctors nurses and other professional
staff which would be required to run
this service
so this is october 2020. now in april
the ccg publicly declared that there was
a problem with the gp service in planet
revealing that planet continues to
struggle with a low number of doctors
and pledge to offer more support to a
fragile gp system
it's important to note this public debt
declaration was made six months after
the ccg made their formal report to tdc
this report did not acknowledge there
was any difficulty in providing gp and
other professional health services to
the residents of margate
either at that time or with the addition
of up to 2 000 new residents
clearly the ccg should be asked to
review
to produce a revised up-to-date report
on the state of gp services in moorgate
and
a bit more background as evidenced by
the following facts from 2018 to 19
they've been significant problems in
planet for many years
in their
2017-18 annual report the ccg noted
primary care infrastructure across
planet could be destabilized to a
critical point due to multiple gp and
practice nurse vacancies
in january 2019 the royal college of gps
compared population data with gp
workforce numbers from nhs digital and
found that thanit
has one of the worst gp to patient
ratios in the country
and this was in january 2019.
in august 2019 the chair of the nhs
fanuc clinical commissioning group
stated that gp practices were unable to
sustain themselves financially with
closures on the aisle meaning surgeries
had dropped from 17 to 13 in just 18
months
he said many of them have not been able
to get the right staff and they've not
been able to get locums this is why we
have to look very carefully at how we
deliver things many gps are burning out
or are over a certain age demand on
practices is phenomenal
so gp shortages and an aging population
contribute to puff tough working
conditions for doctors
the isle has the country's second
highest number of patients over 75 year
old years old per full employed gp
as well as the fifth highest overall
number of patients
this combination of high overall numbers
of patients per gp
and high numbers of patients aged over
suggest that doctors working in primary
care in these areas face some of the
toughest working environments in the
country
in october 2019 the managing director of
east kent clinical commissioning group
said
the recruitment of gps remains a
significant challenge nationally and for
thanksgp practices
in addition a letter from newington road
surgery in ramsgate stated that the
decision to manage list is due to the
difficult situation we find ourselves in
adding that we came to this conclusion
based on clinical safety reasons
we currently have nearly 8 000 patients
and just two gps
the national average at that time was
1800 patients per gp
we've been advertising for a new gp to
join our team since august 2015 without
success
and
the combination of high overall numbers
i've already said patients per gp and
high numbers of the older people make
these very tough working conditions
so along with others for the last three
years i've been actively campaigning and
lobbying the ccg to encourage them to
offer incentives for gps to work in
thanet and particularly margate
but the ccg has steadfastly refused to
consider offering offering incentives
for planet such as enhanced payments or
goals and plan shakes
it's therefore clear that this is not
acceptable
and it seems clear
that the tdc perhaps owns a ccg have no
alternative
but to urgently ensure that our gp
services are improved before the number
of residents increases so dramatically
on behalf of my residents i hope that
any any developer would also take the
situation seriously and take appropriate
action with the relevant bodies um to
safeguard the health
of people in margaret and planet
so i just want to mention a couple of
other factors that my residents have
asked me to raise but i realize have
been covered by others so i will be
brief
residents consistently race the lack of
consideration of the serious flooding in
the area
and i think the important thing to
emphasize information you've had already
this is local knowledge um as locals we
all know that shot and dane road becomes
a river when there's heavy rain
we obviously have physio evidence and
and and there's much other evidence as
locals we're also well aware of raw
sewage being pumped into our coastal
waters resulting in closure of our
beaches for prolonged periods
particularly this recent summer
this not only affects the well-being of
residents but it takes a considerable
toll on our many businesses which depend
on visitors for survival
the raw sewage is pumped out when
rainfall is high
and this is has not become an unusual
occurrence
therefore building on our fields and
thus preventing natural soakaways can
only exacerbate an already unacceptable
situation
i'm also aware that kcc has um
made some contributions about this but
i'm also aware but from their own
correspondence that they aren't aware of
all the relevant information and the
history of flooding the particularly
history of flooding in this margate area
so there are extra
concerns which i'm sure are being
addressed by others
who are
submitting information for you to this
inquiry
i also submitted a map
that shows about global warming
it shows how the sea could come right up
to tivoli brook
by 2050.
um that's a very low-lying area that
coastal area by dreamland by margate
station
and where we've been talking about the
outflow from the tivoli brook
coming out onto margate stan sands
um that very light lying area according
to the map
could easily be underwater right up to
tivoli brooks
residents have continually expressed
alarm
about the building on the films for
these reasons
um but i wondered if anyone had actually
looked at the double whammy of sea level
rising
with the potential to swamp the tivoli
brook from both sides as has been
discussed earlier today
um the final locals concern is about
transport
this development this proposed
development is clearly car reliance um
as has been mentioned the nearest bus
stop and railway station are not really
within close walking distance there's
also a concern about where people would
get their local shopping um there's no
provision for that either
i just wanted to end with a couple of
national points
um
there's been a lack of any thought to
the fact that this is established in
ancient prime agricultural land and the
country is on its way to a state of food
insecurity
um
we import 48 of our total food consumed
and the proportion is rising
we rely on imports
and a thriving agricultural sector to
feed ourselves and dry
and drive economic growth
um
and it just is a source of great
confusion to locals as to why we would
build on prime agricultural land
in addition only last week the
government unveiled the next stages of
its plan to reward farmers and
landowners for actions which benefit the
environment supporting sustainable food
production alongside vital nature
recovery and work towards net zero
so we seem to be going against lots of
aspects there as well
so in conclusion
as i've said nationally we have to think
about food in security
and government
guidelines government um
actions that have just happened about
that um sea level rising rainfall
increasing
and that's having a particular effect
obviously in this area around tivoli
brook
and locally
there's a unique landscape of planet um
it's already over developed compared to
the rest of kent and we do feel that our
unique landscape needs to be retained
and respected
um the flooding and the raw sewage
discharges are major concerns now and
need to be addressed and of course the
gp situation is dire has been for some
years and there is a real genuine fear
amongst residents
if we have more residents in the area
what will happen it's already at
breaking point
and just finally um there was a comment
about
obviously officially the
um
mr williams was talking about
the harm of better
caused by development as
outweighed by benefits
um and about
some comp some uh comments from the
planning committee being will of the
wisp
um what i'd really like to point out is
that the planning committee is made up
of councillors who are democratically
elected and represent their residents
and i think this is the important thing
here we're talking about local knowledge
and local people who feel quite
passionately about this for very
objective reasons this is not an
emotional
situation these i think we've outlined
between us some pretty clear
logical
serious and objective reasons to be
concerned and i do hope that that will
be taken into consideration
thank you
thank you councillor parents for those
comments again uh that's very helpful
thank you
um
just want two questions from
me if that is okay um
in terms of the the
situation with the the gp shortage that
you talked about at some length i think
you've made written submissions on this
already
i will ask that the appellant does
address those in their planning evidence
later on as as well because i don't
think that's something that's been
addressed in a particular position paper
so far of it
yeah are you
because obviously there is a
contribution being negotiated with kent
county council not county council as
part of the actual section 106 that's
not what kent county council is it
which provides a contribution towards
uh
health facilities
have you got issue with with that that
doesn't is your argument that that
doesn't do sufficiently because
gps can't be
the difficulty in gps being employed in
this area yeah i mean you can have all
the buildings in your in the world but
if you can't find people uh if you can't
recruit gps and also other health staff
it's actually pointless and we are in a
dire situation already
what do you think that is your request
to the developer that somehow they
address that or obviously the local plan
is there to sort of you know address
such things through strategic division
etc
what your point of view could the
developer do to address that or are you
simply saying there shouldn't be new
houses because until this has been until
this actually has been addressed well i
i don't think we you know and residents
don't think we should be building new
houses until it's addressed um but it's
never been it's just isn't being
addressed in the situation as i quoted
from 2018 19 was bad it's just got worse
and worse and lives are clearly at risk
um
so
i don't mind who it is but
you know which body is and i hoped it
would be the ccg and i have been in
contact with them over the years about
it um would be offering some sort of
scheme or incentives to encourage more
gps and health professionals to work in
planet but um they just say it's
impossible there are they do refer to
some national schemes
um but i do think that given our unique
situation in sanit that um you know some
more consideration needs to be given i
mean some really deep thought needs to
be given
as to how anyone the ccg tdc kcc or the
the developers you know wants to
contribute to that or help help to
alleviate this really dire situation
six thousand patients per gp is just um
not acceptable i don't know anywhere
else in the country has that number
maybe they do but um
okay that's that's helpful thank you i
understand and you also talked a little
bit about the local plan obviously this
is a site that's been allocated in the
local plan and that there are some
things where it's been allocated for a
specific number of dwellings in the
local plan
uh
and that's quite a recent allocation
there are some things which obviously
are sort of site-specific things where
you could sort of talk about buildings
being sort of too high it was a detailed
planning application of course which
this is not but in terms of the site
being allocated in the local plan
exactly i've got to go away consider the
application against the local the local
plan as part of the development plan and
obviously the material considerations
and i've got to sort of decide what way
to give to such such a policy but
because you were also commenting on
issues on landscaping character
appearance lots of farmland some of
which would seem you know to sort of
already have been sort of almost sort of
being decided by the fact that local
plan has allocated this this site
you know what sort of how would you sort
of balance those things because as i say
several things that you mentioned not
all but several several things that
we've mentioned would have been
presumably would have been considered an
actual allocation uh in 2000 when the
local plan was adopted
um
i i have learnt um
so much more about the site over the
last year or so
um
the fact that it's such a hillside um
and i expect you've walked it already um
it is a hilly area
um there's a flooding situation so i
i find it difficult to comment to be
honest because
i suppose personally
i regret that i wasn't so aware of these
issues before
[Music]
okay
that's fine thank you
one final question that the
document that you submitted i think it
was yesterday or maybe on friday it was
a relation to what you talked about for
the global warming there was there was a
diagram you've submitted which so far so
where is that document from
can you give a uh sort of an annotation
as to where it is taken from because i'm
not sure it says on the oh i i thought
it did i'll look back
if that could be checked yeah sure one
of several things i was looking at
yesterday if it if it does and i
apologize uh i'll say i'm grappling with
quite a lot of information
coming at the last minute but yeah i'm
aware you need references if not because
it's one of the questions that i think
might come up well i think probably
something that doesn't need to be
addressed that when we come to the
discussion later on about drainage so it
will just be useful in that in that
respect
okay i'll send that through thank you
mr williams if you've got any questions
you would like to
ask of councillor farance
no i don't thank you sir just
to reassure you sir in relation to your
question there is as you said
in um schedule six of the
106 agreement provision for the payment
of health center contributions to the
council
yeah 388 000
okay
and i think that will be a question i
think in a way some of those sort of
questions are all links
questions linked to that
i think i will be probably best
discussed during our discussion uh later
on inquiry when we actually discuss the
actual 106 agreements and consider it
against the relevant tests in the in the
national policy framework et cetera so i
i will have some more questions i think
of that of the parties at that that
stage
but no no other questions thank you sir
okay thank you and thank you mister uh
councillor ferraris for those those
submissions as well
it's very helpful thank you
right we've gone a little bit beyond the
one o'clock mark i think it was good to
get that those submissions out of the
way so what i will
adjourn now for an hour i think an hour
is a good
time for lunch so if we come back at
just beyond
quarter past one say you know sorry
quarter past two so 216.
well 2 15. i'm sure we'll be fine and i
propose that we go back to our list of
interested parties
so
i the next one i've got on my list is
sir roger gail you sir roger are you
with us now and are you able to
make your representation at
approximately quarter past two
good
thank you
okay everybody thank you for all the
submissions so far i'll adjourn now for
lunch and we will return at 2 15. thank
you
good afternoon
everybody it's now 2 15
and time to resume
the inquiry
[Music]
looks like we have everybody
back with us
uh
we're midway through item three in the
outline inquiry programme which is
representations from interested parties
jagel being the next speaker before we
do that is there any housekeeping here
any other matters that we need to click
on pick up one at the moment
and let's have a look
counselor pew your name your hand is up
yes thank you cliff it was just to
confirm that i'm still on the list of um
of people to speak i just wanted to
check
you are yes yes mine just wanted to just
wanted to
just wanted to check thank you yeah
you'll be coming up actually i i in
terms of my list you'll be after sir
roger
brilliant as always as always a very
hard act to follow
okay
thank you and mr ball your hand is up um
yes so it's just a very quick matter in
relation to the uh statement of common
ground on affordable housing that has
now been agreed and signed and we're
just about to pour that in and we'll
include mr dickman in the correspondence
or through michael van gaal
right good thank you
thank you thank you
i will review that uh
after proceedings today and of course if
you can put that upon the sure that goes
up on the core documents council website
uh in liaison please
that will be helpful
okay
uh mr dickman yes uh just two matters
firstly i received an email and i
understand that mr nib uh may well not
be uh wishing to speak now however the
good news is he and i have spoken i can
um go through the areas that he was
concerned about
okay
i think he said biodiversity yes
which i think he says that
more appropriate if he took part in the
drainage and flooding round table
discussion rather than the biodiversity
discussion are you not saying you've
been fined really wants to uh
let the other two parties know that mr
hands has contacted me they should be
in receipt of our opening statement oh
right okay good thank you
just going back to mr nib is he now
speaking and telling me to speak just on
drainage and flooding or not at all
the email i
i received from mr hands was that i
believe he's probably not expecting to
do that at all now right um however i i
can uh uh cover his points okay okay
that's fine the one i got all the the
playing spectra done was 11 49 so maybe
it's moved on since then but that's that
that's fine thank you
right
there's everything in terms of
housekeeping
so over to sir roger please
thank you very much dude sir and good
afternoon um i start by saying that i'm
not expert in this by any means so
if i get out of order i'm quite sure
that you'll tell me sir
i will endeavor not to
go over all the ground that's been
already covered this morning
but i'm afraid there will be some
repetition in what i have to say i want
to underscore
some of the points that have been made
i understand sir that
this inquiry is application specific in
the sense that it relates to
very specifically the
gladman proposal
but as kerry boyd councillor kerry boyd
said
this morning
there is a domino effect
in all of this
and it's virtually impossible for us
locally
to extricate
this specific planning application from
the effect that it will have
on a number of um
assets locally
that cover the whole of not just
hearthstone schottendame
but garland
and
westgate
and birchington
and
i hope i won't be out of order in
depending slightly on
that um
in
your question to pauline farance
you reference the local plan
and i'd like to comment upon that
uh in a moment
because i think it is relevant and i
think the fact that you have to take
account obviously what is in the local
plan
is significant and we need to clear that
up
um i'm indebted to rowan dixon from the
swra and also to mrs brown from west
gate and garnish for their presentations
which makes my job a bit easier
um
dealing first with the
issue of affordable housing the
fundamental ground for the tdc rejection
of this application
and the
matter of viability
a very considerable concern to me that
this piece
of the jigsaw the fanuc jigsaw
and indeed
others as i will show
have effectively been motivated by road
funding
there is a very real concern
that in order to secure the necessary
section 106 funding
to build to widen
bits of the local infrastructure
we're sacrificing
the requirement for affordable housing
and insofar as then it has a housing
need
very much of that need is in the
affordable area and of course much of it
it's not an area that i expect you to
know sir but it will be it is being
built at westwood cross
so we're left with a situation where
not for the first time in order to build
a couple of bits of road
around the
shop and the end of the shopping dane
road
opposite the
um margaret cemetery
leading down to what used to be known as
coffin house corner
we're sacrificing land that should not
be sacrificed
i suspect that in this domino effect
we shall find exactly the same thing
happening
as is happening here
with proposals for housing to the rear
of garland
to the rear of westgate on sea
to the rear of birchington and then down
to what is known as brooks end hill
where there will be a huge roundabout
so we're in the perverse situation
of trying to fund a needed road there's
no doubt about that
to relieve the traffic that is currently
running along the canterbury road which
is the only arterial road at the moment
running
from brooks and hill right through into
margaret
in order to relieve the pressure on that
road
we're going to build a lot more houses
to fund a road which those that traffic
new traffic will then use
that seems to me to be utterly perverse
the road is needed
but not at the price of a lot of
agricultural land and again i'll come on
to that in a moment if i may
the infrastructure in the area
um this was referred to by councillor
pauline farance and she's absolutely
right
is woefully inadequate
not only this particular road which is
not funded
uh yet
the government has indicated some
funding and kent county council is
clearly seeking to raise the wind to
do the whole job
but it is by no means in the bag
but it's not only that road
it is feeder roads
it's roundabouts
it is as pauline farren said very much
gp practices
and services and health services
and
a relatively pitiful contribution by way
of section 106 money
to help build
adoptive surgery
is going to be of small value if we
can't put nurses and doctors into that
practice not the moment we can't
there is a desperate shortage already
and the more housing we build the worse
that situation is going to get
we also have to look at the provision
for education particularly primary
education in the area
and
we have to look at
the um transport facilities as well
and again as it's been pointed out
public transport in this area is pretty
sparse and there's no reason to suppose
that in the short to medium term it's
likely to get any better
so basically we're talking about
building a lot more housing this
development and several others
without the supporting infrastructure
and this has been one of my
constant criticisms
of successive government plans
but the infrastructure simply isn't in
place before we add more housing
which is not to say that there isn't
some housing needed because there is
turning to the matter of the local plan
that you put to pauline farence
as i'm
sure you are aware this local plan
was imposed upon the government
by sergeant javid when he was the
secretary of state for local government
um it was
therefore not really a local plan the
team from whitehall came down
told the local authority what we were
going to have to have
and
that was then effectively rubber stamped
by thana district council
it was the subject of an inquiry with a
planning inspector i don't think it was
you um
who um
who not entirely surprisingly approved
the local plan and the secretary of
state then approved what was effectively
his plan anyway
so this was not a local plan it wasn't
something that local people were
involved in really or wanted
the objections and i was merely one of
the many objectives to the local plan
before it was approved
um
were not heeded
the
housing figures 17 and a half thousand
new houses
were based on outdated ons figures from
and the requirement for housing
for local people in thanet
is probably about half between now and
2030 of what is actually being provided
for
not entirely surprisingly that's put a
huge amount of pressure
upon the local authorities to try to
identify
land upon which to build this at these
houses in fact most of our demand can be
met and should be met
by brownfield sites
turning to the specific site
historically
i'm surprised that in kent county
council submission
they did not refer to the 1973 floods
this is an area that is liable to
flooding
um those of us with perhaps rather
longer memories than we would wish
um know very well
the difficulties that we've had
surrounding the tivoli brook
and it's effluent pouring out into the
main sands of margate
um
it's now in a culvert
and
people have tapped into that culvert
nobody's quite sure who owns it who is
responsible for it
or whether manure because that's what it
is
is coming from
uh it's not particularly pleasant
this is he was addressed and
cctv cameras were put down the tube
within my parliamentary lifetime so
within the last 38 years
not entirely a satisfactory solution but
the fact of the matter is
that the proposed site
is effectively
a valley
and a natural watercourse
and the rainwater
surface water runs down that valley
through the plenty brook
through the tivoli brook
and out to sea
it is liable to flooding
it was last flooded in june 2021 so not
that long ago
and i cannot see from the proposals that
have been put forward by the developer
any satisfactory mitigation
that is going to solve the flooding
problem
either now or for the future
that leads us on sir to
the issue that again has been raised
already about sewage
far too frequently in the last two
summer seasons
margate main sands
and various of the bays of thanet
have been subjected to pollution from
raw sewage
released into the sea
by southern water
because the only alternative was to
allow that sewage to back up into
people's homes and gardens
and there was at least one area uh
infantic near ecole where that actually
happens or has happened on a reasonably
regular basis because the pump
continually fails
and that's not a pretty sight either
so southern water have done
most recently
frequently what they've had to do which
is to
release raw sewage into the sea to
prevent
flooding in
people's homes
that in turn has fouled the beaches
and we've had
thousands and thousands of pounds worth
of bad publicity
as a result
which of course at the height of the
tourist season which has already been
fairly rocky for the last couple of
years
has been singularly distressing for
those trying to make a living out of
tourism
the
sewage situation as it stands is not
sustainable
as it stands
um back in i think 1983
i declared open personally and somewhere
god helped me there's my name on a plate
on the door of the
forness point sewage worked
and that was supposed to be the
state-of-the-art
uh facility that was going to solve all
planets sewage problems and prevent the
use of a short sea outfall but in those
days of course long sea outflows were
still permitted they're not now thank
god
it's become apparent since that as we've
added more and more housing into than it
the system simply cannot cope
for why because and i had this explained
to me by southern waters engineers very
recently after the most recent incident
we actually went into it in some grim
detail
fact of the matter is that the surface
water from the roads
and the roofs
goes into the same system that carries
the sewage
and when you get the kind of storms that
we've had in the last few years and
particularly in the last few months
the system simply becomes overwhelmed
the storm drains cannot cope and the
only solution is to
is to release raw sewage into the sea
now if we can't cope now
under the system is going to take
millions of pounds and many years to
resolve
because the only way to resolve this is
to separate out
rainwater
from
foul water
none of the houses proposed as i
understand it have gray water systems
for instance
each and every one of those has a roof
that will drain off onto the land mostly
onto tarmac which will then
drain into the roads
this is a relatively modest development
even this one is going to add
to an already very bad problem
and
that is why one of the reasons why craig
mckinley and um
i can't remember i think it may have
been mrs smith
said craig mckinley and i
have called for a moratorium on house
building
until we've sorted out
the sewage issues for the whole of the
isle of planet
because we cannot go on as we are
and perversely again what we're seeking
to do is to add more and more and more
roofs
and more and more
tarmac drives
and more and more roads and gullies
pouring into an already
inadequate sewage system
so i would argue very strongly
the combination of the
um capacity for the site to flood
together with the failure of the sewage
system to be able to cope
militates very heavily indeed against
this development and indeed others which
we shall no doubt find ourselves having
to oppose in due course
whether or not this one goes through
the final area that i want to cover is
agricultural land
i have
spent many months now doing battle with
successive secretaries of state and
indeed with the prime minister
to try to protect
our farmland
which is part of our
local heritage and i'll come back to
that again in a moment
found it
historically has been an agricultural
area
probably three quarters of the island
much of it represented by
rhys pew who you counselors pew who you
will hear from later
um is farmland is agricultural land
almost all of it is very high grade land
it's alluvial soil
um it's so good that when for example as
a westward cross
they develop farmland they take the top
meter of soil off
and take it away and sell it
and we're losing i mean literally losing
to sale from developments our topsoil
historically than it has grown
cabbages cauliflowers potatoes
as well as of course
some livestock sheep
and some cattle but not very much
we cannot go on
sacrificing our agricultural land
to development unnecessarily because
there are brownfield sites available
the government is at last coming round
to my way of thinking
and policy has changed
and is changing
and in a couple of weeks time i suspect
you'll find the minister of state at the
department for agriculture
making an announcement about how we need
to be much much more self-sufficient
in the food that we produce
food that we eat
in order to avoid the
co2 costs of importing it and also of
course the
to try and make ourselves more depen
independent
of
other countries
um
the particular site
the shotgun dane road proposed
development
will make there is no doubt about this
will make
that farm unviable
and we have to understand that
the other developments
that i mentioned earlier garland west
gate birchington
and brooks and hill
successively will make other farms
unviable because
you have to have some economy of scale
we're not into prairie farming in than
it
we grow
good relatively modest crops
but there has to be enough space to grow
them
if we build over all of this farmland
which is in the local plan at the moment
then farming in than it will not be
viable
now
in the developers
submission they said there was
nothing of any notable heritage interest
and that the heritage aspects of this
were of
negligible significance
forgive me
farming is part of fannet's heritage
it's a part of our natural heritage
the farm land is part of our heritage
the environment
the habitat is part of our heritage
what we're talking about is destroying
so much of this
that there will be nothing left worth
saving
and happily that is an argument that i
think i'm at last beginning to win
with government and again it would be
perverse if
this and other developments in fanuc
were allowed to go ahead at the very
moment
when government was saying actually hang
on a minute we need this farmland to
grow our crops on
and to protect our environment
i am astonished that the
requirement placed initially by thailand
district council i believe
upon the development for an imp
environmental impact assessment
um was scoped out
because of the viability of the scheme
it is no longer considered worthy of
consideration i find that
at best
incomprehensible and at worst a disgrace
so so for all of those reasons
i believe that
only is this
develop proposed development
of itself
undesirable
but the message that it would send out
were it to be allowed to go ahead
and you may or may not consider this to
be a fair considerable consideration but
the message that it would send out were
it to be allowed
will have a devastating effect upon the
whole of the agriculture of the isle of
phanet the environment of the isle of
phanet
and the infrastructure of the isle of
planets so
for all of those reasons i believe that
this application should be rejected
thank you very much
i'm very happy to answer any questions
thank you sir roger that's a very very
helpful submission thank you obviously
covers quite a lot of
ground just a couple of questions
uh
from the you mentioned 1973 floods and
the 2000 and those june 2021 floods and
i've seen those sort of reference
elsewhere in some of the documentation
what did those actually what did those
starting with the recent one what did
they amount to from your
the recent one with significant flooding
of the shot and dane road
um
and
if you know the road because because the
the road is on the top end of one side
of a valley if you like with the um
graveyard and the crematorium on one
side
um the water drains down that slope
into these fields it's not brilliant for
the margay cricket club who find their
pitch waterlogged on for other two
frequent occasions um because the the
club itself and and a lot of the
farmland is at the bottom of the valley
um we don't tend to think of spanish as
being
um through hills and valleys but
effectively this this entire site
is located on either side of and in the
bottom of the farm is located on either
side of it in the bottom of a valley
that valley was flooded in the 1973
floods
a much wider area with devastating
effect
was flooded a lot of westgate was
flooded
as well as this entire site
and the plenty brook was i understand i
wasn't actually i've been around for a
long time but i wasn't here in 1973.
um and i i'm told by those who were
that the the effect on the main sands of
the flooding of the plenty of the um
tivoli brook
sorry the plenty brook is a one in
hernen bay which i have a similar
problem with um
was quite devastating so
i think the
june 2021 incident
was less severe certainly than the one
in 1973
but both was significant
and i'm astonished
that this is not referred to in the kent
county council's submission
okay that's helpful thank you um
mr williams have you got any questions
of sir roger
thank you sir sir roger
with respect we'll take the same
approach thank you very much and deal
with it with our respective witnesses um
as we go through the various topics
thank you very much indeed
okay thank you
thank you very much
roger it's very helpful thank you thanks
now next on my list is
um
counselor pew
hello good afternoon
finally good afternoon we did start this
morning didn't we
um i would just like to
start by thanking everyone uh today and
for everyone that's already spoken um i
appreciate that a lot has already been
covered by sir roger gail
and other witnesses so i will be as
brief as i can because i appreciate
there's a lot to go through so i just
want to cover um just a few aspects um
and trying and i'll try my best not to
go over what's already been discussed
but
to provide some context is that i'm a
district councillor for the fanuc
villages ward which is the uh
particularly the rural ward of the
entire district of the entire isle of
planet um my ward covers about 40
of the entire district um to provide you
a bit of context of its size um
and is predominantly full of villages as
per the name um with a variety of farms
and agricultural land my the boundary of
my ward is schotton dane road so all of
the land south of shot and dane road um
and up to
this site
is the boundary so although this site
isn't in my ward i have residents that
are bounded onto it who are greatly
concerned not only about overlooking
um and particularly the risk of runoff
water and flooding i know that roger
gale has alluded to um
excuse me has alluded to
the propensity for shot and done rotate
flood heavy rainfall that's something
that i have witnessed as a councillor
and as have residents
on almost a yearly basis during heavy
rainfall so it's not exactly limited to
just extreme floods and extreme weather
events so i think that's really
important to uh to acknowledge
my concern as well is that particularly
as a district and i know that we've said
about the local plan and that it
shouldn't be
uh referenced too much so i try not to
but
across the entirety of the iron
authentic we already have over 9 000
consents um 9 000 homes have been
consented they haven't been built yet
um as an aisle and the local demand for
new housing i think last year we only
completed about 200 homes
excuse me
so where was i um over the last year i
think in planets 200 new homes were
built
year on year before that it's always
teetered around about 100
so i'm incredibly concerned and
applications such as this and can be
seen to try and solve a perceived
housing crisis or housing shortage
i think it's also important to remember
and acknowledge that sir roger girl is
right and counselor kerry boyd said the
same in that this risks this application
if approved
uh risks becoming a bit of a domino
effect
and wiping out many farming families
that have been in planet and farming for
generations of hundreds of years
and i think we've got a real risk here
that actually it will do irreparable
damage to the entirety of planet and to
our agricultural land
and it is for that reason and many
others then i would urge you to refuse
refuse this application thank you
sorry i had not uh muted myself thank
you councillor pugh for those comments
again they're very very helpful and very
useful
uh for me
mr williams any questions of counselor
pew no thank you sir thank you
um
thank you councillor pugh um
now next on my list
we've got mr nib but we've already
learned that mr nib does not wish to
speak certainly at this point
uh so going back up to mr mr brennan you
weren't with us earlier on before lunch
but are you with us
now
no it doesn't appear to be
okay if mr brennan does reappear at some
point because obviously he has expressed
a wish to speak if he does
reappear at some point i don't know
might have lost connection or whatever
then i will of course seek to uh
make it possible for him to speak at
some convenient point
during the
proceedings uh
so if anybody knows mr brennan that you
could let kindly let him know but i'll
leave the opportunity open
i think
then according to the list that i have
got those are all the interested parties
who wish to speak
at this stage just to check there is
there anybody who wanted to speak
who
hasn't as yet
no okay thank you
and thank you again for all those
helpful submissions that are
very useful
uh
to me
now
moving then to item
on the agenda
and this
relates to
matters that have been raised
already today is flooding and drainage
so the
formatted this session is that obviously
the
propellants
witness mr travis has already produced a
proof of evidence
seeking to deal with
and respond to the matters raised
uh regarding flooding and drainage
and i think sewerage
as well so the purpose of this session
is first of all
i think it'd be helpful
for those people who've not read mr
travis's proof of mr travis we have mr
travis i see appeared so welcome mr mr
travis
that the performance i envisaged that
that a good opportunity for mr travis to
if you like sort of
talk the inquiry through his proof and
the most sort of relevant parts of the
approve
and then
i i and any other interested parties
would be able to ask you
questions
uh as
we so fit
i don't think and i don't know if mr
livingstone could confirm there's no
actual count council witness being put
forward in this regard on flooding and
drainage
uh no no council witness being put
forward sir
okay i mean if there are any sort of
questions related to the council would
you be the person to sort of without
putting you on the spot obviously not
being a flooding and drainage sort of
expert but there's anything sort of
generally
you might be yeah yes that that's that's
absolutely fine i can pick up any any
particular questions as much as i can
okay thank you i've just noticed that mr
nibb has just joined us
i think i saw
hello mr nib good afternoon
were you intending to speak there was
some sort of confusion as well you
intended to speak during the flooding
and drainage part of the agenda which
we're now at
is it your intention to do i i all i
intended to do was just ask questions of
the
of the um appellant's witness on this
point that's that's absolutely fine i
was just going through the procedure
whereby mr travis is ready to talk
everybody through his proof
and then the opportunity for
interested parties such as yourself
and indeed me as the inspector too to
ask any questions
uh that might be that might be relevant
so absolutely there is the opportunity
thank you
okay mr williams
thank you sir i was also just going to
say
i have been keeping a note on uh of the
points that have been raised
in the earlier submissions by third
parties and rule six um discussions
i think it would be quite helpful if at
some point i could just run through the
bullet points um with mr travis to make
sure that we feel we have covered the
points that were raised
yes that's absolutely fine i mean i've
noticed a few things down as well that i
was going to ask it may well be that
those points are similar points i don't
know but things that came up from uh you
missed some and
they were they were a number but i would
just like to
do our best to take this opportunity to
get all of the points out at one
at one time okay yeah that is sensible
in terms of me hearing from all the
parties on this this issue then i think
yeah now is the time to sort of for the
parties to do that so uh that approach
seems absolutely fine uh from my point
of view thank you
okay well that's great thank you very
much
so mr travis
over to over to you please
thank you good afternoon
um
as let's go when i go through my proof i
will refer to a couple of core documents
that you might want to have to hand as
well
um it'll be core document 1.58
which is the flood risk assessment
i'll also refer to
core document 1.08
which is utility law solutions file
drainage analysis which deals with
a number of the foul drainage matters
are raised
and also refer to core documents 7.01
which is the letter from kent county
councillors the lead local flood
authority
um
which has been referred to today which
is dated the 19th of
november
thank you what was that last one was
that 7.01 7.01 it's the letter from kent
county council from the 19th of november
um
which refers to some of the points
around tivoli brooke
right okay i'm just going to get that up
now so i can have it
ready for me i've
i found that okay
just give me a moment while i get your
proof in front of me as well please
okay and then just so everybody knows to
be clear
once
rather than people sort of interject
with questions as we go i think it's
probably
best and most efficient if mr travis
goes through
his
proof and then at the end i will give
the opportunity for any questions
to be
asked and as i said i might have some
myself as well
okay okay thank you
thank you very much um so just just to
recap in part of my proof um
my proof of evidence isn't responding
directly to the local planning authority
lead local flood authority or
environment agency or southern water
all of whom have raised no objections to
the application on flood risk grounds
subject to planning conditions
the purpose of my evidence is to respond
to the
some stone excuse me some stone ward
residents association the third party
objections
and to assist with an explanation as to
what led the local planning authority
lead local flood authority environment
agency and southern water to their
decision
and why the proposed development
complies with all
national and local policies with regard
to flood risk and drainage
during the preparation as proof of
evidence i visited the appeals site and
i'm i'm very familiar with flooding
issues around the shopping day margate
area having worked in this region for a
long time
um
on a number of applications and on some
of the other watercourses that have been
uh mentioned by
by people earlier before
um
if i can just take the beginning when we
start out in terms of flood risk and we
look at a site
we initially have what we call a
pre-application consultation which we
undertook with kent county council
back in july 2019
and that's in co document 1.58
appendix 5 and that demonstrates
we consulted very early on about
flooding in this area and the historic
flooding and kent county council
responded on that so we were aware for
those matters
and
we then continued on to produce a flood
risk assessment which was produced and
submitted in may 2020 and that is called
document 1.58
um upon review of that kent county
council as a lead local flood authority
they commented on the flood risk
assessment on the 27th of july
um 2020 that's co-document three page
five and had no objection to the
development on flood risk grounds
the environment agency also reviewed the
fra on the 30th of july 2020
commenting that the application could be
granted
subject to a series of conditions and
that's also
within code document 3 page 10.
also southern water responded to the
plan application the 3rd of august and
raised no objection that's also core
document 3
page 23.
if we if we take through um
those initial consultations
kent county council set out as the lfa
set out the criteria for developing the
site with regard to flooding and surface
water drainage
they put forward that all
surface water drainage from roofs roads
etc should be disposed of by to
infiltration if possible they also
provided some information on the local
flooding incidents
a tivoli book wasn't mentioned as a
separate issue within that consultation
um
from the lead local floor authority to
ourselves because of its location
if we then work forward
the site in its entirety is located
within what we call flood zone 1 which
is outside of the 1 000 year probability
of fluvial river flooding and that's a
0.1
annual exceedance of probability
so that demonstrates the sites at low
risk from what we call fluvial flooding
the detailed geology of the site beneath
beneath the site is chalk which
obviously has quite a high infiltration
potential
although it was identified in the
initial assessments that that would be
variable
it was confirmed by a series of
soakaways that were undertaken on site
if we look at core document 1.58
appendix 7
which is the so-called results
demonstrates that the site
in terms of disposal by soakaways is
very effective
and therefore
that was the chosen measure to to
dispose of surface water on the site
we also looked at groundwater flooding
which is section 4.4
within the flood risk assessment called
document 1.58
um
i could draw your attention to to
drawing six which identifies where there
may be high risk a moderate risk of some
of the groundwater flooding associated
with the chalk
i would also
note to draw you back to appendix seven
where all of the soakaway tests we
undertook didn't
exhibit any groundwater strikes at down
to three meters
start to interrupt you just mentioned
drawing six
that's in the f4a that's within the fr a
uh if you go towards the back of the
document
up to page 35
around about page 43 i've got a paper
copy you'll have a pdf
page what's the game
it'll be around about 40. i've got a
paper copy in front of me
the numbers will be slightly different
for you and i right i'm
drawing number six you say
yeah it's titled groundwater flood risk
map
it demonstrates the the majority of the
development site being at low risk of
groundwater flooding
uh it's orange and yellow
yes i've got it okay thank you and if
you move forward one page to join five
um that's the the statutory flood zones
that you'll be used to seeing from the
environment agency which demonstrates
the site isn't at risk of tidal or
fluvial flooding
just just moving forward from that
um the environment agency produced a
series of what we call complex surface
water flood mapping and that's up
towards drawing eight onwards
which is a couple of pages forward
now
what these drawings are showing here
is it's more details with regard to
velocity depth and hazard ratings it's
not normally publicly available on the
environment agency website but it
enables a more
detailed analysis of the risk associated
with surface water flooding and if you
move through the pages
through drawing
one
two
three and four what you can see um
is the parts of the site that are
subject to what we call pluvial flooding
and you'll note on drawing 8.1
we'd expect to see this pluvial flooding
that's effectively where you get excess
rainfall falling onto land and it
creates
rivers that are only there at time of
excess rainfall sometimes referred to as
ephemeral flooding
and what you can see here is it does
demonstrate
a lot of the instances that a number of
the third parties have commented on
today with flooding through the centre
of the site around shotgundane road
around hearthstone road and through
tivoli park as well
and i wanted to identify the point of
the evidence that we we weren't aware of
this level of flooding and that's what
produced some of the mitigation as i go
through to look at all of the built
development in terms of housing and
residential set outside of the pluvial
flood zones
then where we have roads crossing them
in section
5 of the flood risk assessment
i identify the flood risk mitigation
measures in section 5.2
for residential dwellings will
sequentially develop the site by
restricting residential dwellings to
areas of the site
that are outside of the mapped extent of
surface water flooding
and that will set the finished floor
levels of a minimum of 150 millimeters
above external levels for dwellings
i also identify further about the main
road and the link roads as to where
we're
crossing the pluvial
flooding areas we'll situate box
corvettes to allow dry access and egress
into and out of the site
just for completeness as i talk through
those mitigation measures
i also identify
surface water attenuation
we're adopting the surface water
management strategy using
infiltration-based suds that have
two real purposes on this site one is to
take
water out of this tivoli brook catchment
and put it to ground so it doesn't
increase pressure further down because
it's been infiltrated in you won't see
the water going into tivoli brook at
such a great rate
and therefore it removes this part of
the catchment from the flooding problems
and pressures some of the third parties
have spoke about downstream and that
provides a betterment
and that betterment was also agreed with
kent county council and they refer to it
in court documents document 7.01
i'd also talk about in terms of suds
it's well known through the syria
research guides and the the suds
handbook that suds also aim to remove
pollutants from road runoff roof run off
etc
thereby reducing any potential pollution
from surface water runoff from the site
i'd also place one further comment on
that and that's within
section 5.2 i identified that the
surface water attenuation
has been designed up to a 1 in 100 year
event plus a 40 allowance for climate
change
i was conscious
i was asked earlier if uh through the
third party comments do some of the
assessments take into account climate
change
and the answer is that they do
with regard to
the drainage on site
the proposed site would reduce the
greenfield runoff utilizing the infantry
infiltration providing a demonstrable
betterment regarding surface water
runoff this would also aid in a
long-term strategy to reduce flooding
within tivoli park
the proposals are to provide a series of
detention basins and infiltration
trenches
within the site to deal with runoff and
also use plots open ways um
the use of of that is
as we what we talk about is a hierarchy
of drainage for disposal of surface
water that's identified in h3 of the
building regulations um
2000 and what what that proposal is that
there's effectively
three ways that we dispose
of surface water and if i point you to
paragraph 6.3
in the flood risk assessment
um we talk about hierarchy of discharge
it says it's quite important to see that
the top level of hierarchy of discharge
is an adequate soak away or some other
adequate infiltration system now the
idea of that infiltration based suds is
that we remove water from flowing over
the land into rivers we put it into into
groundwater so it takes longer to come
out through as if you remember the
hydrological site um cycle from school
it takes longer to come out
the other the other parts of
the drainage hierarchy is obviously if
you can't go to soak away you go
watercourse or if not you go to a sewer
but on this development site we're not
going to watercourse or
let's see where we're doing it through
infiltration
um
excuse me
it is proposed that the maintenance of
the suds drainage features would be in
line with the the suds mario manual and
that's the public document syria
c753 that's uh commonly used for
designation sign of drainage systems
um
at this stage of the outline application
the maintenance is envisaged will be
undertaken by a private maintenance
company
and relevant agreements will be entered
into you the maintenance is carried out
the lifetime of the development it's
also subject to the suggested planning
condition that we've put to ensure that
comes forward and details of the other
suds features on site and maintenance
will be considered at further stage
detailed design
and when the layout is being being
produced and fixed so the level of
detail provided with the fra at the
moment is sufficient to demonstrate that
steam would be deliverable on site
[Applause]
if i move to it through onto section
three of my proof of evidence
i look at the local policies here from
the thanet district
council draft local plan i'm not going
to read them out
there is policy cco one
which is directing new development only
being
acceptable in areas that are outside
flood zone two and three
and that assessment should be made of
all risks of flooding including surface
and groundwater flooding
i know the flu the submitted flood risk
assessment it doesn't propose any
development within flood zone two or
three
and the risk of surface water and
groundwater flooding has been assessed
through the flood risk assessment as
i've described earlier therefore it is
compliant with the policy cco one
uh policy cco2
refers to development using sustainable
drainage systems where possible and also
showing that
they have robust long-term maintenance
plans again that's included within the
flood risk assessment
and subject to condition which was
agreed with the llfa so therefore the
submitted flood risk assessment
demonstrates the site's compliance with
those local policies
if i move forward just to start to
address some of the third party
objections which i do in the proof
and i'll also cover some of the topics
that were spoken about today
um
one of the topics that came forward is
that the proposed site is at risk of
flooding and development would increase
flood risk for neighbouring areas um
in my proof of evidence at point 4.2
and within core document 1.58
which is the flood risk assessment we
recognize that the site is at flood risk
through pluvial flooding
um however through the mitigation
measures incorporated into the design
by restricting the residential dwellings
to areas of the site outside of the 1
000 year
surface water event and outside of the
map hazard ratings greater than moderate
we can demonstrate that there is no
flood risk to the development in its
built form and furthermore by taking the
existing runoff into plot soakaways and
infiltration basins and trenches as i
described earlier that will create a
betterment for downstream
and i'd also note that
kent council's lead local flood
authority called document 7.01
and stated that through collecting
surface water attenuation discharge to
the ground we would anticipate that any
contribution to overland surface water
flow routes will be reduced it is likely
therefore that the development may have
a positive impact on local flood risk
experienced at heart down hearthstone
road and that's at the bottom of the
site
i just refer you sir to drawing 11
within
um core document or one point five eight
um it's quite quite a full drawing um
towards the back it's just before
appendix um one
what's its title
um it is called surface water flood
outline overlay
and it's the last of the drawings
it's quite a busy drawing
i think it's pdf page 75 of 184
thank you okay it's uh
surface water flood outline overlay yes
i've got it thank you it's quite a busy
drawing but what
what you can see there is that i've
overlaid the thirty hundred and thousand
year flood extents on the development
and what we can demonstrate is that the
built form is outside of of
where that is and we can also see the
indicative locations of the base and
some of the drainage features as well
so just to the next objection that i had
within that section four of my proof of
evidence
whilst the it was in relation to the
sewage system is out of date and already
struggling to cope
the proposed development risks more
sewage spills onto the beaches um i
would point out and refer to some of the
third party comments already that it was
current about surface water getting into
the fowl
uh and that that was creating
an element of of the sewage oh
they're called csos their sewage
overflow spills where the network's full
of a mixture of foul and surface surface
water so it spills over into the sea
um i would know that this development
has separate surface water and foul with
all surface water going to ground
therefore there is no surface water
being put into the foul system
which is what causes the spills at time
um
and also know that while the flood risk
assessment and my evidence doesn't
specifically deal with aspects of foul
drainage i would refer yourself sir and
third parties
to the um utility law solutions report
which is core document 1.08
um which details why the development
will not increase
sewerage spills onto the beaches and
furthermore it details the process
for southern water to upgrade their
network ahead of the development being
constructed
and i think that goes a long way to
answer some of the the concerns
just to some of the uh the rule six
objections now there was a comment that
the lower field regularly holds water
during heavy rain
um
i'd note surface water flood risk maps
clearly show this impact and i refer you
to drawing 11 that we just had up a
second ago
um where we demonstrated
that we can see we we're aware of that
pluvial flooding we're aware there's a
history of it this develop will not
resolve all flooding in kent however it
will do what it can
to provide a betterment to reduce
flooding on hearthstone road
through the consultation with the lfa we
agreed at an early stage about
sequentially developing the site to
restrict in the residential dwellings to
areas outside of the thousand-year
surface water flood event and thereby
mitigating that risk in line uh with
national planning policy framework
and also just just touch again on on
that betterment side that we would
provide uh which was agreed
there's another comment about other
proposed homes uh 450 homes and 250 that
have all been approved
adjacent to
some stone grange and another 1450 are
allocated in the local plan at westwood
close to central cemetery
i know that i looked at a number of
those applications and that they are
also proposing disposal
of surface water from the development to
infiltration
and therefore part of the comment that
it hasn't been taken into account
but by virtue that's going to
infiltration it's not water that would
be flowing
directly overland through our site um
i'd furthermore note that on the the
recent planning application that was
there the lead local flood authority had
no objections to their method of surface
water drainage
if i just move on to to the sort of
latter point around tivoli brooke
um this was one of the one of the main
concerns of swara
in that the proposals hadn't taken
significant account of the presence of
the historic watercourse
and that flows in underground culvert
from tivoli would on to margate sands
and down
i know we did consult the lead local
flood authority of this it wasn't raised
at the time
in terms of our site our drainage is
contained within our site we're not
creating any more water or forcing any
more water down towards tivoli brook
so if anything we have a betterment
effect by reducing that water further
um
i find it a little bit difficult to
comment anymore on the
historic works that were undertaken by
the llfa and that were written within
their core documents 7.01 as to
ownership and other aspects because
that's not within the reason to the
flood risk assessment
it's just for
myself and the fra to demonstrate that
we are not creating any increase in
flood risks downstream downstream we're
providing a betterment where we can
and that by bringing this forward this
development forward there'll be no
increase of flooding as further accounts
for the mppf
so to uh to summarize
the development sites located within
flood zone 1
the residential dwellings are restricted
to areas outside of the 1 000 year
surface water event
and outside of the map hazard rating
greater than moderate as was agreed by
the lead local flood authority there are
no statutory objections to the proposed
flood risk and drainage strategy by the
environment agency southern water
or the local flood authority
it was agreed
by the lead local flood authority that
all runoff will be attenuated by
infiltration for storms up to 100 year
event plus an allowance of 40 percent
for climate change that's in line with
current planning policy
the series of suds measures have been
proposed to provide attenuation and also
water quality benefits again
in line with planning policy
planning condition will be entered into
to ensure there's long-term maintenance
of the subsystem the lifetime of the
development
and it is my professional opinion the
flood risk assessment complies with
national and local policies
with regard to flood rescue drainage
i've
identified
in appendix one each part of the mppf
plan and practice guidance where there
are aspects in my proof of evidence and
where we comply with
um any of the remaining aspects in
relation to flood risk and drainage can
be adequately dealt with by
a suitable word planning condition which
i've put at 5.9
within my proof of evidence therefore in
conclusion
it's my professional opinion that the
development should not be included on
club risk or drainage
thank you
thank you mr travis uh
that's helpful thank you
is there anything
i've got a few questions that i wanted
to ask and obviously others i think
probably will do as well
was there anything at this point mr
williams you wanted to say or or or ask
mr travis in terms of that list you had
well i think perhaps just
two points that are on the list which
were touched on but my benefit from just
addressing
specifically one was there were a number
of references to
historic flooding issues
um 1973 i think was mentioned 2021
and i just
wondered if
you mr travis could just give us your
response to that and the relevance of it
and your conclusions
um okay well in in terms of the historic
flooding issues that were described
today 1973 and 2021
um they're exactly what we'd expect to
see um as i referred you before to
drawing eight
um 8.1 onwards you can see that the
flooding that's been described by
residents follows
the pluvial maps that we we
see within the flood risk assessment so
it comes as no surprise to me that
references made
shot and elaine flooding references made
to overland flow flooding and flooding
of
um hots down road at the bottom
and also so flooding
they're all well they're all well
documented and shown within the
political flood maps and they have
historic anecdotal evidence that's been
provided today is what i would have
expected
thank you
and then a point i think i just didn't
know sufficiently clearly
the concerns that relate to
the
mixing of the surface water potential
runoff
in relation to foul sewage can you just
explain again how
whether those concerns arise or how
that's treated on site because that's
obviously
some concern to the wider areas as it's
been expressed rather than specifically
what's happening on the site
um that's quite right in terms of this
development it will be created with a
separate surface water and foul drainage
system
therefore foul drainage will go into
southern waters fowl drainage system as
was identified in the
utility law solutions report core
document 1.08
surface water will not go into foul it
would be a
completely separate system
all surface water drainage on this site
from roofs roads and hard paved surfaces
will go to infiltration so it will not
increase the pressure
um
on the foul network from surface water
and that was very key from the very
first
discussions that were held with the lead
local flood authority if i refer you
back to
appendix 5 of the flood risk assessment
which is core document 1.58
where the lead local food authority was
looking for surface water to be drained
through infiltration because they're
well aware of the problem that's
occurring
with surface water and foul and
misconnections
thank you sir they were the points that
were on my list that i felt worth
raising thank you very much
okay thank you thank you mr travis again
i'm aware of uh sir rogers got our hand
up and i think mr dickman has appeared
as well so i think i'm aware of some
pressure for people to start asking uh
you want to ask some some questions
which i'll i will open up to just in
terms of when we do that is
as we've been going for about an hour
and so six minutes and we're online
do you think now is the time just for a
short comfort break before we come back
for
questions
otherwise we get into the questions
which could sort of take a reasonable
amount of time we may be sort of then
just splitting them up so
would uh everyone happy with a short 10
minute break now
and then
we can come back for
questions
i expected but maybe just the
appropriate time
okay
okay and so sir roger was your hand up
because you wanted to ask a question or
was there another matter you wanted to
no i wanted to ask a question okay
absolutely i will give you a chance to
do that once we come back from the from
the break so let's have a
let's have a short break
and then we'll come back four questions
for mr travis from interested parties
and myself so it's now 3
so if we have i'll be going 15 minutes
let's have 13 minutes so we'll come back
at
thank you
okay welcome back
everybody
could just wait to see miss
travis okay
right well i moved to the opportunity
for interested parties to
ask questions which i think i will
i've seen various hands go up i think
i'll allow interest to ask questions
before
i do and i can cover off anything which
hasn't already been
um
asked if i start with as the rule six mr
dickman you want you want to go first
and then i'll go to
i'm happy for sir roger to go first if
he wishes i know he asked me for me so
i i don't mind
i don't mind if if you want to go first
that's fine
sorry
i had a frozen mouse it's on it's
unfrozen
um thank you very much indeed it's most
kind of oh good grief sorry about that
go away
um
trying to do too many things at once
mr travis i'm not expert in in this at
all
but um i'd be grateful if you could
clarify exactly what you mean by
infiltration
because it seems to me that that's
what's been happening in the past
effectively
um sorry about it there's nothing
there's no way i can stop it um
if
attenuation means holding
groundwater rainwater in tanks before
then releasing it
i'd be grateful if you could indicate
where it's going to be released too
um i noticed that you said
that
obviously
it's a given isn't it that the sewage is
going to go into the southern water
sewage system
so that of course is an addition to the
but what i'm really concerned about
because than it perversely while
um
we get flooding in the
soggy bit in the middle of your sight
that you say you're not going to build
on
um we get flooding there tanis also
suffers from a water shortage
and we have to pipe water already from
the midway towns
because the fanny's aquifer is drying up
and the reason for that of course is
because of so much water is being used
for drinking water
car washing flushing lavatories and all
sorts of things
can you explain to me as a layman what
effect
this proposal
on its certain freestanding never mind
added to others is going to have on the
phanet aquifer
please
thank you sir roger i got i got three
questions in there so your initial
question was me to explain infiltration
so um
as i as i touched on earlier when i was
talking about the drainage hierarchy um
when we look at developments we look at
three ways of you will drain them you
can either do what we call infiltration
which is where we take water and we put
it into a large engineered soak away
as i explained earlier we've done a
series of soakaway tests on site down to
two and a half and three meters and
demonstrated that the water will soak
away
very quickly and that leads you to the
point if you say the impact on the the
aquifer or by putting infiltration it
will recharge the aquifer
because that water will go directly to
ground as opposed to running off
um so that's what infiltration means
and it's engineered infiltration um so
it's not when you look at infiltration
just directly onto the ground you only
get at a certain rate when we engineer
it and we dig down we put focus at two
and a half three meters below ground
level
and they'll recharge much quicker
um
your second part of that question was
about holding water and attenuation and
that's quite right so
as part of the design
there's a series of what we call
detention basins and if you
you won't have it in front of you but
drawing 11 that i referred to within the
risk assessment showed where those
basins were going to be so what will
happen is we'll get a rainwater storm
generally something greater than one in
30 years that basin will start to fill
up with water it'll hold it there and
then
as time goes on it'll drain down into
the aquifer and that's that's where the
water is being held in the basins and
then it's released into the ground so
it's not going to be flowing down
from the developed areas into tivoli
brook and that's where the betterment
comes from
forgive me are those um
what you
refer to as retention basins are they
what other developers sometimes call
balancing ponds or is that something
different no it's to say it's the same
sort of thing we tend to refer to as
being detention when you use
infiltration and balancing ponds when
you've got a positive discharge that
they take they they do exactly the same
thing it's just that the ones on this
site are going to ground
that was established very early on in
the initial consultations the lead local
flood authority because what kent county
council is trying to do is put more
water into infiltration so it doesn't
get into the foul network and it doesn't
result in overland flow
because the problem you then have is if
you've got a lot of overland flow it can
get into the foul network and cause your
problem there so what we're trying to do
here
is take all the surface water and and
put it into the ground so none of the
runoff on this site goes into the fowl
and so that leads me to your second
point which was
um
the sewage would go into the southern
water system that that's correct it
would but remember it's only foul flows
so it's quite a low level of sewage that
goes in
um all i can really do there um because
my evidence isn't concerned with foul is
just refer to the utility law solutions
report which was code occur 1.08
where they'd undertaken the foul
drainage analysis they'd agreed a point
of connection with southern water and
that rate of discharge that was
acceptable to them
um it's difficult for me to comment more
because southern water in control their
own network
and whatever upgrades are needed and but
but that is that is in in their gift
um your final comment a question that
you asked me
was what would the effect of this
proposal on the aquifer well there will
be no contamination of the aquifer
because they've been using subs and
things like detention basins there'd
also be
excuse me
interceptors placed where any highway
drainage
comes forward so if there was an oil
spillage etcetera it'd be captured
within
um within the interceptor so the water
quality benefit of this would also be
the betterment as well
and i think it's roger i've answered
your questions they wrote them down that
that's very helpful i mean just for
clarification this will be my final
point and then i'm going to shut up and
if i may sir i'm going to then have to
excuse myself i've got a parliamentary
meeting i've got to go to um but my
understanding is that southern water has
a statutory duty to provide this so
while you say it's in their gift
actually it isn't in the gift at all
they've got to do it well that's right
yeah
that's that's my um that's my coin of
phrase in their gift it is their
statutory duty yeah
okay thank you very much indeed thank
you thank you sir
thank you i'll join you tomorrow if i
may thank you
yes yeah thank you for your contribution
today
mr
dickerman would you like to
go next
thank you sir um perhaps uh rather than
a series of questions if i may better
explain our concerns
um and perhaps questions will
arise from that um
because we've heard from your concerns
this morning as part of the the uh your
opening statement so if you could sort
of keep it because if the idea of this
was that it's more
questions rather than i mean sometimes
it can drift a little bit into
uh you know like comments being made
which i think for this session is
probably sort of fine but if you could
try and sort of stick by and large to
questions please and that would be the
nature of this this session uh given the
nature of the land in as much that um it
has been at one time a creek um that
it's low lying and it takes the
catchment from her 1650 hectares um
is it not so much about the brook but
the fact that you're taking large
amounts of water even with the
mitigation and slowly transferring that
then down into the brook
um i think
mr dickman if i can split that into two
parts really um
obviously further upstream that there is
a catchment which generates what we call
that pluvial flooding that's flooding in
extreme events 20 years 7 500 years as i
explained on on drawing sort of eight
and drawing
um 11 within
my flood risk assessment core document
1.58 so that that water will always flow
at times of flood and this development's
not going to stop that because we put
the development outside of it
what we are doing is in terms of the
rain water that falls on the roads on
the roofs on the drives we're taking
that water and putting that into ground
through infiltration so we're
effectively removing that water from the
pluvial water that flows over land
so in doing that we're providing a
betterment by removing that part of the
catchment and putting it to ground but
what we can't do is i can't
i can't within the flood risk assessment
deal with that pluvial water flow
because to deal with that i'd have to
create a flood storage reservoir so
that's not something that we're required
to do by the nppf
or or that you'd feasibly look to do at
this point so i hope that answers your
question that that as you referred to as
the creek which is obviously it's part
of the catchment of tivoli brook that
would remain and then where we have the
built development surface water falling
on the roads the roofs and the drives
would be put to infiltration sort of
take it out of the system for a better
world
um given that um much of the water that
flows off the present farmland at the
moment is uh um
running off of land that's uh regulated
by law
um and that
we can't regulate those houses and hard
surfaces the chemicals that may or may
not go on to gardens
uh will the very nature of that water
that's running off that that area uh be
likely to continue to further
contamination
okay well in the way to deal with that
the way sustainable urban drainage
systems are designed is to provide water
quality benefits so what we do is we
call them treatment trains
so as this development moves from sort
of outline to detail that'll be when the
details of the treatment trains come
together so we typically say to put
three treatment trains in
which is what's recommending the suds
man you will have a gully pot so if
there's an oil spill or something like
that of a limited level it gets
collected in the gully part then it'll
run through some forms swale or some
filter media
before it actually infiltrates into the
ground so with studies and assessments
that have done as part of syria's built
environment
and the suds manual it demonstrates that
that provides what we call a water
quality treatment train so what you
should be seeing from this development
discharging to ground is reductions in
nitrate sulfates etc because it's not
agricultural land it becomes
like you say housing land
that's then going through the treatment
train and as part of that as as i
mentioned in my proof of evidence
there's a management and maintenance
aspect to that and that is also covered
with validation reports and other
aspects to show that it's maintained
throughout the lifetime of the
development
how sure can you be that these subs uh
will be affected the size of the estate
um
all i could refer you to there is in
terms of design guides such design
guides have been adopted across the
country
and they've been in existence for many a
year now and it is designed in line with
the syria suds manual for this type of
development it's national policy it's
industry standard guidance to
deal with water quality and attenuations
of flood water
given that um
if this bill does go ahead then it's
likely to they they they will build on
the other side the hill
uh how many subs can be put in to work
successfully for
a thousand plus houses
when you say how many suds can be put in
what kind of okay so what kind of
mitigation would be required
for a thousand plus ounces because quite
clearly if the 450 houses go in then it
sets precedent for the other bills well
if i if i just take a step back as part
of the nppf and flood guidance
each development's regulated so
what we would do in terms of when we
talk about suds that's sustainable urban
drainage systems so that's how we drain
the water from the site when we look at
each site as i've done with this one and
if we look at section
6 within the fra
what we've done
and you can see that in i think it's
appendix nine that shows the drainage
calculations social appendix eight
what we do for each site is we look at
the rainfall that falls on the site for
a range of return periods from a one
year up to 100 year plus allowance of 40
for climate change and then we designed
the suds for the density of the site
so a site that's got 450 units on would
have a certain size of soakaway certain
size of attenuation to provide
mitigation for that site
the site's got a thousand units on it
would obviously have a greater
level of attenuation basins and more
point sources to discharge because it's
larger but it's all done within industry
design calculations either through
software like micro drainage or software
like causeway flow so it's an
engineering calculation looking at the
hard paced surfaces and then calculating
what levels of attenuation and
infiltration can be taken on site
because although we're all on chalk in
ken
you know some places water runs away
really quickly but you can get what we
call sort of like
putty chalk where the top of the chuck's
not fractured it's kind of quite bitty
and the infiltration there's much less
so therefore you need a larger base and
that's why when you look at the
assessments that we've done here and
specifically around about the the soak
away test that we undertake undertook on
site in appendix 4 for the flood risk
assessment that's what's created that
design
uh given the circle ways that that i've
seen i have a limited knowledge um the
water often stays in the soak away for
some time as it drains as you say as it
drains down slowly
can those be prone to um blue-green
algae and if so do the um
do the filters actually take that out
um
it's it's unusual that a soaker be prone
to blue green alley because the time
that flourishes in the summer is the
time when you've not got a lot of
standing water around as you would in
winter now i'm just looking for the
point
in the flood risk assessment on page 33.
we talk about what we call drain down
times for each of the soak aways and
it's in
6.3.16 i'll i'll i'll just read it to
you it says surface water from
residential dwellings will be directed
to individual plot soakaways which will
manage post application surface watering
off from the site up to and including
the 100 year plus 40 climate change
rainfall event which achieves a 50 drain
down time within 24 hours so what that
means is if we have a 100 year event
and i had 40 percent onto that so i make
it 40 bigger that soak away would drain
down within 24 hours to empty
it's unlikely that you would get the
sort of blue-green algae bloom within 24
hours because the the basin would be dry
don't make sense
yeah yeah
and last um
to ensure that this um
runs correctly doesn't affect the uh the
athanic coast um
do i take it that you are um
depending on southern water improving
the system
um
i think as as that came across with with
sir roger that it is southern water
statutory duty to to undertake that
um
thank you very much and thank you for
your patience sir
thank you
sir
thank you mr dickman for those questions
and mr travis for those
responses that's all helpful thank you
i've got two hands up i think mr
was first and then uh councillor
farrance
thank you
um i've just got a couple of questions
i'd like to know
how whether the proposed um
the proposed survey of the surface water
drainage that's um
going ahead by
southern water this year
could affect
the proposals here
there is another thing i wanted to ask
were the any options to test the surface
water from the annual flooding
that's seen every year in tivoli woods
which is very adjacent
and subsequently tivoli brook
to make sure that any pollution from
this site
during and after construction is
contained within the proposed
attenuation measures
and uh what are the guarantees this
won't occur
because um i'm rather worried about
this
thing that
it's a self-contained development
visa v surface water
because i'm not certain
that
owing to my local experience that this
can actually be um
i can't see that you can contain all the
water within the site and allow it to
infiltrate just into the aquifer i think
that some of it
will go outside and i'd like to see it
testing outside the site for pollution
preferably in the tibley woods when it
floods every winter just to make sure
this isn't happening thank you
um
thank you uh
mr i picked
sort of four points out of there i i'm a
little bit unsure what you meant by this
the proposed southern southern water
works
um
if you could just explain what you meant
there
well southern water have said they're
doing a a a surplus water survey this
year
and obviously it will include this area
and uh maybe they
they might find that it drains a little
bit further than you say it does because
i don't think that you can contain it
purely in this site
well i i think there's
i think you've got two points there so
i'll start with the first one um we we
acknowledge we can't contain all the
flooding within this site and as i
presented in my evidence you will always
get pluvial flooding through the middle
of this site into arts down road
and then into
into tivoli brook because that that's
just going to keep happening and
occurring i think the surface water
survey that you're referring to is what
southern water are doing in this area is
they're looking to see if there are any
misconnections
of surface water into their foul network
because they know um i think as sir
roger said
um when when he made some third-party
questions that they're aware that
surface water gets into the foul network
so
i i i don't know what so then what we're
going to do with that but if
from my understanding of what kent
counts county councils the lfia is
saying there isn't a connection from
tivoli brook into our site
and so so i wouldn't expect that to be
seen
um
moving from that the areas of our site
that we're taking that's the roads the
roofs and the paved areas they're going
into
um the infiltration basins and and plot
soakers that we've got there now the
calculations within my fra which is
based on a site investigation of the
infiltration potential of the soakaway
shows that will work with a factory
safety of two
now that's in line with industry
practice and design it has been reviewed
by the lead local flood authority
the design of that for a reserved matter
scheme should this application should
this this appeal be granted
um
that will be subject to condition
so with it being subject to condition it
will be shown that the
the surface water network on site will
be cctv and demonstrated it's all built
in accordance with
uh with the design at reserve matter
stage
um
your other comment about testing the
annual flooding in in um
in tivoli brook um you you could you
could test the water there
and see if it's got any e coli in which
is a marker for sewage or you could test
if it's got any
um sort of sodium as a marker for salt
or any nitrates i'm not quite sure what
benefit that would have of you
for you because
there's quite a large catchment as we've
been talking mr dickman said around you
know
1650 hectares flowing into that so
be very difficult to identify where it
came from the only thing i can say is
that this development will have separate
surface water and foul
infrastructure and and therefore that
will be
won't produce pollution um
the only other comment um
i got you made was saying that it was a
self-contained site which which as i
previously said it will be
i hope it answers your questions
okay mr nib is that your questions
okay i've just got one more
question
occurred to me
i noticed that the attenuation measures
are going to be maintained during the
lifetime of the project
now does that mean that as soon as the
um construction is over
the maintenance will stop and thereby
the attenuation measures will
gradually fail until there is more
pollution in the local
area including tivoli brook
that is my question thank you
okay if i could answer that um the
phrases for the lifetime of the
development
if you just
allow me to read out the part of the
condition
which is the suggesters condition that
we have and i'll just read it from a
part where it says the scheme should be
based on section 66 of the submitted
flood risk assessment and should also
include the phasing for the
implementation of the surface water
drainage scheme appropriate operational
maintenance and access requirements for
each drainage feature or subs component
or adequately considered including any
proposed arrangements for future
adoption by any public or statutory
undertaker
furthermore the scheme should be control
constructed in full accordance with the
approved details and shall be managed
stroke maintained in accordance with the
approved maintenance and management
details for the lifetime of the
development
now i hope that answers your question
because what that's saying in layman's
terms is there's a condition that it has
to there has to be a management
maintenance plan for the lifetime of the
development set up so
it's not just going to be left when it's
constructed um there will be a
maintenance program that goes on
for the lifetime of the development
i hope that answers your question
thank you very much
thank you mr nib
and
now uh
councillor farron's please
thank you
um
what was you interested in the um little
exchange you had with um
sir roger
um
about southern water
so you said it was in their gift and and
then you agreed it was a statutory
expectation however
um as we all know around here and we're
not the only area in the country or
under southern water um
there's very little happening about the
dramatic release of sewage into the sea
um southern water don't seem to
[Music]
be under any requirements to
to to sort this out i mean they might
they do little things but it's still a
massive massive problem and we don't we
simply cannot see the end of it
um especially with you know the system
being used more and more so
how are they um bound
to do the works that are in association
with any
new development
okay um i'll take that question
obviously my my evidence really deals
with
sort of flood risk and drainage not not
specifically foul because there's a
separate report by
solutions that does deal with that but i
want to i'll i will
provide you with some answers to that
because
um
as far as i can but i would refer um
the inspector to the utility law
solutions reports it's a lot more
detailed than my answer to this question
effectively some of the water abound by
a statutory
um
they are the statutory undertaker and
they are bound to take sewage from
developments and upgrade their network
in accordance with what's coming forward
they do that through a process that they
call amp periods that's asset management
plan periods they run for blocks of five
years so they'll be well aware of the
local plan that was recently coming
forward and that what investment and
upgrades are needed within their network
to take the level of housing going
forward
sometimes it seems that things aren't
happening because for them to upgrade
their network over a period of five
years it does take a long time and but
they are statutorily bound by off-what
to undertake those those upgrades
i hope that answers um your question to
the best of my abilities
yes thank you um
i think you unders you know you probably
appreciate uh skepticism
i understand what you're saying yeah
thank you
it's a problem thank you
okay thank you councillor faris any more
questions
from interested parties for
mr travis uh
this boas
oh i think you're on mute
sorry thank you okay uh hopefully not a
good question to answer um you've talked
extensively about the sub system and
referred to it being maintained
throughout the lifetime
i just wondered who would actually be
paying and would be responsible for that
maintenance because you could imagine
see that going on for
oh a long time so who actually pays for
that
okay um at the moment uh where we where
it's left amount is it depends on
whether it's adopted by uh statutory
undertaker such as southern water or
whether it becomes part of a management
company so the way that that would work
is if it was adopted by southern water
there'd be adoption payment from the
developer to southern water and then the
residents through their relevant bills
that they paid for disposal surface
water soon and foul will go to the
statute you undertake it to maintain the
system if that doesn't occur and it's
done by a private management company
then effectively what happens is each
individual household pays a
a lease or a management payment to the
management company generally the
individuals within the estate form part
of the management company their point to
come
a point of reputable
civil engineering type company who will
maintain that throughout the lifetime of
the development
there's all sorts of clauses that are
put in there that if the the company
were to go bust it could reform etc and
so that's how it would be funded
thank you confirmed my fears it will
fall onto the residence to pay for it
okay miss bowers i didn't get your uh
you weren't one of the names i had down
before so just so i can make sure for my
notes because when i do my decision
everyone who speaks i have to make a
list of them all at the end of the day
no that's fine i i i came in a bit
earlier when the westgate and garland
lady jackie was making a statement so
i'm a resident and a member of the west
gate and garbage action group
and it's sarah bowers sarah bowers okay
thank you so if i referred you as a
local resident would that yeah yeah that
would be great thank you very much okay
good thank you for that clarification
thank you
and
uh
i've got another hand up uh
mr dickman is that you yes it's asking
for the question that's fine me again
i'm afraid um
it may be a question you can't ask uh
answer but um going on from what uh
sarah bowes has just asked about
maintenance
uh given that um
uh that kcc tdc in southern water uh
won't take on ownership of the brook
does that and and kcc have stated in a
reply to us
that it will fall to the uh landowners
uh could those um
people who buy those houses be um
responsible for the upkeep of the brook
as well
um thank you mr dick i think we're
confusing two two aspects there because
um what my spouse was asking about is
the maintenance of the suds the
sustainable madrid
sustainable urban drainage systems on
site
um
and and you're you're mentioning the
brook
um so the brook's offsite so that
wouldn't really
come into the the management company of
the site if that makes sense
uh only in this uh i i we will probably
contest that the brook is off actually
on site the brook runs down the middle
of the valley uh that's the issue so if
that if the houses are on that land
um and none of the uh statutory bodies
want to take ownership of it
uh and kcc quite clearly is saying to us
that that um
it will be um in the um it would be down
to the owners of the land which would be
the people who had the houses on it then
they may well be uh required to maintain
that as well
um
i think that's a difficult question for
me to really answer i appreciate that
probably for kccc but you know within
within land drainage law uh riparian
owners of land are responsible for
for their their parts of land um just
just because you brought back to miss
miss bowers comment i i would just
direct you to page 31 of the flood risk
assessment
um
311 where i detail what the suds
maintenance is for the site
um when we talk about they've been
maintained in line with the suds manual
and just to further elaborate on the
point i mentioned about the management
company it's standard for such features
within a new development to be
maintained by a private maintenance
company unless the council adopts it if
the maintenance company goes into
administration the site will be
contracted to a new maintenance company
residents will pay a surcharge to the
maintenance company and several of them
will be appointed to its board this
would ensure the maintenance throughout
the lifetime of the development i hope
that just just sort of helps emphasize
that a little bit more
thank you okay thank you mr dicker while
you're there and i have both you and mr
travis on the screen
the uh in your uh
position statement you made before or
after christmas or certainly it's a
submission that you've made anyway you
suggested a condition
uh one of the suggested amendments in
addition to the conditions by the rule
six party that you provided
and this was a suggested condition
about
tivoli brooke
in the uh given your concerns about what
you've just been touching upon about the
uh lack of knowing who is actually
responsible for it outside of the
site mr travis have you had a chance to
actually i know we're not in a
conditions debate today but as we're
discussing surface water and discussing
to volleybrook it might be sort of
sensible to
to ask you about it now have you had a
chance to see that condition
i haven't got permission i've got the
position statement um but i haven't
actually seen
the condition itself and the only
so it might not be the position
statement then it was a
i don't know when it came i can't
remember but it was it was suggested
amendments and additions by the rule six
party
maybe you've not actually you may not
have been passed it yet
um
if colleagues can direct me to where it
is on their
um
the suggested conditions that might help
and what i would say and sir is in terms
of conditions for looking at off-site
assets um
i think it's very difficult to put that
on the developer for this site to look
at an
asset that's off site that they can't
have any control on
um
i i think
i think
perhaps it's something for kcc
and um and suarez to discuss but it's i
don't see that in terms of this
development
why you would put a condition on us for
for an asset that's sort of off site not
in our control i don't see how it could
be enforceable
i if i could um just say that
i think that the point that we're making
is is that the brook runs through the
site
and we have been told by kcc
and and quite clearly kcc tdc and
southern water don't want to take up any
ownership and the the um advice from kcc
is that given that southern water and
tdc can't agree and that they certainly
won't then it will fall into the hands
of the owners of the land and those
houses are on that land
so
i really one of the conditions that
we've put on is that we really need to
ascertain who has has ownership of that
disputed brook
otherwise you run the risk of of putting
tenants or householders into a situation
that we're finding at the moment with
credit that they may have to pay out
large sums of money
should
should um
there be any problem issues with the
proof
i think at very least we feel that um
that and i know that's not in your your
gifts and in your remit but at very
least we feel that we there should be
some identification of ownership of that
brook
it's not disputed
uh it's
disputed in our view for a very good
reason
mr mr williams did you want to add
something at this point in response
i was just going to suggest sir that
that sounds like something that's
probably best revisited in the condition
session
um
i'm not sure and it would be helpful
just to possibly speak about whether
there's any
um
confusion or disagreement about the
culverted section of the brook and the
brook moore more generally
okay because
and one of my questions actually was um
i'm not sure i should i'm not sure
there's agreement but it doesn't sound
like there is agreement on where the
actual brook
goes and where it particularly inside
the site so i'm not sure if there's an
actual i'm not sure it's actual drawing
that's actually showing where it goes
outside of the site but certainly not
inside the site but just some
our understanding um is that it runs
down the valley and then out next to the
cricket club that's why it floods
regularly at the cricket club
then under house down road uh and that's
why it floods regularly at heartstown
road then into what is described as the
catchment area which is the old boating
lake that used to be on site there
and kcc in their report refer to that
now as a possible catchment area for for
the brook
um the dispute i think is whether the
culvert still exists which would have
run under uh tivoli park avenue
um
my contention would be that the
catchment area stretched under tiffany
park avenue indeed under mirgate which
is the uh housing estate just the other
side of the tennis courts
now given
if the if the brook runs down that
valley and that's been our belief from
that strong um local knowledge if the
brook runs down that valley then who has
ownership of that and that's very
important for future tenants if the bill
does go ahead
i think just to to just sort of
help separate that issue from a
hydrological point of view um when we're
referring to it it's coming down the
valley and through the site it's more of
what we call the federal water course
that's not a water cost that's flowing
all to all the time it's a pluvial flow
route
and that through the centre of the sites
in in the sort of public open space as
it comes into tivoli park as you're
mentioning through uh tilly park avenue
that's the point where
it in code document 7.01 of november the
19th 2021 that's the point where kent
county council was saying that they
looked and it had been
the watercourse had been separated or or
cut off at some point so in terms of
when it's within the site it's not
physically a brook within the site
because it's only overland flow coming
over land whereas when it goes into a
culvert or an actual river that's
flowing all the time it becomes a water
course and that's why um if you look in
the flood risk assessment
and i'll try and direct you to the right
page um
um
within a couple of the figures within my
section
three
specifically around
it's the right one when i get around to
6.3.6.2 on page 18
you can see the environment agency river
map
and also um figure 3.11 which is the map
of watercourses it doesn't show a
watercourse through the middle of the
site but whereas when you look at the
pluvial in drawing 8.1 etc you see the
pluvial flow through the middle and i
think that's where the difference is
coming when kcc as the lead local flood
authority are talking to
to the residents association that
they're differentiating based on the
technical terms we use between
watercourse and pluvial flow route i
think that's where the difference is
coming from
i hope that helps
okay thank you so i understand so yes
it's not a
it's not effectively an underground
water coast through the site it's a
as you put it fluvial air flow route
which incorporates sort of water
draining across the site is that without
going for a particular channel
that's pluvial with a p
pluvial right
yes pluvial water is what is sort of
excess water that comes on the land and
flows off where it's fluvial with an f
um is where it's within a river
okay hydrology
okay
i'm i'm happy to take consideration of
uh
mr dickman's or the royal six party's
condition forward to the conditions
session
uh later in the week uh i just thought
i'd flag it up at this point
mainly make to make sure that
mr travis you're you're aware of it
obviously so your views are probably
going to be sort of
uh useful in that respect as well so i'm
happy to take that forward as part of
the conditions discussion
any further
questions
right we've got mrs
brown
yeah thank you hello um i just wanted to
ask with regards to the climate um
emergency
the um standards that you're working to
um
are in government and
what the government requires what
planning requires i'm just curious to
know when this was put in place and
sort of
how can we be sure that given the sort
of what happened in europe this year
that they're going to be sufficient for
for this development
yeah thank you mrs brown um climate
change has been included within flood
risk and floodless calculations for a
long time now and it is regularly
reviewed as part of the nppf and
planning guide um the current 40
allowance for surface water drainage was
i can't for the exact day it was around
2016 2017 that was put in place
and earlier this year the environment
agency reviewed climate change
and with regard to river flooding and
they've left the drainage at 40 percent
so what i can say is it is regularly
viewed if you think about a one to one
hundred year event
forty percent is almost half as much
again
um so in in my opinion i do think that's
quite a a reasonable level of climate
change to be
applied thank you thank you
and just one addition to that what year
does that take us to
oh it's the lifetime of the development
so
why was it 70 years
i think it's 70 years now but i don't
want to come back to you on that sir
i think it's 70 years for residential
development i i would need to check in
the guidance
okay that's that's fine if you can check
yeah it's just for
but my note
okay
thank you
right that i think is all the questions
just one or two for interesting parties
just one or two things from
my
self i think i'm writing saying this
just to make sure that i'm writing the
same way you showed us the the one of
the drawings earlier on
showing that the areas that were
liable to flood within the site and
there's talk about sequential approach
and that all the built development would
be uh outside of those areas is is that
and in terms of the master plan is that
all the built development so that would
that would be all the houses proposed on
this particular part of the the site
plus plus garaging or whatever else as
well
yeah that um well obviously at the
moment you've just got an indicative
layouts here so all that you can
demonstrate the minute is that the land
the parcels that have shown a indicative
layout would be outside of that zone the
only areas of
when i refer to built development i'm
talking about dwelling houses um
the only areas that cross the blue
floodplain of the roads that we
identified and in those locations um
within
section five which is mitigation within
the flood risk assessment i explain how
the roads will use box culverts to
bridge
um over that pluto flooding because that
doesn't occur all the time
it's
it's only on extreme events
okay thank you um
and is is that one of the
suggested conditions because as you say
there's this is outline at the moment so
layout is a reserved matter for future
consideration if
is that something that could be
controlled by conditioner is that
something that this would be left for
the local authority to consider when it
considers any future reserve matters
application
just really mike
um
from my um
it could be conditioned that it's
outside of the one in one thousand it's
not in the suggested condition that i
have
um but but quite clearly if you were to
put dwelling houses within
areas that are at flood risk it shows
that when somebody
somebody goes to buy it on a title
search so it's not within the developers
best interest to put houses within flood
zones because you can't sell them
if that makes sense
okay
subject to discussion with colleagues
i'd see no reason as to why that
couldn't be conditioned
okay i'm not suggesting myself just
interesting to know what's being
proposed and maybe maybe actually mr
when we go forward to the conditions
discussion that's something the council
sort of
wants to consider mr livingstone if you
comment on that later on at our session
mainly in terms of well actually if it's
not a condition is it something that the
local planning authority would clearly
look at when it considers that
application i assume it would do but
then is that necessarily
the uh that the case so
if that can be carried forward to the
conditions discussion
and then again on this point about that
area of if you like sort of greater risk
where i think you've said in your proof
that
that would prevent development in
areas that have a greater than moderate
risk of
flooding does that still mean that some
moderate flooding
might still occur
and if that is the case what does
moderate
okay i'm out too um
the best way to explain this
is if you look at drawing eight
eight point four of the flood risk
assessment
okay bear with me because yeah it's
gonna be a little while to find down the
air
the document
while you're there i'll just look up
that climate change allowance for you
and so i can answer that date
right 8.4 did you say
that's right yes sir so
what you can see there is what we call
this is the environment agency surface
water
hazard rating uh with 1 000 a year
sorry i'm not i'm not there yet my
computer's just showing my pages uh
so is that paragraph 8.4 or it's it's
drawing 8.4 sorry 8.4 so that's in the
batch of drawings at the end that's
right
i think it's from page 90 something
sir it's page 69 of the pdf 69 of the
pdf thank you uh
i've resorted to paper hence
everything laid out in front of me
i can't actually see the page numbers on
the document that i've got uh
well let's see oh sorry so if you if you
go up on the pdf viewer
at the top yeah
there'll be
so many of 184 yeah so if you just type
in 69 there it should take you to it 69
oh i see
right the environmental surface water
a thousand-year hazard rating yeah so so
what we've done here is i'm i'm looking
at quite an extreme event greater than
we would normally do for the
um
for the 100 what you can see on the
right-hand side of the key we've got
extreme household significant hazard and
moderate hazard
and what they effectively do is look at
a combination of depth and velocity
so when you have extreme hazard that's
the sort of thing that the fiber gain
won't go into
and that can cause sort of danger to
life yeah um so so that's where we're
proposing that we wouldn't want any
development in there and you can see how
thin it is through the center of the
site sir um that that's where we're
limiting to that because that's the real
extreme hazard does that make sense
yeah i see so okay
so the area that says in yellow which is
the moderate hazard yeah we're outside
of that as well so you're outside of
that i see okay you're outside of that
right
i think that's within um
i can reference the page in the fra we
say that if that helps
um i think you see that in better detail
on drawing 11 actually because i've
overlaid that on top
okay what page is that
in terms of your pdf
this would be good
what were we on before we were 69 70
it's about 72 i think
72 now 75 actually yeah
because there's some black pages in
there as well yeah
75 yeah yeah
right oh yes that that drawing i
remember that drawing from before
surface water flooding uh outline
overlay
and if you go to in the flood risk
assessment section 5.2 page 26 and 27
that's where i describe the mitigation
measures
and just help with your notes
okay thank you
and um colleagues just help me with the
climate change question you asked
um so it's the total percentage
change anticipated for the 2080s
covering the years from 20 70 twenty one
fifteen
okay say that again
okay it's the total percentage change
anticipated for the 2080s yeah well
that's covering the years twenty seventy
to twenty
15.
if if you like i can send you the
government guidance reference where
that's from if that helps as well um
no it's probably no
okay
no need to but thank you so effectively
it's my sort of basic understanding that
that 40 pack 40 allowance would take it
to 2115
yeah that's right
that's the upper end
that's your friend yet okay
i see
okay just bear with me because lots of
the points i think that i was going to
ask have actually been raised through
questions in the discussion that has
taken place so that is
useful uh
[Music]
another matter actually which i'll rate
now but can be answered in the
conditions discussion is that in the
condition on i don't actually know which
condition it is it must be the condition
requesting details of surface water
uh flooding management et cetera it
relates to
i think on a pace on a per phase burst
basis
rather than the whole development
and
if it's done
as i understand it on a phase by phase
basis could that in any way jeopardize
the overall effectiveness of a
comprehensive site-wide approach i.e in
fact the first phase is done and it has
its
water drainage measures put in which
might be work for that phase
would that would such a perhaps
incremental approach jeopardize what
could be a better system if it was done
comprehensively
so
i.e
i'll be approved before the entire
development starts rather than allowing
one bit to start and then the rest
typically if we were looking at a
discharge to a water course you'd say
yes because you need to control
construct the balance in poland before
it discharges but because we're looking
to ground
a lot of this will be done through
individual plots okay so you could do it
in terms of phases the highway is
drained as one section and then other
parts so it's not as much of an issue
when we look at infiltration
because they're done in in sort of
individual parcels anyway
it's more of a concern really where
you've got say a balancing pond for a
whole development that you need to put
it in at the beginning because you're
discharging to a river but here because
you've got so many diffuse features
because it's groundwater
through infiltration it's not as
difficult
okay thank you
okay um a note for mr livingstone if
you're sort of happy with that then uh
let me let me know when we get to the
conditions discussion uh later in the
the week
thank you
okay uh
we've dealt with that
okay that actually i think everything's
been covered off that i was going to
ask so
thank you
for that is there anything else before
mr
travis
leaves us or certainly leaves this part
of the agenda that anybody wishes to
to raise
so can i just flag as well as a point
for the condition session you'll have
seen that certain of the conditions
relate to
tying in the parameters plan and the
development framework plan
and
we can deal with it in conditions but
that's
consistent with the approach that mr
travis has been explaining to
leaving certain areas of the site where
there's pluvial flooding undeveloped
okay thank you
okay
thank everybody for all your
questions they've been helpful for my
understanding
as well and thank you for your responses
mr
travis obviously i'll take all the uh
what's been said forward to consider
when i come to making the
the decision so thank you
everybody
uh
right that is
item number four
so we're getting to so the next item
is item five which is on biodiversity
which we include there's two parts of
this really
there may be to a degree interrelated
but there's the first part on the
effects upon the thames coast and
sandwich based special protection area
which i've got to consider uh as the
competent authority irrespective of if
the council sort of still objects or not
and then we get on to perhaps what i can
call them the sites more site-specific
concerns
on breeding birds and bats etc
as i don't want to finish any later than
five o'clock
uh
we've got two options
we haven't finished for the day now
or we try and do the first part of it
which is the thames coast and sandwich
bay special protection
area
discussion which i think i might be
wrong but i think might be the shorter
of the two
parts because i've got
shadow appropriate assessments being
submitted i've got up-to-date
consultation responses from tens
from thames from the uh
from natural england
and uh
i've got quite a lot of written
submissions and various documents that
have been sent over the past
few weeks which are very helpful to me
in terms of going to do my competent my
uh appropriate assessment as a competent
authority
so
if all the parties are here and i see we
already have miss caldwell sort of
waiting
to
contribute
is everyone happy that we do that first
part of it
and
on the special protection area and then
we leave
the other site specific things most
specifically breeding birds and bats for
tomorrow morning at 9 30 when we start
so that's certainly
fine by us i mean as you say the
position in relation to the appropriate
assessment
from our perspective is is
just making sure that you've
understood
what we've done and where you can find
the relevant material and as my learning
friend referred to in his opening
yeah there is
case law and um
we
submit that our assessments compliant
with that but obviously
i view this first part as an opportunity
for you to explore
with us
um
where the information is that you need
in order to reach the conclusion that
we're asking you to reach
yeah that seems that seems sensible
along the lines of what i was going to
ask i've got a series of
questions which really follow the uh
draft agenda that i set out sent out
last week
uh with the various questions is
everyone else happy with that that we we
do this one before
but i think it's probably a good use of
time that we do rather than
any sort of time we could say
helpful
um
so in terms of the first part of the
discussion this is just on the thames
coast and sandwich bay spa and of course
ramsar sites
who would like to contribute
to
this
um
well obviously sir
i provided the uh shadow hra so i can
run through that as you wish
okay yeah absolutely and
mr livingstone you you you've appeared
and i'm sure your contribution will be
helpful yes as as necessary if you have
any questions on it for the local
authority sir okay thank you and would
anybody else like to contribute to this
part of the discussion
okay
no okay um
the the other thing about this is that
i've well actually now we've got i've
got a copy of the draft
106 that came in yesterday which i've
not actually had a chance to to to see
yet i was preparing more for other
things last night so i'm not a chance to
consider
that anything that arises from that i
will have to uh to to raise it another
time
but
and i think it can be taken as read in
terms of the submissions that you've put
in including your proof of evidence miss
caldwell and your
shadow appropriate assessment that's
been done so i don't need you just to go
over
that as as we did for drainage for
example i'm happy for you just to
respond to a few questions that i have
got unless there's anything sort of
burning in terms of introductory
comments that you've
that you've written down you want to
sort of say i'm happy that everything in
your british submissions has been taken
as read so if we go through the order of
things in my
uh agenda
from section
two
could you just
briefly
uh
describe the qualifying features
of the relevant
protected areas
i know some of this is going over your
proof so i'm just like guess what i've
said but i think it's probably just
useful to sort of set the
scene as we go
yes certainly sir so um
for the
planet coast and sandwich bay spa
there are three qualifying features
which are internationally important
breeding populations of little turn and
golden plover
and internationally important wintering
populations of turnstone
and
with regards to the ramsar designation
that we consider as well
criterion two of the ramsar
relates to the site supporting 15
species of british red data book
invertebrates
uh three of which are endangered and
criterion six um the site supports an
internationally important wintering
population of turnstone
all of that is detailed within my shadow
hra
which forms
appendix c of my proof of evidence
and in the shadow hra appendix c
table c2 and c3
c2 and c 3 yes thank you
okay
and then
mr livingstone feel free to chip in if
you disagree with any of of this or if
there's anything else you want to to
moving on to be
then
i think it's agreed that there is
a potential for like a significant
effect what would those significant
effects be and where would they come
from in terms of this this development
obviously in combination with other
developments as well but what does
specific likely significant effects
arise from
yes so the likely significant effects
concerned with these designations are
disturbance from recreational impacts
and there have been various studies
undertaken and a
zone of influence of 7.2 kilometers has
been identified in thanet for new
residential development that could give
rise to these disturbance effects
either alone or in combination with
other plans and projects
okay seven kilometers
7.2 7.2 okay
um there are other
potential impact pathways that we
considered as part of the screening
exercise within the shadow hra
that include consideration of
the site itself as functionally linked
land to the spa so
one of the qualifying features golden
plover are known to
come up on high tide and forage on
agricultural land
along the coast
and our winter bird survey work together
with
previous survey work undertaken to
inform the local plan
looked at whether the site formed
functionally linked land for gold and
plover
um
that work confirmed that we didn't
weren't recording gold and plover
foraging and roosting on our site and
therefore we screened that impact
pathway out
that is detailed in appendix d of my
shadow hra
table d2 for the spa and table d3 for
the ramsar
okay
let's move on to section c proposed
mitigation measures
including strategic access management
and monitoring plan an on-site
provision
if you could go into some more detail on
what those
measures
are
and then we'll move on to the sort of
the particularly important bit about
how would those measures be
uh
secured because obviously as a competent
authority i'd need to be absolutely
clear that the measures would be are not
only being proposed but they'd actually
be
secured
in the future and obviously things like
the money being spent by the council on
the correct things uh at the right time
to serve this development so yeah if you
could start by going through the actual
sort of substance of the proposed
mitigation measures again mr livingston
you want to add anything then please do
as well
so in line with policy sp 29 of the
local plan
um development within the seven point
residential development within the 7.2
zone of influence area is required to
make financial contribution
to the strategic access management and
monitoring program which is already
underway
um this scheme has been supported by
natural england
and the various local authorities
within the zone of influence of atlantic
coast
there is a tariff set out within sp 29
for these financial contributions and
that they would be secured by a section
106 agreement
so
i believe we have the draft of that
agreement now and those sam's
contributions will be set out within
that document
okay and that's within the actual
section 106 agreement not in any
unilateral undertaking is that is that
right
i believe so
so yes that's that's right okay
because the reason i asked that is it
ones where they're in the unilateral
undertaking there's always the question
of well what how is the council bound in
terms of how they actually spend them
the money on the correct the correct
things but if that's within the
section 106 as drafted agreements then
that could hopefully give some surety in
that
regard okay
okay
yes schedule schedule six contains
the
requirement to pay the
sam contribution
and in schedule eight
there's
a covenant given by the council
to use the money for the purposes for
which they were
paid
okay
okay thank you
any other questions sir with regards to
the
sam's payments
no uh let me just think um
it could be a question more from mr
livingstone but for either of you so
just thinking through the processes of
this
the obviously if this is if the appeal
was allowed
the
section 106 would be applicable the
monies would be spent by the council
the council will uh spend the money on
the appropriate mitigation set out in
the uh strategic access management and
monitoring plan which i've got a copy of
that so no need to go into sort of much
more detail
on that
what is in place to make sure
that
the relevant measures are put in
uh if you like before
the development is occupied
is there some sort of ongoing process to
allow for there must be a sort of lag
between what section one sixes etc and
uh things being done on the actual site
in terms of what's needed so can you
sort of provide some more yes thank you
thank you sir um in terms of what we
look at with with all residential
developments because this triggers on
every single scheme for one or more
dwellings and we we secure these
contributions um the tariff has been
based on in perpetuity
uh i suppose payment for the the amount
of population or that's expected to come
out the housing developments to 2030
link to the local plan
uh what that means is that we have a
sort of pot of money that keeps being
topped up and used for this particular
project
for this development itself
one of the things that's been put
forward in the 106 is obviously a
trigger for when the contribution is
paid
linked to the phases of development as
as has been submitted
which would mean that prior to
occupation
of dwellings on each phase we would
receive the the contribution for the
whole phase
which would then go into the project
to be able to then be spent in relation
to the sams
oh sorry sir you're on mute
apologies um
and what
what internal arrangements
and procedures or whatever it might be i
know it's in the 106 which the councils
will be uh presumably signing up to but
what internal arrangements and
procedures are in place that the
council's got to ensure that the money
will be spent
at the right time on the right the right
things
to ensure that
that
an adverse effect is uh prevented in
this case
so it's an ongoing is this an ongoing
project um what the project uh it's
actually a joint project between um
district council and canterbury city
council
and what it means is that there's
uh an ongoing assessment of basically
the money that's held by both councils
which is then pooled into the project
itself which is the the birdwise east
kent group now there are quarterly
meetings in place uh which include
senior management from both authorities
includes a project officer who
specifically employed to to manage the
project it's got two engagement officers
that do the same
are involved in that same way as well as
natural england who are also part of the
project and sit on in the quarterly
meetings as well um so in terms of the
budget itself it's actually it's it's
sort of dealt with in that forum in
terms of internally and our own measures
just as we do with all 106 contributions
see when they are submitted to the
council they are they are stored
separately from other other financial
amounts that come into the council
and kept on uh on a record that then
basically would release them as as and
when necessary and requested by the
relevant department in this instance
it's the strategic planning team
that effectively um
you know are managing the project as as
it goes forward
okay
thank you and we've already heard a bit
about other developments that are going
on or proposed
how does the uh
what is the ongoing process because
obviously it's the incarnation effects
that have to be considered not just the
effects from the site itself how are the
other developments that are being
proposed or being allocated how is
everything sort of updated to reflect
those and to make sure that the actual
uh
works that are being done if you like
sort of keeps up to date with the
possible impacts that might result yeah
being successful yes um so um one of the
bits that the work is is doing is
there's ongoing monitoring and survey
work through the
the birdwise and east king um project
um basically to to assess visitor
numbers and bird numbers uh which then
were linked then links and feeds back
into where the wardening occurs um you
know going through on a you know a
yearly basis and the um
i i must admit i don't know if it's in
the shadow hra that the appellant has
submitted but certainly in rhr it's made
mention of the most recent survey work
that has been uh that's that's that's
actually
been apparent for that
um in terms of how it sort of feeds into
the in combination effect
obviously when the the sort of tariff
was set through the sam's work uh was
when
uh the new uh housing number in the
local plan was set um at a few years ago
obviously as things develop that will
need to be reviewed if in through the
local plan process in the future there
are changes to that uh which would mean
mean that there's a set of work would
need to be done to you know reset that
tariff as appropriate uh to ensure but
it's uh it's a sort of cyclical nature
of assessments you know and changing the
project to ensure that the basically
that the bird population doesn't dig
doesn't decline
as it was doing from
2013 uh through um and it's you know
slowed down in rate but obviously um
survey work that's been going on at the
moment um is sort of slowing down the
rates but obviously we're publishing
yearly survey work now
as
now the whole uh the project is actually
sort of fully staffed almost
okay thank you
there's a hand gone up miss bowers have
you got something you wanted to say at
this point
yes give me if you don't mind i know i
haven't put my name forward but i just
want to ask questions about the sam
payment if you don't mind since that's
what's under discussion at the moment
would that be okay that's fine um my
understanding is the sound payments
covers disturbance for birds at the
coast
my question is around
what is mitigation then for loss of
functional land which is actually inland
from the coast because i i don't believe
sam's payments covered that but i i
could have that wrong so that that's my
question really
could i come back and address that
point um
in fact uh mrs bowers um
i covered that when i was talking about
functionally linked land in terms of the
assessment that we did within our shadow
hra
so in terms of function link land we
look at
how the site itself the habitats on the
site could be used by species which form
qualifying features of the spa and
ramsar
that really boils down to golden plover
in this instance because they will use
land away from the coast for foraging
and roosting
so we undertook
winter bird survey work 2019 2020 winter
during which we didn't record golden
plover using our site
um there was some previous survey work
done to inform the local plan
allocations
that was 2016 2017 which included our
site
and
there was no golden pleather recorded
using our site for foraging or boosting
either
that information um
is provided within our winter bird
survey report which formed an appendix
of the environmental statements
and we have had consultation with
natural england on that point
um and
as a result of that they raised no
objection to our conclusion that the
site does not form functionality land so
as such is screened out of
further appropriate assessment within
the shadow hra
does that address your
concern
um if i come back with a couple of
points initially natural england
actually did raise concerns about the
winter bird surveys
um they said that they there was only
one winter covered um where there should
be at least two and that the cropping
regime at the time the survey was
carried out was actually wrong for
golden clover so it wouldn't have
attracted those birds
the other point i'd make is the golden
clubber doesn't always come back to the
same land so just because you didn't see
it during your surveys doesn't mean that
it doesn't use it
and the third point i'd make is with
reference to um the inspectors uh
question around cumulative effect and
impact it's not only this land that
we're losing unfortunately we're losing
an awful lot of other functional land
and if we want to consider the
cumulative impact then we need to
consider the impact of loss of all this
functional land on the golden plover not
just this site
okay thank you i'll try and come back to
those comments in order
um first with regards to the initial
comments from natural england with
regards to one versus two years worth of
winter survey data um that's correct
they provided a consultation response
querying that
we provided a rebuttal statement to
natural england to clarify the volume of
um winter bird survey information that
we considered when making our assessment
that did include just one winter of
survey work undertaken by ourselves but
also considered
um the data presented to inform the
local plan
um and to inform natural england's
own mitigation
um
assessment for the planet coast
so
um
as set out within our
rebuttal statement that that included
surveys over 2016 2017 winter further
surveys undertaken on separate dates
during 2017
and our winter survey data 2019 2020. so
um they were
content with that
um and there was no further objection um
with regards to the cropping regime
we also went back and looked at the
cropping regime and provided as much
evidence as we could for the historical
cropping regime on that site
and provided evidence that in fact
golden plover do use fallow fields and
stubble which was a situation when we
undertook our surveys on the site
um and
natural england
accepted that in fact it was one of the
conclusions that came out of the
monitoring survey work that they had
instructed
to inform the local plan that actually
golden plover will use uh
fields when they're in that part of the
cropping regime
um so
those points were addressed with natural
england and they were satisfied with
that um
in relation to in combination effects
of course we consider in combination
effects as
part of the shadow hra assessments
and cumulative effects as part of the es
um
we can't have an in combination effect
with other development
if we're not recording our site being
used by golden plover so i take your
point that other development in the
local area that golden pleather are
using
may have an effect on that qualifying
feature of the spa
but
our site cannot be considered to have a
in combination effect because
we have demonstrated that gold and
plover are not are not using the
habitats on this site
i don't think i can go any further um
i hope that addresses your points
it answers the questions but i still
have concerns about the golden plumber
just because you didn't see them doesn't
mean they don't use it
it's the nature of surveys i guess and
the land is perfect for golden plumber
there's no reason why it shouldn't be
there why would it be on land just
around the corner but not on this land
so i appreciate you may not be able to
answer that but
that is the limit of surveys
and i would return to the point that the
sam's mitigation will not mitigate for
internal
loss of internal land just to be clear
on that it only mitigates the
disturbance at the coast just
to ensure as i think hopefully you agree
with that
yes that that is a good point of
clarification thank you
okay thank you what is the matter is
obviously for me to consider in
further details part of my decision um
and thank you for those uh questions and
submissions uh miss bozen
in that respect mr dickman have you got
something you'd like uh thank you sir um
just really to clarify is the hra now
uh out of date as it only looks at the
impact
loss of 350 hectares whereas now it's
close to 700 and likely to grow
sorry i lost that last bit do you want
to repeat the question mr dickman
it's is is the hra out of date now
because it looks the impact of loss of
just 350 hectares
of latin when we know
this is now to be closer to 700 hectares
are you talking about in combination
yeah
well in terms of
the impact pathways that we've
identified
um
that would not have a bearing so in
terms of the in combination effects at
the coast
there is this uh obviously there's sp 29
which deals with the in combination
effects through the sam payments
and any new residential com coming
development coming forward will have to
pay into that scheme
and therefore
um those effects will be mitigated
with regards to functionally linked land
as i've just described
we cannot consider in combination
effects of
um loss of any function like land
because
our survey data and historical data that
we have i.e
the best event information that we have
available has not indicated that our
site is being
used by golden plot of ad function link
land
so
um
i don't think those points have a
bearing on the impact pathways that we
have identified
thank you
um there was one final point about the
mitigation that i just wanted to clarify
which was um the provision of um
immunity space public open space within
the development itself
um and that that to a degree
um
mitigates for some of the visitor
related impact from our site alone
um that might be expected at the coast
i.e for you know
daily dog walking uh things like that
and as that out within appendix e of the
shadow hra and we have provided um a
note about um
the amount of pos and the type of pos
provision
and that will be provided as part of the
scheme
um and that is over above the policy
requirements and um
also considered as mitigation in
relation to the stanley case spa
provision of that would be secured
through any planning consent or
condition
right that was going to be my question
how would it be
how would that be secured to ensure that
i as the
compton authority could be sure that is
carried forward obviously the game that
looks a bit like a discussion on
flooding obviously the local authority
will be able to look at that but in
terms of my position
making the appropriate assessment
needing to be you know absolutely sure
uh i'll certainly be honest with
scientific how how would that be how
could that be secured or how has that
been proposed to be secured
there are a number of planning
conditions that have been suggested
relating to the green infrastructure
provision
and also the
landscaping provision in terms of
type and quantum
and therefore i would expect
the planning conditions to secure that
provision
okay and i suggest we look at those in
detail as part of the conditions
uh session
later in the week
thank you mr livingston were you going
to have an influence on it it was to um
to say pretty much the same point as as
ms caldwell so that's that's fine thank
you sir
okay thank you
okay thank you uh and i think item e is
the further consultation response from
natural england
which i've now received in fact there's
been two as we was explained earlier and
i don't think there's anything
that i need to ask myself i don't think
from what i've read uh
anything else you want to make in
response to that or don't need to do it
there's not
uh i think that seems clear
okay um
are there any other relevant matters in
terms of
this part of the discussion on
biodiversity in relation to the sba and
ramsar habitat's regulations that
anybody else wants to
to to raise before we
close this part of the discussion
no thank you sir
okay
okay good thank you for those
clarifications thank you for the various
documents that have been put in which
i'm sure are going to be helpful to me
uh
when and if i need to do
an appropriate
assessment so thank you
thank you
sir okay that takes us to five o'clock
or just after so i think it's time to
adjourn
tomorrow morning if we can start at
9 30
as mentioned earlier
and we'll proceed with the second part
of the biodiversity
uh
discussion and this is particularly in
terms of the effects upon breeding birds
and bats and i think if anyone's not
seen it i have sent out a as a suggested
agenda which i think is on the council's
website mr livingstone uh
and uh we'll start that sort of soon
after 9 30. if first thing in the
morning as well we can just have an
update on any various things that are
outstanding and i think two we'll have a
little discussion on a sort of an
outline timetable for the rest of the
week if we can so with the
two advocates and can have a little sort
of think about how long you're expecting
the various discussions etc to take
obviously i'll give that some
consideration as well and we'll have a
sort of an outline program to see where
we're going to go in terms of the number
of days required etc and we'll do that
first thing quite briefly i think
okay thank you
okay thank you everybody for all your
helpful contributions today uh
i'll now adjourn the inquiry and we'll
recommence tomorrow morning at 9 30.
thank you and just on that obviously the
virtual room if you can come into the
virtual room
before 9 30 so as today you're all in
the room when i enter the room at 9 30
so we can
get on straight away okay good evening
everybody thank you thank you very much
you